Thank you.
All right, it's 9.06 or so, and I'm going to call the House Judiciary Committee to order.
And first, please stand and join me in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation, under God and I'm gonna call the prime sponsor representative jr hool good morning everybody representative whole excuse me serving the towns of dunbarton hooks at allenstown and epsom here in support of houseville 1664.
um hooks at allenstown and epsom here in support of house bill 1664.
the bill before you um expands some of the options available to those who choose to detransition why do i say that we currently have in our laws medical malpractice options we have them for for lots of could be someone had a surgery a friend had a hernia surgery and the mesh they put in created unintended consequences this is routine we do this all the time the difference we're talking about here is we have a minor who may or may not have consented, and I'll come back to that point, to various drugs along the way, or medications, or even surgery, who then potentially years later, excuse me, finds out that there were some unintended consequences of what they did.
Now, in the state of New Hampshire, we limit what miners can do.
I'm going to pass out a bill that passed in this house in 2015.
We decided in 2016, or sorry, 2015, because some young woman had cancer resulting from tanning, that we would prohibit going to tanning booths at age 18.
And that passed, became law.
House Bill 136, I'm sending it around right now.
Why does that matter?
We realized as a legislature that minors don't have certain cognitive skills necessary to make really difficult decisions.
And in this case, that was relative to tanning.
Now, I voted against that bill because I believe there could be compelling reasons that a minor may want to go to a tanning salon prior to a prom or whatever else.
There might be medical reasons to go to a tanning salon.
But at the end of the day, this legislature and the Senate and the governor agree that this was a good prohibition to have in place.
if we're going to prohibit something as mundane as scanning for minors, theoretically, we could prohibit something as significant as surgery.
This pill doesn't do that, though.
I don't like to try and prohibit things with the use of government.
I don't know that that's the appropriate use sometimes.
I think it makes more sense to make sure the playing field is level between the patient and the provider, such that when they learn about the unintended consequences of some of the decisions, they have legal options later on in life.
We already have, under RSA 507E, right, a cause-based system relative to medical injury.
All this bill is doing is extending it to those who might realize later on in life that they had permanent harm relative to the procedures they received as a minor.
The important point in all of this is we're talking about minors who are making lifelong medical decisions, and we don't allow minors that level of authority in anything else.
We've determined as a society, 18 is the age where someone now is legally able to consent to something.
So in the case of minors who have, quote, consented, unquote, to whether it's medical treatments, whether it's medical surgery, they may not have the cognitive skills necessary to understand what they have been told to do or allowed to do.
Who is liable during that period of time?
Is it the provider?
Is it the parent?
There's an adult somewhere in that room who is making, is signing a piece of paper because the minor can't sign that piece of paper to say yes for seed.
This allows that minor their only shot at getting a chance to address any unintended harm from what happened.
Cutting off testosterone or estrogen doesn't seem like a big deal, but theoretically, that could have real long-term effects to the patient or to the minor as they grow up when their reproductive organs haven't fully developed or have developed incorrectly.
Obviously, transition surgery potentially causes real harm by cutting off functional body parts to the point where this person may not be able to ever have children.
We might sterilize these minors before they're an adult.
I think they have, they deserve the right to address that issue.
This bill just goes through, it creates the definitions necessary to be clear about what you can do relative to cross-sex hormones, transition surgery, medical detransition, and puberty blocking drugs.
And then in 507E7e and this is page two it starts to allow for the minor to have access to a longer time period necessary to figure out if there was harm done and i did it with a fixed date as opposed to after it like they start their detransition because that's a little bit more nebulous in my eyes than this here which is they get they get to their mid-30s well late 30s and i said that because the average age that not the average age the top end of the age where children where adults are now having children is in their late 30s That's where society has moved.
My wife and I had our children in our early 30s, but unfortunately as society has moved on, a number of parents are having their children in their late 30s.
If it's only then when the child has a chance to learn that maybe they're sterile, maybe there's unintended consequences, and they're having trouble having children, why can't they then go back to their provider and ask for some remuneration because what happened to them as a minor sterilized them?
So in summary, the bill takes our current law and allows those who would like to seek detransition because of some harm a chance to get a level playing field with the provider that happened along the way that's about it um i can answer any questions specifically to the legislation if necessary all right Kutub.
Can you please point to me where it states that this only applies to a minor?
Because the way I'm seeing it, this applies to anybody, including a 50-year-old adult, except that a 50-year-old would have a three-year statute of limitations and a minor would have 20 years from the time that they turn 21.
You're correct.
It could apply to anybody.
The biggest issue that we're seeing, and if we need to tweak the legislation a little bit, I want to aim this toward the minors because I don't believe minors have the ability to consent.
They don't have the ability to consent legally to buy a car, to do a bunch of other things, take out a loan, much less have potentially a life-altering surgery.
So I want to focus on that narrow group more so than anybody else.
So if we need to tweak the language, I'm with you.
This extends the time period for minors.
The three years exist today, effectively.
Someone who chose to transition as an adult and then detransition could be could sue under today's laws at least the adult has the ability to make an informed and decision and actually consent the minors don't have that option i don't believe they they can consent at all legally and it's hard to make an informed decision when you're when you're just at i don't know 14 15 16 the ability to make to fully understand and grasp the long-term ramifications of these type decisions yeah follow-up sure so i guess my other question is is that let's say that you were 22 at the time then this bill would apply to say that you would have three years from the time so at that point you'd be 24 why isn't it three years from the time you turn 21 why is it 20 years why is it a different standard for one group and another standard for i interpreted the 20 years um okay the three years exist today this was an extension of 20.
I was trying to get to the late 30s we could say we're on page two line 10 where it says 21 we could make that 18 instead of 21 there which would bring the final age to 38 which was my intent and it's really about the minors who start right who start transition a lot of this transition surgery isn't happening in your 20s a lot of this is happening prior to 20 during the development phase other representative horick i'll make this quick this is more of a would you believe question.
You seem to say that it's just a very new phenomenon for women in their late 30s to give birth, but would you believe that, and this is not an isolated example, that for example my maternal grandmother gave birth to my mother when she was 42, and that was in 1931, so women in their 40s giving birth is is would you believe that's not a new phenomenon and the cutoff date which i mean i'm not sure if i agree with this bill at all but the cutoff date obviously the late 30s is probably younger than when women stop having babies so thank you representative horgan yes i believe that women have children well into their 40s.
The current data shows that there is a growing trend where the first child happens in the mid to late 30s, which is the part I'm talking about.
You don't find out that you're sterile until you start trying to have kids.
And if you don't start trying to have kids until you're mid 30s and it takes a year or two or three to figure out that there's issues, that's why this bill allows for that extended period of time and yes families continue to have children well into their 40s so thank you other questions for this witness yes representative turr yeah thanks and thanks for taking the question um might be a two-part question i as i'm reading this um we're adding this to essentially the claims for what amounts to malpractice.
The issue, as I'm understanding what you're saying, is really not that any sort of standard of care or the current rules regarding consent being properly given, which is what's embodied here in paragraph three, which is the existing rules.
I'm not hearing anything in here that says that any of those things were actually structurally violated.
So we're basically, it sounds like opening the door to having, you know, liability malpractice cases brought, even though all of the rules and standards of care were followed that were in place at the time that that happened.
Is that an accurate reading?
No, it's not.
So a minor can't consent.
Let's all acknowledge in this room that 18 is the age that we as society have determined that Thank you.
No, it's not.
So a minor can't consent.
Let's all acknowledge in this room that 18 is the age that we as society have determined that a minor can consent to something.
So what we're talking about in this case, and this is relatively to Representative Katab's question on line 10, page 2, 21 versus 18.
It should be 18.
Okay.
A minor who is trying to go through this is not signing the paperwork, does not have the insurance.
That's allowing for this surgery.
This is happening around them.
Now it may be done in a very supportive way.
That's fine.
But when the minor becomes an adult years later and finds out harm happened, unintended consequences because they've they've chosen to undo some of this they that's when it triggers that they can they can have access to a liability claim all up yeah one so one follow-up and and again i'm crossing over into another bill before us a little bit um to ask this we heard a bill that was your bill last year last week sorry um you know CROSSING OVER INTO ANOTHER BILL BEFORE US A LITTLE BIT TO ASK THIS.
WE HEARD A BILL THAT WAS YOUR BILL LAST YEAR, LAST WEEK, SORRY, YOU KNOW, WHICH I BELIEVE IS BASED ON THE CONCEPT OF A MINOR BEING GIVEN A PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION AT ITS HEART BUT THEN SORT OF EXPANDED INTO THE HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATION QUESTIONS.
DOES THAT SAME THOUGHT NOT APPLY TO B, are you, are you, am I being clear about what I'm asking here?
No, you're not.
Cause the last bill I was in here had to do with qualified immunity, which was a completely different domain than this.
So I'm not sure what bill you're referencing, but I'll gladly take your question.
If you can get me to a bill number or a title that, that, that it, correct bill and my understanding um is that the underlying concept behind that had to do do with prescription or at its at its outset prescription medication no no the qualified immunity has to do with if a state actor okay chooses to pursue a case in my case we, we had provided medication.
That was the example I used, but the state act, the qualified immunity had to do with the state actor pursuing a case beyond imminent danger.
Imminent danger is measured in minutes, hours, might even be days, but it's definitely not weeks or months.
Okay.
Qualified immunity has to do with the state interfering and acting.
In this case, what we're talking about is completely different.
We're talking about a person who cannot make an informed decision, who cannot legally consent, who then takes and does something or something is done to them, who then finds out years later, there are unintended unintended consequences i don't think there's anybody in this room who wants to sterilize children if you do please raise your hand i'd love to see that group but i don't believe anybody in this room wants to see children sterilized unfortunately that is the net effect of some of these surgeries and i have real concerns i believe we as the adults in the room need to do our best to protect these children from this.
Representative Smith.
Thank you.
Representative, if the physician filed appropriate procedures to do whatever the physician did, and no one's saying that the physician didn't i don't understand why you are suggesting going after the physician rather than after the parent who um okay was who supported uh had to have supported whatever the procedure was it.
Okay.
Who supported, not to have supported, whatever the procedure was that gets you upset here.
That's a great question.
Thank you.
So, I'm going to put.
You know, when people say it's a great question, I don't ever know if they mean it or not.
No, I do.
No, legitimately, it's a great question.
Why the provider versus the parent is the question.
So let's put yourselves in the shoes of a parent who has a child who's a little bit confused right now about what their gender is.
They like hanging out, right?
I have one girl, three boys.
I'm going to take my daughter, for example, right?
She hangs out with her brothers and realizes, you know, being a boy is fun, climbing in the woods, running through the woods, whatever, climbing trees, playing with the dog.
Maybe I am a boy.
That's not what she's decided.
But for a hypothetical, you have a loving parent who wants to do the best thing.
They're not going to be a medical expert about things like unintended consequences.
They're not going to be a medical expert about hormones and the net effect of growth of organs relative to hormones, how many hormones are needed.
They're not going to read the medical journals.
Who's reading the medical journals?
Presumably the provider.
Who's studying this?
Who has the professional expertise?
Presumably the provider.
So in this case, the person who's most knowledgeable in that room that's having this discussion isn't the child or the parent.
It is the provider.
So that's why I think the provider is a better person to hold accountable than the parent, because the parent is trying to love their children.
They're hearing all these things about this might save them from a potential suicide attempt, or it might this gender-affirming care might be the right thing to do, but they don't have any expertise that they bring to the table.
They're relying on the medical professionals as well.
So that's why I think the provider is more liable than the parent.
Other questions for this witness?
Representative DiLorenzo, yes.
Thank you for taking my question.
So what if the child is in an emancipated minor?
Would they be eligible for legal remedies?
I'm not sure what happens to get an emancipated minor.
Do they have full legal rights?
That I don't know.
I'll leave that up to someone who's in this room who might know that better.
maybe the chairman of the committee would know what what rights an emancipated minor has i i can't speak to that may i follow up of course yes certainly now is um medical transitioning is that legal in new hampshire i don't know of any prohibitions.
Thank you.
Other questions for this witness?
So I guess I do have just one question.
I want to sort of follow up on Representative Smith and Representative Turr's questions.
I want to make sure I understand.
Let's suppose in a hypothetical situation that a parent decides that, you know, whether the parent decides that it's okay for their child to have, let's say, transgender surgery.
You know, a child under 18.
And the doctor advises the parents of, you know, every risk under the sun.
You you understand your daughter or maybe it's a son they will not be able to have children you understand that there you understand that there's a risk of x y everything under the sun they advise them and the parents say yep i agree so now the surgery is done yep is it your view that and the sir and let's assume also that that it's legal in those circumstances for the doctor to do the surgery.
Yep.
Is it your view that there is still a cause that the child can say after the child turns 21, I don't care what my parent did, I didn't know all the risks.
And so, doctor, you're liable.
So that's a great example.
And I think this allows for this to go through a court case.
And the court case, the doctor can say, look, I have this signed form.
I asked them to read.
We read through this document verbatim.
It said, line one, that you risk your child being sterile for life.
And the person initialed right after that.
And then we went down and I went through this step by step with them.
And the parents still insisted, judge, I am not liable.
I gave them the best information I had available at the time.
And the parent chose to proceed anyway.
Your honor, I didn't, I didn didn't cause this i didn't sign this paperwork that said yes proceed i gave them all the information necessary for them to say no i encouraged them to say no and they still proceeded anyway okay and so i'm sorry i guess i'm so what happens then the judge so that that so the judge could reject that and say well you might have that, but your child didn't.
Well, no, but what I'm saying is the judge will have that sounds like a great defense in a medical malpractice suit, especially if it's been documented as thoroughly as you've just mentioned, where the judge can look and say, yes, it's clear that this doctor did what he could to prevent this.
And the parents did insisted that this go forward.
I think that's a great case, and that ends the case, presuming the judge is making a balanced decision.
I guess what I'm wondering is if that isn't, rather than sort of expose the doctor to the potential of a lawsuit, isn't what you really want to prevent is you want to prevent people that are minors from being able to consent or for the parents being able to consent.
Isn't that really what you're asking?
But that's a prohibition.
It says that.
So that's a prohibition.
And I said earlier in my testimony, I'm not in favor of strict prohibitions.
I try and tend to avoid that.
I don't know that that's a proper role of government.
In this case, I believe there is real harm for some of these minors.
But I believe the best way to address it is to level the playing field between the patient and the provider, because the provider knows some of these things.
If the provider is aware that there's going to be long-term consequences, the provider will be highly incentivized to make sure the parents know this before they proceed.
Back to the example of what you just asked.
The doctor can say, you know, there's real harm.
You understand as soon as we start taking, as soon as I start providing these puberty blockers, they're gonna have less less estrogen.
There is a chance their ovaries and their fallopian tubes aren't going to develop correctly or their uterus isn't going to develop correctly.
And then they're going to have long-term pain.
Are you okay that if we start giving this medication to your daughter because they don't want to be a daughter anymore, they want to be a young boy, that there's going to be some unintended consequences.
I think the doctors are the perfect people to have that conversation.
I think they are more than often more informed than anybody else in the room, and I want them to have that conversation.
The best way to do it is to level the playing field between the patient and provider, because right now, if a minor 14-year-old this hits 18 guess what time limits up they're done that's where the problem is let's solve that problem all right other questions for this witness yes representative perez thank you i have two quick questions number one i have two quick questions number one are you aware that there are many law cases going on right now all over the United States where young people who transition are now suing medical companies and doctors?
I am not aware.
It would not surprise me for that statement to be true.
And I say that because this is kind of experimental surgery and treatment.
And some countries have started to ban it.
Some states have started to ban it.
As I said earlier in my testimony, I'm not thrilled with just straight prohibitions.
I don't like that approach.
I don't think that works for many things.
So a better solution is to allow for the legal system to help determine whether harm was actually done.
This doesn't guarantee a win against the provider.
It just allows for the potential for the patient to address the unintended consequences that happened.
One such case is the Chloe Cole case that we're all aware of Chloe Cole.
Also, as far as emancipated minors are concerned, are you aware that they have rights of an adult except for things like they can't buy alcohol, they can't vote, they can't quit school if they're under the age of 16.
So emancipated minors, are you aware that there are limitations for them as well?
Thank you.
I actually have, I believe you, I have never studied, I have never studied what the, what an emancipated minor can and cannot do.
So I can't make, I can't speak to that.
I do know as a society, we've determined that 18 is the magic age by which someone transitions from a minor to an adult.
All right.
Other questions for this witness?
Representative Manos.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
You gave the example earlier of your friend who had, I think you said it was kidney surgery and some wrapping was left behind and I can understand that as perhaps traditional medical malpractice but your section on page 2 number 2 new section medical injury actions and you add what appears to me to be new claims defined as medical malpractice that are not traditionally viewed that way.
And I wondered if you could address that and they seem I just wanted to also add they seem to be what are called per se claims that you don't have to actually prove the injury but if these occurred it would per se be medical malpractice and i wondered if you could address that also thank you so in section two um let me first i'll answer your question it was um um her surgery.
One of the treatments for hernia surgery is to put in a mesh to reinforce the lower abdomen.
Unfortunately, there's been, I'm not even sure if it might be class action suits at this point.
I know there are a number of suits relative to the unintended scarring due to use of an artificial mesh for hernia surgery..
So they were told to do something.
This was the best recommendation, and unfortunately, it caused long-term consequences.
That's traditional medical malpractice.
I'm fully with you, but it wasn't like a surgery where a piece of fabric was left behind or a tool was left behind.
Those are different.
This was, they did exactly what they intended to do.
The surgery went fine, but three years out, people find out that the mesh that was being used at the time had created issues.
In this case, paragraph one, starting at line six and through 10, okay, is in fact a list of particular items that are new.
line 11 through 15 is in fact something that would be if if you had surgery and someone ended up sterile because of that surgery you were going in for instance to do a hernia surgery and you ended up damaging something because of that surgery, you were going in, for instance, to do a hernia surgery, and you ended up damaging something in terms of a reproductive organ, and the person was of childbearing age and ended up scarred fallopian tubes or whatever else.
They did something during surgery.
That would clearly be a medical malpractice suit.
This just says if the person is infertile, that is clearly grounds for convincing evidence that harm was done.
The other is going to have to be, you're going to have to make the case for the section one that those are real harm.
Section two being sterile is in fact a very defined case.
It's either yes or no.
All right, other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next, I'm going to call Beth Scar, please.
Or Scar, please.
You need to turn on the mic.
That's it.
There you go.
Okay.
Hi.
Dear committee members, I'm testifying in support of HB 1664 because my niece deserved better.
My niece's mom took her to Planned Parenthood at the age of 17.
My niece had severe ADHD and a chaotic family life.
She and her mom respected and trusted the medical professionals at Planned Parenthood to properly diagnose and treat her.
She was administered testosterone instead of getting the treatment she needed for her mental health, and this led her to spiral down into depression and opiate addiction, and she died of an overdose at 21.
I miss her terribly, and this didn't have to happen.
And our friend Katie Anderson, who tends church with us in Nashua, was administered testosterone and had her breasts and her entire reproductive system, including her uterus, ovaries, fallopian tubes, and cervix removed after being misdiagnosed by medical professionals as transgender.
Now she is at much increased risk of early osteoporosis and early dementia and she has lost the ability to have children.
The medical professionals Katie trusted misdiagnosed her and she has no recourse.
Now she has to deal with a lack of standards of care and a lack of diagnosis codes to get the treatment she needs to recover her health as much as doctors are able to.
It breaks my heart to see her love and devotion for the kids at church and to know she can't have any of her own.
Doctors are making money off these confused young people and not paying any price when these young people's brains mature and they realize it was all a horrible mistake.
Vote ought to pass on HB 1664 to help hold the medical professionals accountable and give detransitioners justice.
Thank you.
Questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Next, I'm going to call on Matthew Hood.
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't sure what you were saying.
Proper pronunciation.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, members of the committee.
For the record, my name is Matthew Hood, like H-O-O-D.
Okay.
I am Vice President for Government Relations at Dartmouth Health, and I'm here in opposition to the bill.
Actually several of the points that I was going to make have been raised by members of the committee, so I will be short and reiterate those points, one of which is that we're concerned that it's a rather significant deviation from the current medical malpractice legislation, which doesn't enumerate any particular practice area, cancer care, genetics care, take your pick.
We're concerned that it's a slippery slope if you start to enumerate particular services.
If a physician or a provider performs out of the standard of care, there's liability.
If they haven't, then they shouldn't.
What I would say, in addition to just enumerating it, is substantively, excuse me, it's a fairly significant deviation in that it extends the duration of liability from the standard three years or when discovered to 20 years this seems like a fairly long period of time second it switched the burden of proof finding harm if there's infertility which can be rebutted I don't know if it's the intent of the drafting but I'm not sure how you rebut whether someone's infertile or not so that doesn't seem like a reasonable burden of proof to switch further it leads me to the point that not only is there no violation, there be a requirement for a violation of the standard of care as raised by Representative Tourer, but we know that gender affirming care often results in infertility.
And so you're setting up a provider for failure by having actually successful outcome.
And my other point is there seems to be a lack of recognition of parental involvement with the minor's decision in this case, so there's never a minor that's subject to procedures in this space without significant parental engagement.
And my final point is that there is in fact a bill that would prohibit transition surgery for minors, including referrals for out-of-state care that pass the House.
So I'm not sure that this bill would be strictly necessary thank you mr chairman questions for this witness yes representative page thanks thank you mr hood for taking my question um this relates to the standard of care in the medical field and how that's arrived at or changed according to science i suppose i suppose the law could help do that.
It's probably the least efficient way to have doctors figure out how to stand up care.
But could you just, just in general, describe kind of what the medical profession does when they're looking at procedures and science and understanding what the best course of medical treatment is?
Is there a rigorous process with that um thank you for the question I it is a substantial question for the VP of government relations to answer what the what the medical field does in that space but I will certainly attest to the fact that our providers have standards of care evidence-based practice from which the care is provided, studies over years, thousands of people who are engaged in these studies to come to a conclusion.
There's exceptions in terms of experimental studies and clinical trials, of course, but to answer your question, of course, there's a rigorous basis of science and medical practice that goes into making determinations for each clinical area, whether it's, again, OB or clinical care or cancer care, et cetera, orthopedics.
Other questions for this witness?
Representative Alexander.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
Does Dartmouth Health typically perform these surgeries?
Can you give me a little bit more detail about how often they happen and what the procedure entails?
Can you talk to me a little bit more about what Dartmouth Health specifically does?
Dartmouth Health does not provide gender transitioning surgeries for minors.
And in fact, I don't believe that they're performed in the state of New Hampshire, but I wouldn't want to speak for all of the providers in the state.
Follow up?
So why are you weighing in on the bill?
I guess I'm just wondering.
If you don't perform the surgeries, why are you weighing in on the bill?
Because we're, well, there are other provisions of the bill, hormone therapy, et cetera.
And so for that reason, we're weighing in on the bill.
And we're also significantly concerned about changing the paradigm of medical malpractice.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much, sir.
Thank you.
Next, Stephen Scare, please, Scare.
Good morning, Chairman Lin and representatives.
I'm asking you to support this bill and hold the medical industry accountable.
No one can give informed consent if the parents are threatened with their children's suicide or if they're given false information.
My friend detransitioner, Preisha Mosley, wanted to be here.
She can't, so she sent me this testimony.
Gender-affirming care, from its procedures to its results to its very name, is a fraudulent farce.
Manipulative language has been carefully crafted to deceive you, but gender-denying care is not health care.
The goal of health care is health.
I shouldn't have been able to go to my doctors as a distressed teen and become more sick.
I deserved ethical, evidence-based care for my mental illness and trauma.
No child can consent to a health-destroying lie, even if they're sick enough to thank their abusers.
Dartmouth Health has testified that gender-affirming care is safe and well researched.
This contradicts the findings of the systematic reviews of medical panels in Sweden, Norway, Finland, England, France, and the World Health Organization.
They made that announcement last month, and I've included the executive summaries in my testimony.
The panels each concluded there was no sound evidence of benefits to puberty blockers and hormones, so they should be considered experimental treatments.
They expressed concern about how these treatments affect bone health, fertility, intellectual development, and cause premature menopause.
They recognize that trans identities can be transient and seem to spread as a social contagion.
And they warn that children with mental health disorders and autism are especially vulnerable.
So why the difference between what's happening in Europe and what's happening in the US and what's happening in New Hampshire.
Our major medical associations dropped medical science and they assumed a religious model that teaches we have gendered souls or gender identities that we're born with and they don't change.
They're immutable.
Any attempt to tamper with them will likely result in suicide, so it's better to try to correct the body with chemicals and scalpels.
The ideological view was the foundation of the American Academy of Pediatrics Transgender Care Policy.
It was written by one man, Jason Rafferty, who agreed to take full responsibility for it.
It's easy to look at.
You can pick out your phones or go onto the computer and check his footnotes.
You'll find it doesn't provide any research to substantiate his claim that helping children learn to be comfortable with their own sex body is a dangerous conversion therapy.
Instead, what he does, he referred to things regarding sexual orientation.
Our medical societies refuse to respond to international criticism.
They forbid debate at their annual conferences.
The publications that they're affiliated support their view with a low quality research, like this 1% regret rate which keeps getting bandied about, which is about, among other problems, it's old data based on adults and their surgery.
It's not relevant to this conversation and the number of detransitioners at all.
I hope you'll pass this bill and help detransitions get the compensation they deserve.
And please keep in mind that the research that we have shows the average time it takes to feel the regret is over eight years.
So thank you.
Questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much, sir.
Oh, I'm sorry, Representative Alonso, I didn't see you, sorry.
Thank you for taking my question.
So can I ask you, what do you do for work?
I am not a medical doctor, but the people I gave each of you the executive summaries that have all of the experts' testimony there.
You shouldn't trust me.
You should trust that.
And I realize that some of you might be tempted because you disagree with it to put these in the trash or the recycling bin without reading them.
That would be consistent with what the medical industry is doing in the United States.
Other questions for this witness?
Representative Horrigan.
Yes, you, I'm not sure whether that was your statement or who's the woman whose statement you read at first that's my first question what was her name then trisha something i didn't catch the name i'm sorry presha mosley trisha wensley okay fine so anyway either you or patricia wensley or both were saying uh attributing the medical you know medical professionals uh view on on trans surgery to their religious beliefs.
And I won't get in the argument whether or not you actually stated their religious beliefs accurately or whether they all share them.
But if it is religiously motivated, isn't that covered under the right to religious freedom, which is guaranteed by both the federal and state constitutions?
No one has a First Amendment right to mutilate and sterilize children.
All right.
Other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much, sir.
Next, I'm going to call am Shannon McGinley.
I am a volunteer executive director with Cornerstone Action, a Christian advocacy organization here in New Hampshire.
I am here to testify in support of HB 1664.
i had some previous testimony that i was planning to talk about but based on the testimony here this morning i want to hit on a few points that were actually um i felt missing from the testimony before and it also i'm referencing senator kevin avard's testimony on a very very similar bill, SB304, in the Senate.
I just want to be clear that this bill does not create legal remedies for those who are detransitioning because under RSA 507-E, New Hampshire already has a general cause of action for medical injury.
This cause of action is open-ended and it can include any type of medical injury so long as the elements of 507-E are met.
Under our current law, there is nothing stopping a detransitioner from bringing a medical malpractice suit tomorrow.
The problem is that because this is a developing area, there's great uncertainty about how our medical injury statutes would apply in a suit by a detransitioner, especially with regard to the statute of limitations.
The goal of this bill is not to create a fundamental new cause of action, like I said before, but to give greater clarity to both detransitioners and medical professionals.
A secondary goal of this bill is to clarify under 354-A, discriminating against someone for being a detransitioner is a form of gender identity discrimination.
I argue that this is already the law under the U.S.
Supreme Court's decision in Bostock, but this bill's modification to 354-A would make that explicit.
I first want to distinguish this bill from other bills on this issue that we see around the country, like Representative Hohl said, that this is not a total ban on medical detransitioning.
Should this bill become law, a patient will not be automatically entitled to a monetary award just because they've detransitioned.
They will still have to meet the regular elements and of our existing medical injury law in 507-E.
There will simply be less ambiguity ambiguity about how that law is going to apply.
Under RSA 508 colon four, New Hampshire uses what's called the discovery rule, which was mentioned before to determine when the statute of limitations starts to accrue in a medical practice action.
Currently, you must sue for medical injury in New Hampshire within three years of when you discovered the injury.
The problem is that in the case of a detransitioner, it's not clear when the discovery happened.
When detransitioner suits start to be filed in New Hampshire, they will be brought for sure.
Whether this bill is passed or not, both parties will have to spend undue time and expense litigating the issue of when this discovery happened.
This bill will resolve that question going forward.
If you allege that you were medically injured by a transition, that three-year timetable will start to tick when you begin to detransition and no sooner than that.
So again, detransition here means that you're receiving medical treatment to help reverse some of the effects of medical transitioning.
For example, a woman who starts taking estrogen trying to heal some of the damage to her vocal pitch from testosterone will be detransitioning.
Finally, let me just say something about the non-discrimination piece in this bill.
In its decision in Bostock v.
Clayton, the Supreme Court said that to determine whether there was discrimination, quote, because of, end quote, some factor, a court must ask whether there would be a different outcome if that factor was different.
For example, if you fire a male employee for identifying as a woman, the court asks whether you would have fired the employee if he identified as a man.
If the answer is no, then you discriminated because of gender identity under RSA 354-A.
Now, what if someone is discriminated against because they are a detransitioner?
This has already happened right here in New Hampshire.
For example, last year, a New Hampshire Holiday Inn location right here in Concord was ordered by its corporate office to cancel a planned event hosted when they learned that Chloe Cole, a detransitioner, was the speaker at the event.
The Holiday Inn shut down Cole's event because while Cole used to identify as a man, she now identifies as a woman.
If she pursued a claim under our laws, this would be a violation of 354-A.
That's because if Chloe Cole still identified as a man today, there would not have been a so-called controversy and she would face no discrimination.
This example shows that discrimination because of someone is a detransitioner simply is discrimination because of gender identity.
In closing, while I believe that this is a common sense application of current law, I hope that making this explicit in RSA 354-A will help to deter unlawful discrimination in New Hampshire and encourage detransitioners to vindicate their rights as full and equal members of our society under our state laws.
Thank you.
I'll take any questions if you have them.
Questions for this witness.
Representative Alexander.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
I'm looking at page two lines six through ten.
There's a previous question about the age that the person may bring such action.
Why is it 21 and not 18?
Do you think it should be, do you think the clock should start at 18?
honestly I think that lines 6 through 10 are a bit confusing in this particular bill.
The Senate version does not have that particular section.
And I think that the rest of the bill is very straightforward and that enters in some complicated language.
I think that the committee could have a conversation about perhaps removing that section.
I believe that the bill overall is totally solid because it doesn't change anything under current state law as it relates to a cause of action.
Other questions for this witness?
Mr.
Kue.
Yes, Representative.
Thank you.
Thank you for taking my question.
Yes, ma'am.
As regards to line 13 on page 2, there's a definition of medical care provider that seems to be really, really extensive.
It's almost as if anyone, any employee who stepped into that hospital or medical place is viable.
I'm sorry.
I just want to clarify the line that you're looking at, Representative DeLorenzo.
You're looking at page two.
You said line 13?
Yes.
Medical care provider.
That's Roman two, medical care provider.
I'm sorry.
I'm not seeing it.
That's page one.
Sorry.
Okay.
That's current law.
I was just getting ready to say it.
I'm sorry.
That's just the current law of the definition.
Okay.
Sorry.
I was just trying to track it.
Other questions for this witness?
So I guess I have one, and I'm not quite, I mean, I think you're generally correct that this bill doesn't make really very many changes to existing law.
And so I guess one question is, if that's true, why do we need it?
But more importantly, the question I have is this.
The one area where it seems to me that it does make a difference is the statute of limitations because under current law, under the discovery rule, a minor would have three years from the time they discovered or reasonably should have discovered the injury and its causal relationship to the actor's conduct.
This would extend that to 20 years.
Why for this particular kind of injury should it be 20 years as opposed to three years?
Well, that kind of goes back to the response that I had to Representative Alexander, that that section of line six through 10 definitely, I think, complicates it.
And that's why I would suggest that the committee consider to remove that, because I think it's fair to stay consistent with current state law being the three years.
This bill, the reason why it's needed, Mr.
Chairman, is because we need to clarify when the clock ticks, like I said in my testimony, because this is such an unknown area of law that it's unclear when the clock begins to tick.
So this way, we're not wasting time in the courts trying to determine that statute of limitations and when that clock kicked in.
And so what it means is that at the time that the person starts to detransition, like the example that I gave about taking the estrogen, et cetera, that that's when the clock would tick.
But you know, I guess, where does it say that?
I know you said that before.
I don't see that in the bill.
Where does it say that the clock starts when you start to detransition?
Sorry, I'm just flipping through this to make sure.
Sure.
Representative Hool?
Yes.
That doesn't say when the clock starts.
That doesn't say, that doesn't have anything to do with when the clock starts.
No, it says that the detransition means that the treatment received by an individual for the purpose of reversing or mitigating the effects of the gender transition surgery.
So it's referring, it's defining what medical detransition means.
Right.
Where does that, how does that say that, how does that say that's when the clock starts?
In fact, actually, that would, that would, I mean, I don't think it says it in either case, but if anything, it would seem to suggest that that would say when the clock starts, if someone were bringing an action for negligence in the D-transitioning.
so that if someone were saying, you know, you started to give me some anti-transitioning medication or treatment or whatever, and you did that negligently.
And now that's when, I mean, first of all, I don't think it says anything about when the clock starts, but that definition of what constitutes detransitioning, how is that relevant to whether there was some negligence in the original treatment to transition?
I just don't see it.
I'm going to have to read it again, and I'm going to have to look at the statute there that's referenced, and then I'll get back to you on that.
That's fine.
Other questions for this witness?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Ava Hawks, please.
Good morning, Mr.
Chair, members of the committee.
For the record, my name is A Hawks and I am the director of advocacy for the New Hampshire Medical Society on my pin card.
I did list that I had copies of my testimony and as it is a Wednesday morning, I printed a different bell.
So I'm happy I'm limiting my remarks based on how far we are on time.
And also a lot of this arguments that were going to be made in my testimony were articulated through some of the questions raised by committee members, particularly the chairman.
So the Medical Society is opposed to House Bill 1664 as we have concerns that this would unjustly put our state's gender-affirming care providers in a uniquely difficult position as the bill would target this specific provision of health care and create a carve-out in the RSA that's being referenced and invoked in this bill.
And it would target the specific provision of this care by dramatically increasing the potential medical malpractice liability for doctors who provide such care.
The Medical Society is not alone in opposing legislation such as this.
We stand alongside the American Medical Association, the American Academy of Pediatrics, the American Psychiatric Association, alongside our local New Hampshire chapters as well oppose this policy.
In efforts to safeguard the provision of gender-affirming care around the country, and here in New Hampshire, we would continue to oppose efforts that would dissuade our providers from providing this care out of fear of litigation.
And I will leave it at that.
I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you so much.
Questions for this witness.
Representative Perez.
Thank you.
Thanks for taking my question.
Of course.
Are physicians that give gender-affirming care subject at this time to malpractice?
I don't want to ask a question to a question malpractice for the provision of gender affirming care.
If I'm a doctor and I give whatever or perform surgery or give hormones or anything am I liable for a malpractice?
Am I can I someone file a malpractice suit against me?
So, while I wish I was one, I am not a lawyer, but what I do know is if a patient feels that they have suffered a medical injury, current state law already affords them the opportunity to seek damages from a provider.
I know, and the reason I reference that is I know we shouldn't invoke other pieces of legislation but a prior testifier did so I will say there's a similar bill with similar legislation and the New Hampshire Association for Justice testified to that point that under current state law if there is any medical injury folks already have recourse.
All right other follow-up.
Yep follow follow up.
So if I'm a doctor performing transitioning or giving hormones, I'm liable for malpractice, is if I assume we're assuming, correct?
I don't know if I can agree with that.
I'm not a lawyer, so I don't know exactly how I would answer that question.
You know if there is a medical, I'm not here to argue whether or not the provision of gender affirming care and the range of care.
I feel like the question's insinuating that there's medical injury associated to that care.
Okay.
Sorry.
I must be misunderstanding then.
No, I just, if you're liable when you perform it, why wouldn't somebody who's transitioning, the doctor also be liable for that, I guess was the point I was trying to get.
Thank you.
All right, other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Molly Brennan, please.
you hey everyone good morning uh molly brennan where i'd like to um speak in opposition to this bill um my i'm gonna speak uh anecdotally over and over again with all of these trans eradication bills that I've sat in in the House and Senate since I moved back to New Hampshire from Chicago.
I hear all of these experts talk about the benefits of gender affirmation care and how much more beneficial they are and how small the margin is of people who are injured and who make a choice to detransition.
So we've heard all of that.
And what I'd like to actually provide today is some anecdotal experience.
I was in Chicago for 30 years and I ran a community space that centered transgender artists.
I had hundreds of transgender artists in my backyard and in my home.
The problem that they had was not that they had been medically injured.
In fact, the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the makes it sound like it's like a vending machine and you go up and you get your estrogen, you get your testosterone you get your surgery and it's not like that even in illinois which has some of the most liberal laws about this there's a huge process that you have to go through to get any of this as an adult and certainly as a child as well and the struggle is about people accepting them, their families, their classmates, their co-workers.
This is the struggle, all right?
That is where the injury happens.
It isn't largely by the numbers because of the care that they receive.
And I feel for detransitioners as well.
And mostly I feel for them because they are carrying now physical or vocal characteristics that people are going to clock them as being queer and wrong.
And that is the thing to address is how are we treating everyone?
And how are all of these bills that are, again, the agenda is to get rid of trans people.
It is not compassionate.
It is not kind.
It is not caring for children.
It is to eradicate trans people.
And I know a lot of them.
They're real.
They are who they say they are.
And it is hard to get this care.
And you are told about the sterility and you are given options about that.
You can get your ovum saved.
You can get your sperm saved.
So that if you want to have children in the future, that is a possibility.
There's just a lot of mythology that's happening.
And I don't know if you're interested in asking me some questions, but I literally have had hundreds of trans people in my life, and I may be able to shed some light on the real experience of this.
Thank you.
Questions for this witness?
Seeing none?
All right.
Thank you very much is there anyone i don't have any other pink cards on this bill is there anyone else who wishes to be heard on house bill 1664.
all right seeing none i'm going to close the hearing on house bill 1664 and open the hearing on house bill uh 1672 and uh you have representative mr chair i think that she's in education if you just give it oh okay sure no that's fine they're a little bit busier than us believe it or not no that.
That's fine.
They're a little bit busier than us, believe it or not.
No, that's fine.
Okay.
yeah she wants somebody uh jess oh okay all right sorry about that thank you thank you thank you for being patient so al Alicia Lekas, Hillsborough 38, Hudson and Litchfield.
And when I am in my district and I see people from my district, I generally ask them questions like, do you have any comments, concerns, questions, criticisms?
Is there anything that the government, is there any way the government is keeping you from doing your job, regulations or whatever?
And that's kind of a standard.
And I was talking with a waitress that I often would have at a place in town that I eat sometimes.
And she said, yes, actually.
Her, I do not remember exactly the relative, whether it was grandson or nephew, but had gotten involved with drugs.
And he had gone through rehab and he came out and the family wanted to have him live with them so that they could support him and keep him out of drugs and keep him clean.
But they lived in Section 8 housing.
And they were told that if, because he had been involved in drugs, they were told that if he came to live there, they would be kicked out.
So here you have a family who has to decide between their family and their home.
And I said, you're right, that isn't reasonable.
Because A, we want families to stay together in where they are, and B, we want people who are trying to get clean from drugs to be able to do that and have the support they need so that's why I put this bill in questions for this witness representative Stapleton thank you mr.
chair and thank you for taking my question relative to section 8 how does you know making allowance for the recovery of the drug use affect the federal statute and monies that come forth out of Section 8?
Is it positive, negative, any restrictions?
I am not sure because this is, I know education.
I don't actually know this.
I was just trying to do what I could.
And yeah.
So I mean, well, first, are there other questions?
So I think Representative Stapleton's question is really, I mean, I don't think that this is federal law, but I'm certainly not sure.
If federal law were to say if you're a drug user, you can't be in Section 8 housing, whether you're the primary tenant or a relative or whatever, I think it might be hard for us to say to pass this bill because it would be in conflict with federal law.
On the other hand, if, as may be the case, federal law simply says you don't have to have, you know, you don't have to allow someone to be a tenant that if they're a drug dealer or a drug user, I should say, then this may be okay.
And I don't know the answer to that question.
It may be that the next witness does, and we'll find out.
So thank you for considering it.
And, yes, the researcher when I went to do this also didn't know the answer to that question.
So we said let's just go ahead and put it in and maybe somebody will know because they didn't.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Are there any other questions for Representative Durr?
Yeah, and maybe this is related because my one note when I was reading this is where the definition, right, the sort of analysis of completing a substance use disorder treatment rehab program is.
and it sounds like it might be the inverse of some clause that's in section 8 um regulation that says that folks that are are in some way involved in substance use are prohibited is that is that kind of how that reads I'm just wondering whether this needs to be clarified to make it clear what situation this is exempting.
The situation it's exempting is when the drug rehab is done, as opposed to somebody who's actively involved, and that if the person became actively involved, they would be kicked out, but the other people, the rest of the family would not be kicked out.
Yeah, just a quick follow.
I guess what I was really wondering is do we need to reference somehow that provision somehow to make it clear what this rule is exempting?
And do you know where that's defined?
That I don't.
I'm sorry.
Representative DeLorenza.
Thank you thank you Mr.
Chair thank you for taking my question um when you mentioned section 8 housing you mentioned the bill mentions public housing was this actually public housing or was it about your program I believe she just said public housing and the Section 8 ended up being written in.
It was just so I'm not.
Yes, I.
I don't know what all of those titles are.
Like I said, I know education.
I don't know this.
I'm hoping that you do and you can figure out how to deal with the situation that I came across okay okay so there are two types of section 8 housing one is public housing mm-hmm the other section 8 vouchers which are traveling vouchers so go it was she said public housing okay do you know what that's the so no it was she said public housing okay do you know what city she lives in Hudson does that has it does Hudson have a public housing authority development I don't know that we do we do have we do have um in a variety of places we have.
Oh, actually, no, the waitress lives in Hudson.
I do not know what town her family lives.
No, thank you.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Did you have another follow up?
Well, yes, I was in touch with HUD yesterday and talked with them about the bill.
And they said essentially that according to Section 8, a person who has gone to rehab and shows that they successfully finished rehab, they could be considered to become a family member of the household.
Do you understand?
Yes, I do, and that's interesting because that's not what the family was told.
The family was told they had to leave if they took him in.
Sure.
So I'm not know i don't know that the entire situation there may be more to the story but um i don't think passing a bill like this would change anything because it's already in the hard regulations that a person can um be allowed to live in the place if they've gone through rehab.
But there are a lot of very extenuating circumstances.
But that's cool to know because then I mean we didn't find that when we were researching the bill.
Sure.
But if that is the case, that's awesome because then I can go back and tell her that.
Okay.
And then there's a difference between being a drug user or being a person who is selling drugs or someone who has a meth lab in a property.
So there are a lot of variations.
Yeah, no, this was somebody who had finished, completed his rehab, and they wanted to take him in to keep him clean.
So as a property manager, that's my background.
I've had cases like that and we would have the person mitigate, you know, the circumstances.
For instance, you know, okay, we had a guy, he was in prison for so many years and he left prison and no actually while he was in prison he completed a lot of training programs he had tons of certificates um he left prison and he was looking for housing and no one would take him well we took him in we first we screened him we asked him you know he came in with a binder full of certificates a binder like that full of certificates of programs that he that he achieved and everything and um we ended up letting him in letting him move in and he was a fabulous tenant i will tell you so there are success stories and oh i i know of success stories that's why i was so disturbed that this one was the opposite sure and if you like, you know, like after this hearing, you and I can talk and I can show you.
That'd be great.
Yes.
Okay.
Then I can take that to her and she can give it to her family.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
You had a question.
So it's more of a comment.
I did, I did end up finding the, would you believe that the, that the federal statute actually states that the person can be allowed to live there?
However, if they relapse while they're a member of the household, then the entire household could be terminated because it's, if any member is determined to be illegal using drugs or whose illegal drug or alcohol abuse is determined to be a threat to others that the entire household could be terminated.
And is that a could or shall?
That is a could under 42 U.S.C.
13662A.
So then this law would not necessarily contradict that because that's a could.
and we could say, well, in our our state we don't evict the family we just evict the person right is that correct yeah I mean I I want to look at it a little more carefully but that may be you might be right you may be right well it says that they shall establish standards for it though right but that those standards could include that you could include but you have to establish standards yeah so and then just follow up when i spoke with the president had exactly an email when he looked at the bill and he said that the bill is more restrictive than what HUD has on its books so this bill is more restrictive than what's on the books for HUD okay cool so I'd be happy to work with you and to work with anybody else and make this so that it does what what i'm hoping it will do without harming anybody else well rather than go directly to me they could also go to legal services all right other other questions anybody else have any questions for this witness thank you very much thank you thank you next i'm going to call on Josh Meehan, please.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Josh Meehan.
I'm the Executive Director of Keene Housing, the City of Keene's Public Housing Authority, and Chair of the New Hampshire Housing Authority Corporation's Legislative Committee.
I'm speaking in opposition to House Bill 1672, which, if enacted as drafted, would throw the state's affordable housing programs and the private, public, and nonprofit organizations participating in them into disarray and considerable legal and financial jeopardy.
First, despite amending RSA 203, which applies to public housing authorities, the bill would regulate almost every federally assisted housing program in New Hampshire, including housing owned and managed by private and nonprofit owners specific specifically the bill states in Roman numeral 4 quote in the operation or management of section 8 rental assistance or other public housing assistance by including section 8 rental assistance in its language the bill unambiguously applies to all types of housing covered by Section 8 of the Housing Act of 1937.
This includes properties in the project based rental assistance or PBRA program, which are typically owned by private or non-profit owners and not by public housing authorities or PHAs.
PHAs are not involved in approving or disapproving tenancies in the PBRA program at all.
This language would also apply to individual property owners renting to Section 8 voucher holders.
So it raises the question, which federal housing programs does the bill intend to regulate?
The bill title is, quote, an act relative to tenants in Section 8 public housing but there is no such housing program section 8 of the housing act of 37 includes the housing choice voucher also known as the section 8 voucher and pbra programs but not public housing public housing falls under section 9 of the 37 act if the bill's reference to section 8 is accidental and it intends to apply only to public housing which which I'm not sure we heard from the bill's author just now.
It's still a little bit unclear.
One must ask why.
Public housing accounts are just a portion of the federally assisted affordable units in New Hampshire, whereas combined, the Section 8 voucher and PBRA programs account for the largest share of affordable housing in the state.
Nonetheless, unless otherwise indicated, the rest of my comments will assume that the bill intends, as it's drafted, to effect eligibility screening in both Section 8 and Section 9, so all the voucher program, PBRA, as well as public housing.
If enacted, the bill would conflict with federal law pertaining to eligibility criteria in federally assisted housing programs and the chairman had asked some questions around that very issue early on federal statutes and the regular regulations derived from them prohibit PHA's housing authorities and PBRA owners from assisting certain applicants Housing Choice V voucher participants, public housing or PBRA tenants.
For example, level 3 sex offenders and anyone previously evicted from federally assisted housing for methamphetamine production are prohibited by federal law from ever participating in the Section 8 or Section 9 program.
There are also prohibitions related to income ceilings and immigration status.
PHAs who fail to comply with these regulations are subject to HUD findings, which could result in prorated funding, more frequent program audits, or even eventually federal receivership.
PBRA owners violating these prohibitions could lose subsidy and potentially have their housing assistance payment contracts with HUD terminated, which would result in defaults on debt service to lenders and eventually the residents being forced to find someplace else to live.
Despite an indirect violation of federal law, the bill appears to prohibit housing providers from applying any eligibility criteria to applicants who have completed a rehabilitation program.
PHAs and PBRA owners could no longer consider criminal background, income, housing history, credit, or immigration status when screening household members who had completed a drug rehabilitation program.
So for example, if this bill were enacted as drafted, it appears that a PHA or a PBRA owner would be breaking state law if they denied eligibility to a level three sex offender who did not have eligible immigration status, was a millionaire, and had previously been evicted from public housing for producing meth, so long as they'd completed a drug rehabilitation program.
It's also important to note that So can I just interrupt you for a second?
Sure.
So could we fix that part of it by simply saying May.
And has not for, you know, Section 8.
Yeah, I think that would that would likely fix it.
I'm I'm not an attorney chairman, but I think that would fix it or change the shall to a may.
OK, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to.
No, that's OK.
I mean, this is a really, really important question.
In particular, because if the state were to pass a law that required housing providers to violate federal law, we would have no choice but to sue for relief from the state law, since following it would expose housing providers to substantial, even existential, financial and legal risk.
Another question that is raised, though, that isn't fixed by your question, is who would enforce this new law?
The Section 8 and Section 9 programs are funded and regulated by the U.S.
Department of Housing and Urban Development.
Except for the PBRA program, which HUD contracts with New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority to oversee on HUD's behalf, there is no state agency or regulatory body with jurisdiction over the voucher or public housing programs in the state.
If this bill were to become a law, the state would need to create a mechanism for auditing PHA and PBRA applicant files.
The state would incur costs to stand this new enforcement mechanism up, and PHAs and PBRA owners would be subject to even more oversight than the onerous HUD and investor audit and management reviews that they are already subject to annually.
The bill could also cause overcrowding and municipal health and fire code violations.
PHAs in many municipalities have occupancy standards to prevent dangerous overcrowding in apartments.
If this bill were enacted as written, a PHA or PBRA owner could not deny a resident's request to add a household member who'd completed a drug rehabilitation program, even if doing so would result in the unit becoming overcrowded and in violation of local health or fire codes or the PHA or owner's occupancy standards.
As I've stated, I'm not an attorney, but if state law, in fact, would preempt local regulation, then municipalities would be forced to exempt Section 8 public housing and PBRA units from health or fire codes related to occupancy standards.
And then I think maybe it's representative Stapleton who raised the question about the definition of substance use disorder treatment.
We have this question as well.
Is there an applicable definition of substance use disorder treatment or rehabilitation program as referenced in the bill?
Are these programs typically accredited?
Is there state licensure or certification requirement?
What would suffice for verification if not?
Would it be left to the housing providers to determine what constitutes a bona fide program?
And if so, what protections would housing providers have against claims of disparate impact if they found one program to be legitimate, but another not, absent some definition provided by the state?
And finally, as Representative DiLorenzo mentioned and others, current HUD regulations don't prohibit individuals with substance use disorders from eligibility in any case.
Other than those statutorily prohibited from participation in federally assisted housing programs that I described earlier, PHAs and PBRA owners already have the regulatory flexibility to consider mitigating factors like completing drug rehabilitation programs when screening applicants who'd otherwise be denied assistance because of prior criminal convictions, poor housing, credit issues, et cetera.
In fact, HUD recently issued guidance encouraging housing providers to revise their eligibility screening procedures so that applicants with concerning histories can provide documentation of mitigating circumstances prior to denial.
In the past, housing providers denied first and then allowed applicants with mitigating circumstances to apply for reconsideration through a hearing process.
Now, allowing applicants to demonstrate mitigating circumstances up front accelerates the screening process for applicants and owners and removes an intimidating and time-consuming step from the screening process for the applicant.
In other words, existing rules already allow for individuals who've completed a drug rehabilitation program to be admitted into Section 8 and Section 9 programs, but they are not admitted by right, as this bill would do.
Instead, they must otherwise be eligible for assistance according to the federal laws and regulations that apply to all applicants.
Okay, I apologize for the length of my testimony, but as you can see, this is a very technical issue, and the bill creates basically a cascade of problems, and I really wanted to try and share some of the breadth of the problems and I actually cut some out from my testimony so is the bottom line here for our purposes that this really isn't necessary because whatever whatever information Representative Lekas' constituent may have said about what was told to her, it's not correct.
There's not a prohibition, a flat prohibition on somebody being a tenant if they've gone through rehabilitation.
Yeah, that is correct.
I mean, without knowing the particulars here, often when folks are denied housing that they've been waiting for for a long time, they hear that and understandably get really upset.
And there's often more to it.
And unfortunately, the regulatory labyrinth that we have to navigate is hard to wrap your head around, even if you've been doing it like I have for 24 years.
And so trying to explain it to somebody who's desperate for housing, why they're not eligible can obviously make people upset.
Questions for this witness?
Mr.
Chair.
Representative DiLorenzo.
Thank you for your testimony.
It was excellent.
Thank you.
One of the questions that came up when I spoke with a gentleman from HUD was I asked him if the New Hampshire legislature has the authority to make rules for HUD programs.
What is your opinion on that?
Well, I'm not an attorney, but I think what you will encounter is supremacy clause issues where the states, and again, I'm not an attorney, but a state typically, I don't think, can pass a law that directly countermands a federal law, and this bill as drafted would do that.
You're welcome.
All right.
Other questions?
Representative Stapleton.
Yeah, thank you for taking my question.
Government applications and forms tend to be rather lengthy and thorough, and I've got to imagine that the Section 8 HUD housing applications are fully replete with all kinds of questions relative to this subject matter.
Is that the case?
Yeah, that is correct.
I mean, we do the best we can within the regulatory flexibility that we're provided to make those applications as penetrable as possible, but they are much longer than we would like and quite thorough.
And of course, things like criminal background, we do those checks.
We have to do a criminal background check.
But a lot of sort of the end of my testimony is sort of focused on, and what DiLorenzo mentioned as well, is that we can consider mitigating circumstances.
You know, it's not, there's just a few federal statutory prohibitions, and those are the ones that I mentioned.
And there's no getting around those from us.
We put our funding at risk if we try to work around those.
You're welcome.
Other questions?
Representative Tripp.
Thank you for taking my question.
Since we're not really sure where this person is trying to find a place to live, can I ask if the HUD regulations in Massachusetts are the same as they are in New Hampshire?
They are.
It's a federal program.
The 1937 Housing Act was an act of the U.S.
Congress.
So we could have some certainty that if we tell Representative Lekos that what you've told us is true in other places.
I've worked in Massachusetts and Texas.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much, sir.
Thank you.
It was a very informative testimony.
I appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Do you have your testimony to give to us?
I do.
Where should I bring it?
Right up front.
Right here would be great.
Thank you.
Okay, sure thing.
Actually, you could give it to Representative, well, I was going to say you could give it to Representative Horrigan right there, and he'll get it around to us.
Thank you.
Okay, you're welcome.
Is there anyone else here who wishes to be heard on House Bill 1672?
Seeing none, I'm going to close the hearing on House Bill 1672 and fortunately for once we're actually a little bit ahead of the game so we will recess until 11 o'clock to hear House Bill 1684.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Honorable Members, for the record.
My name is Ellen Reed.
I represent Rockingham 10 New Market and New Fields, and I am here to introduce HB 1684 on behalf of the recently resigned Honorable Dan Hines, but I'm not just doing it as a formality.
I actually offered to co-sponsor this, so I am personally fully in support of the bill as well.
Representative Wallace.
Thank you.
So consortium, when we talk about liability, consortium is the effect effect the emotional damage one experienced from losing companionship we do have a loss of consortium already in the books but it only extends to spouses and it is not defined so this bill quite wisely i think and and i think well defines loss of consortium that's the very first that section uh roman number one as the loss of love companionship you wisely, I think, and I think well, defines loss of consortium.
That's the very first, that's section, Roman numeral one, as the loss of love, companionship, comfort, care, assistance, protection, affection, society, and moral support, the loss of enjoyment of sexual relation of a spouse, or the loss of ability to have children with a spouse.
So it gives a definition, a pretty good definition for consortium, which again, we already have loss of consortium for spouses.
It then extends that loss of consortium, first of all, to children, which if you can imagine someone either negligently or intentionally harming or killing your child, you know that the damages far exceed whatever monetary impact that might have on you.
That's probably one of the most awful things a person can experience.
And we don't extend that consortium to children currently.
And then it also extends loss of consortium to pets.
And I think most of us have probably had a pet.
And again, we know that if someone were to intentionally kill our pet, that it's not just the replacement value of the animal.
That would mean nothing to us.
A few hundred dollars or what have you would mean nothing to us.
It feels quite unfair that you can't go after someone for intentionally taking away this, and it may sound trite, but a member of your family so for those reasons i am fully in support of this bill and i'm happy to take questions i will say that the honorable heinz is in is a lawyer um and will probably be able to better answer legal questions but i'm happy to do my utmost representative Thank you.
I have a question.
So if someone, if I have a dog and someone kills that dog, are you saying that there is no law that says I can't go after them for doing that?
For the, like, monetary damages.
So let's say you spent.
Criminal charges.
Well, the criminal charges, but we we're talking about so all of this section 507 is liability so that's civil like going after them civilly and right now an animal is considered an object and so if if you got anything you would get the replacement value of that animal in terms of buying a new puppy, for example.
You wouldn't get your dog back.
You know that your dog is not replaceable, and certainly not for a few hundred dollars.
So when someone takes your pet away from you like that, that is them doing significant emotional damage to you in a very unfair and unjust way, and people should be able to go after people who do that to them.
So what this bill is saying that not only what could I get the value of my property the dog back but I could get emotional damage.
In so many words it's it's It's not general emotional damages which would be a broader category it's specifically loss of consortium which again we already have when it comes to spouses so right now if someone were to like vehicularly homicide my spouse and i know i just butchered grammar there i could go after them for for civil loss of consortium they hurt me by removing my companion but we don't do that with anything else and I think everybody should be able to grade children should fall under that category and so should your pets representative Tura yeah thanks thank you for taking the question I.
I guess in your introduction, you mentioned that this is about the death of a child or the death of a pet.
When I'm looking at this, it looks like the specification of death is only related to the Section 4 on pets.
So I'm wondering, is this intended to be, I mean, I guess my traditional understanding of LOSA Consortium is it means it does not mean your spouse has to have died, but rather that something has interfered with your loving relationship.
Is that, could you clarify what the meaning of that is if this were to be expanded beyond sort of just your spouse?
Thank you.
So again, not being the lawyer that drafted it, I'm happy to refer details of that question to the lawyer that drafted it.
But in the definition that's given here, it's the loss of love, companionship, comfort, care, all of those things.
So however that loss takes place, in many cases, it would be a death.
But however that loss takes place is, you're still that companionship, and therefore that should be covered.
Any other questions for Representative Reed?
Seeing none, thank you.
Thank you.
Former Representative Dan Heise.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I did submit written testimony last night representative Reed did a good job of summarizing adding to my testimony to answer the representative's question that was just asked so I am distinguishing between pets and children to me they're the same but to others not so much so the difference in this bill, if it expands to pets and children, is children, I'm leaving the standard as negligent or intentional, which is the current standard for loss of consortium for loss of a spouse.
But when it comes to the pets, I upped the mental state to reckless.
So it's a higher burden of proof.
But also I did limit it to just death.
I would be happy to support an amendment that did expand it to injury, but I figure a start is better than nothing.
So as it refers to pets, this bill specifically for lust consortium would only be for death.
But for children, it would be the same as it is for a spouse, injury or death.
And so Representative Reed did a good job of describing what a loss consortium is.
And to answer the other representative's question, so it's basically an additional cause of action.
So right now, if someone killed my spouse, I might have other remedies, one of them being emotional infliction of distress.
We don't have that for animals.
I submitted in my written testimony a decision by a judge, which I believe is case law throughout the state, that we just don't extend that emotional distress damages to pets.
So unfortunately, yes, if someone intentionally murders my pet, I can get the replacement value of that.
I got my dog in a shelter eight years ago.
I a couple hundred dollars no animal pet is worth two hundred dollars to someone um so this bill instead of expanding it broadly just to all emotional damages does limit it to um what specifically i'm defining as loss and for consortium and um as was pointed out our state law doesn't have any definition of it so certain there's probably case law on it.
I don't handle loss of consortium claims.
But I picked what I believe loss of consortium to be and what another state uses the definition.
The other thing I'd like to just address.
So other states do allow this.
In my written testimony, I submitted a journal article.
I believe five states have it in different forms.
And some of them are broader than what this would be, and others more limited than what this would be.
So it's kind of a middle ground.
The way this is potentially broader than other states is not limiting the damages.
So if there were to be a cap on it, I still think that's better than nothing.
I don't think there should be a cap cap i think the jury should be able to decide so what would happen is if someone brought a case um and proceeded to jury trial someone would testify how much that pet meant to them and what type of assistance they gave um so i can foresee an example if someone has a guide dog or some type of animal that they use for a disability would expect that would have a lot more value than someone whose hamster might have died.
So at the end of the day, someone would be able to testify to the loss.
And the purpose of our civil system is to make someone whole when they've been the victim of an injury.
In this case, the animal being injured, but that injury just doesn't extend to the animal.
It touches upon their owner and other people.
In regards to other states that have passed it, one of the things is Tennessee, I believe it was, defined knowingly to also include the word unlawful.
So I think that might be a good amendment if the committee were so inclined.
However, our statute, I believe, does have built-in protections.
So I expect a lot of the opposition to this bill would be an argument that veterinarians, if they're injuring animals or killing animals, that they shouldn't be held liable because their costs will go up and therefore your costs will go up.
I think if veterinarians are recklessly or intentionally harming animals, then their costs should go up and they should possibly be going out of business that a better vet could come in.
But we have medical malpractice laws and we don't use that same logic saying, hey, you're going to increase our medical bills.
Let's get rid of all medical malpractice.
That just doesn't make sense.
Again, there's protections in this bill, my language specifically, to make it reckless.
And in regards to knowingly, if it's unclear, let's just say the vet is putting the animal to sleep per the wishes of the owner, I do not think this bill would apply to that.
But just to make it clear, if you wanted to add the word unlawfully with knowingly, that might make sense to do just to clarify.
But the built-in protections are the original bill has the words in a proper action, and then it further goes on to deal with what's called comparative negligence.
So, for example, if I'm negligent in harming you, but you somehow are also negligent, then what a jury will do will typically offset the damages.
So that's already built into the existing statute.
So I copied that language over.
But it might make sense to add the word unlawfully.
The reason I don't think it might not be needed is our statute for loss of spouse doesn't presently have that so i can imagine if my if someone kills my spouse but that person who killed her was acting in self-defense certainly that's not murder i can't imagine a jury proceeding with or even a court allowing this to go to um a jury trial on that issue so i don't think it's needed but it might make sense just to clarify.
And then other states that did do it, they did have some further exceptions.
So I'm happy to resubmit the testimony of the couple other states that do have similar bills, because they have various exceptions, some applying them to bets, some applying them to nonprofits, some of them applying when animals are basically in someone else's yard, injuring fowl or things like that.
So it might make sense to build those things in.
But the difference between this and the other states is, so I'm limiting it specifically to loss consortium and non-economic damages.
So other states that have dealt this, they do further protections.
So they allow veterinary expenses and other burial expenses, things in that match nature that are considered economic so they don't fit in the loss of consortium statute they might be in a better place or a different place of law um i think that is pretty much it and i'm happy to take any any questions.
Questions for this witness.
Representative Perez.
Thank you.
Thanks for taking my question.
Would you be adverse to putting a monetary value in Section 4 when it came to pets?
And the reason why I say that is because you're leaving it up to the judge, and judges are human.
If they like dogs, they may say do one thing, or pets, or they don't.
If your shepherd was killed, and I'm a judge, and I have five shepherds that are my family, would you be opposed to putting a monetary value in there?
I think it would make more sense to put a cap.
So at the end of the day day um in new hampshire entitled to a jury trial i believe it's fifteen hundred dollars so i expect most of these cases are going to go to a jury so at the end of that i think the jury is in the best position to listen to the testimony and see how much harm was really done to that person but i believe it was tennessee has a cap i think they set it at five5,000.
So I think a cap's still better than nothing.
But I think at the end of the day, it's just we can't imagine all things.
So like I said, if someone has a seeing-eye dog or someone that they really use to assist their entire life, $5,000 might be very inappropriate for that person where someone else might be entirely appropriate other questions yes representative stapled yeah thank you and thank you for taking my question again in the section Roman for damages recoverable shall be subject to diminution to the extent and in the manner provided for in RSA 507.
Can you talk about that a little bit?
I'm not sure what that means.
Yes, so that was our comparative negligence statute.
I believe when I, I didn't relook it up last night, but I believe that's a comparative negligence statute.
So my example was if I, if the person who is harmed or in this case, the pet, I guess did something.
So let's say in this case, if my animal was like provoking someone else or something like that, running at them, attempting to bite them, something like that, might bar recovery altogether.
But at a minimum, it's certainly going to offset it.
So it's basically a comparative negligent statute to potentially offset damages.
So a jury would look at how much liable one person is versus the other and kind of calculate and do a percentage generally.
Yes.
Okay, that's helpful.
Is it possible that, you know, in making a case for the amount of harm that you incurred on loss of consortium, is it not very highly subjective and could be variable to a large extent on a case-by-case basis?
And this is a job for judges and juries to parse through and, you know, difficult culture in other words it certainly is difficult um but our laws um i mean they're not always black and white each case is different and the goal is to make someone whole so we have emotional um infliction of or infliction of emotional distress already um those yes i one jury could award a hundred dollars and another might award a million.
At the end of the day, I think each case is different.
The facts will be presented.
And in this case, so like I said, we also have a loss of consortium for wives, so the same argument would apply, but we still allow it.
At the end of the day, I think the jury is in the best situation to listen to all the facts and how someone is affected by that loss.
Yes.
So in one case, a person is distraught and maybe has to take some pills for a depression.
In another case, if they're admitted to treatment, clinic, or hospital, because they're really off the deep end, and are there other mitigating circumstances or contributing circumstances, this could still be a complex ball of wax.
Can it not?
Yeah, absolutely.
And I do believe at the end of the day, the jury is in the best situation to answer that question or address damages.
if they do find liability then the next step would be damages other questions yeah just just an open question um the idea of expanding the loss of consortium definition to children and pets i'm wondering why um the the base definition remains with spouse and why YouTube.
LOSS OF CONSORTIUM DEFINITION TO CHILDREN AND PETS, I'M WONDERING WHY THE BASE DEFINITION REMAINS WITH SPOUSE AND WHY YOU DIDN'T CHOOSE TO ADDRESS OTHER TYPES OF, YOU KNOW, LOVING RELATIONSHIPS THAT HUMAN ADULTS, I GUESS I'LL CALL IT, YOU KNOW, THAT MIGHT FALL INTO A VERY SIMILAR SORT OF CIRCUMSTANCE AS SOME OF THE of circumstance as some of the ones that you've included particularly say around pets or or you know the love you have for your children thank you um sarah boleyn might be able to better do some statutory interpretation so the reason i put the word spouse in two parts of the definition is there's no good way to put it.
I don't want people claiming certain sexual losses of a pet and a child.
That's just ridiculous.
I don't think any jury would do that.
That's the reason it's limited just so someone doesn't even try to do that.
But the word spouse in the two spots I do have it should not include all the other commas.
least that that's my interpretation that's my intent um if that is incorrect i would hope it gets uh changed to meet my intent representative de lorenza thank you mr chair um thank you for taking my question uh representative honorable dan hines um so since we're applying human characteristics to pets can we switch that around and say you know let's say I was murdered and I have a pet would my would my pet be um eligible for consortium they wouldn't just because pets can't proceed with any type of cause of action it's an interesting question.
But no, this only applies to the owner and not the PEP.
Thank you.
Other questions for this witness.
So can I, I just have a couple.
Am I understanding correctly, Mr.
Hines, that the way this is drafted, the, a parent would be entitled to make a claim for loss of consortium of a child Thank you.
that the way this is drafted, a parent would be entitled to make a claim for loss of consortium of a child, even if the child was not a minor.
So if my 53-year-old daughter was injured negligently by someone, I could make a claim for loss of consortium.
Yes, and the reason for that is I think each case is different.
So if that child lives with you, I think that is something that should be recoverable.
You are losing companionship, love, comfort, care of that person, even if they're not a minor.
So I did not limit it to a minor.
If the committee thinks that's better, I still think it's better than nothing that's the reason that and the other thing is it does that it also there's no limitation that only one person gets the consortium so that for example if my 53 year old daughter is married and she's injured her husband can file a claim for loss of consortium and so can i yes i think the damages would potentially be different in that case i would think the spouse had would should require them be able to recover the most damages especially if they were planning on having a child with that person um but uh yes it all three could recover um and so you might be able to better explain it so i know a lot of times when there's recovery, it kind of gets split amongst parties if there's joint liability.
So I don't know if that concept would kind of apply or anything.
I don't think my wording would, if it does make sense to kind of limit it so that there's one pool of money that gets split amongst people.
Maybe that makes sense to do.
And just one final question.
Do you know, put the pets aside for the moment.
Can you tell us how many other states allow loss of consortium for the, with respect to a child?
Yep.
So I don't have the exact number, but in doing research just last night, it looks like some do.
And then of those states, some also allow it for the parents.
So there are states that allow it some one way, some the other.
The more common one is the one for the child, but some states also do allow it.
Can you give us a number?
I mean, how many states roughly allow this?
I don't know, but I'll get that answer to you as I further submit testimony or the written testimony just of those two statutes.
So I will try to get that answer for you.
All right, great.
Thank you.
Other questions for this witness?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next, I'm going to call on Stacey Ober, please.
Good morning, Chair Lynn, members of the Judiciary Committee.
My name is Stacey Ober.
I am the New England Manager of Government Relations for the American Kennel Club.
And I'm here this morning before you to express opposition to Section 4 of House Bill 1684.
The American Kennel Club was established as a nonprofit in 1884.
And we are a recognized trusted expert in canine health breeding and training.
We're going to be talking about the American Kennel Club was established as a non-profit in 1884, and we are a recognized, trusted expert in canine health breeding and training.
We advocate for the purebred dog as a family companion and promote the ideals of responsible dog ownership.
We also represent over 5,000 dog clubs nationally, including 13 here in New Hampshire, which represent thousands of constituent dog owners.
The New Hampshire Dog Owners of the Granite State is our federation of dog clubs, and they have submitted testimony to you this morning, but have a scheduled conflict.
They're down testifying in front of the House Environment and Agriculture Committee at this time.
I wanted to acknowledge that House Bill 1684 would expand the relationships eligible for potential loss of consortium damages to include individuals relationships with their pets.
Our understanding is that loss of consortium was originally designed to respect the sanctity of a spousal relationship and the companionship that comes from a spousal relationship.
And the calculation of damages in those cases are very subjective and are typically based on shared activities by a couple, housework, cooking, the sexual relationship.
They base it on the severity of the spouse's injury, and also a jury would look at the state of the couple's relationship.
Our concern is that House Bill 1684 would have unintended negative consequences by including pets in the category of loss of consortium, even though more and more American Society views and has pets for companionship purposes.
And the reason I say that is that non-economic damages are traditionally only allowed in cases involving close family of people who have died or have been severely injured.
Allowing them in cases with pets may signify an implicit change to the legal classification of animals as property, which would destabilize the predictable and reliable system of laws that protect both animals and owners' rights.
So what do I mean by that?
Basically, here in the United States, laws governing animal ownership and animal care have been remarkably consistent for over 200 years.
The traditions provide that pets are considered the legal property of their owners while benefiting from laws governing their care and treatment.
It does not mean that we care for our pets any less.
Rather, it simply provides the legal framework by which owners derive the right and the responsibility to provide care in a manner that is best for the animal.
When combined with criminal laws prohibiting animal cruelty and dog fighting and civil laws addressing both intentional and negligent injury and killing of animals, the classification of pets as legal property has served as the foundation of a stable legal system that promotes responsible animal ownership, deters animal abuse, and promotes innovative, affordable, and quality animal care.
So we would respectfully request the committee to strike section 4 of the bill and I'm here to answer any specific questions that you might have as well.
Questions for this witness.
Representative Stapleton.
Thank you, and thank you for taking my question.
I think you just hit something there.
Animals as legal property, not persons.
Yes, sir.
That's a pretty significant distinction.
That's the position of the American Kennel Club.
We consider ourselves an animal welfare organization, and there are some organizations that philosophically have been advocating for animal rights analogous to the legal rights of humans.
And so we frequently will see legislation proposed that would include pets in a category of other vulnerable human categories like children or the developmentally disabled in the spirit of, yes, trying to incrementally change the laws and have the laws treat and categorize pets synonymous with those who enjoy legal rights but are unable to independently protect those legal rights.
So I see this bill as an example of that movement to signify a change in the legal status and framework and our concern is that it would significantly disrupt a system that, for instance, protects animals by imposing on owners that responsibility to provide care for their animals, for instance.
So if that were a fundamental change to happen, I think it would basically throw the legal framework into some degree of disarray.
Thank you, and thank you for that background.
Other questions for this witness?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
I'll submit some written testimony for you as well.
Thank you.
You know, I wonder, Mr.
Hines, I wonder, since you're here, if I could ask you one other question, please.
Can you tell me, and I'm not sure I know the answer to this, but I think that this may be true, that a claim for loss of consortium is a derivative claim.
In other words, can somebody, if, for example, if my wife were injured in an accident, not killed, but just injured, and she decided not to bring a lawsuit against, let's say, the other driver, could I bring an independent action for loss of consortium where she didn't bring an action?
I actually don't know the answer to that.
I think the answer is no, but I'm not positive on that.
I'm not sure.
I'd be happy to look into that.
So I gather it's by case law as opposed to statute, because I didn't see anything in reading the statute.
So that could be the case.
If it is, I guess our  So here's what I'm worried about.
If that is the case, and I think it might be, but I'm not positive.
If that is the case, then this expansion that you want, I mean, I could  would that also be limited that the, in other words, there can only be a claim for loss of the consortium relating to a child if whoever is able to bring a lawsuit for the child, and obviously if the child is an adult, it would be the child itself, but if the child is a minor, the parent would have to bring a claim for the law, in the name of the child or for the benefit of the child in order to get the consortium.
Is that correct?
Without knowing, I guess, the derivative issue, I'm not sure.
If so, I believe this would be the statute to get rid of that.
So I'm not sure when that i guess i'm i'm unsure because i think i think regardless the parent would still have a claim whether it's um just like the spouse of the former spouse or unfortunate or it could be dead spouse um would still be bringing a claim so if you're saying they need to bring another claim to get this one in i think they still could have that um if you're saying that the decedent would have to bring the claim um i gather a parent definitely could do that for a minor um i think if someone's i guess i'm not sure exactly when i guess since I was just tracking the language of a spouse, I didn't think of this issue, but I would think it would still be allowed to proceed.
But maybe it makes sense to make it so that this is an independent action that doesn't require other actions, just because I don't know the answer to that question.
All right.
No, thank you.
Thank you very much.
I was able to find the answer to your other question.
32 states have some form of familial loss of consortium.
Filial.
Sorry.
So allowing the child to bring.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Other questions for this witness?
Thank you very much.
Joan O'Brien, please.
Thank you, Jim.
My point was made already, so I'll pass.
Joan O'Brien please.
All right.
So is there anyone else here who wishes to be heard on House bill 1684 yes Come on up.
Secretary, you should have a card that we...
Oh.
It was packed.
For Kirsten, Shelton, Jim Hedon.
Is there one right in front of you there?
Okay.
Sorry, I, I didn't see you.
All right.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm Kirsten Schultz.
This is my colleague, Jim Hadam.
We're both attorneys with Nixon Peabody.
We're here with Nixon Peabody in the Manchester office here in New Hampshire.
We're here on behalf of State Farm, one of the leading writers of auto and home insurance in the United States and here in New Hampshire.
We'd like to express our opposition to HB 1684 relative to loss of consortium.
I think I'll speak first if that's all right, and then I'll pass it over to Jim.
I'm going to bring a sort of litigator perspective to this, I think, and Jim has a more insurance-specific perspective.
We've also submitted our written statement for the record, and I'll just summarize the main concerns in there.
Primarily, the bill is concerning because it significantly expands the definition of loss of consortium, along with the categories of family members who are entitled to seek those damages in ways that we think are inconsistent with existing law.
So by their nature, as Chairman Lynn, you just noted, you've already picked up on this most important point, loss of consortium claims are derivative.
You know, if there's no liability on the merits for an underlying injury claim, then there is no loss of consortium claim available either.
So, and at its common law origins, essentially consortium was defined in a really limited way.
It was sex services and society, sex services and society, and it was only available to a husband for injuries that his wife might have sustained, physical injuries.
And it was only in 1967 that New Hampshire took the sort of necessary but bold, I suppose at the time, step to extend the availability of those lost consortium damages within a marriage to wives for similar damages that they sustained when their husbands were injured.
Since then, our courts have consistently declined to recognize causes of action for lost parental consortium brought by a child or for a parent's loss of a child's consortium.
And this there's a line of cases extending from I think Siciliano, the capital city shows back in the early 80s on forward.
More recent one is Harrington, the Brooks drug and the courts cited the same concerns.
I think that State Farm is raising today essentially about extending consortium claims in those cases.
They were worried about an unwarranted expansion of liability and that recognition of such claims would lead to increased litigation.
For example, in Siciliano, where the court had declined to recognize a parental right of consortium for a minor who had been injured or killed, I think injured in that case, the court stated its concern that the social burden of providing damages for this loss will ultimately be borne by the public through increased insurance premiums or an enhanced danger that accrues from the greater number of people who will choose to go without insurance.
And later the Harrington court echoed these same concerns in a similar type of claim between a parent and a child.
And based on its own analysis to of public policy considerations, as well as the common law and existing statutes.
And, you know, extending to essentially a bereaved pet parent is also very, very inconsistent with the derivative nature of lost consortium claims.
And I believe it was Representative DiLorenzo who asked the question before about whether a pet could pursue a claim, and that is the heart of what is sort of wrong, the logical fallacy essentially underlying this bill.
Of course, we can all understand the emotional appeal of allowing such a claim.
No one would deny that pet owners can feel truly profound loss if a pet is taken from them but as again the siciliano court had recognized you know not every relationship is even legally recognized relationships necessitates its own cause of action and it does not follow logically that a pet owner could pursue lost consortium damages because there's no underlying claim for bodily injury or personal injury from which that consortium claim could derive.
The pet cannot bring a claim.
He has no claim.
There's no cognizable claim.
You know, there are a lot of creative legal arguments, I think, out there in academia that talk about recognizing the rights of non human animals and they're really interesting to read and lots of smart people thinking about those things, but we're not there yet.
And those efforts have been universally unsuccessful in all other jurisdictions in states elsewhere.
And so for those reasons, I think we think it's appropriate to follow the weight of authority that exists in other states that, you know, from my, you know, just general research that what I've looked at, I think there might be between maybe 12, anywhere between 12 and 17 other states that recognize some degree of familial consortium claims in non-death cases.
But it's far from the majority.
It's far from the vast majority.
And so for these reasons, we would ask you that you vote an expedient to legislate on this bill.
And I will turn it over to Jim, but happy to answer questions too.
All right, questions for this witness first before we hear from the other one.
All right.
Thank you.
Yes.
Yes, again, Jim Hadam for the record.
And I'm here as a non-litigator to give you a perspective on why this is a concern to State Farm.
And, you know, whenever we see a bill that comes up that involves the increase of a definition of a category of damages and the addition of parties who can claim those damages, we inevitably wonder how that's going to impact the policyholders in the state, the citizens of New Hampshire.
As Kirsten testified earlier earlier it's clear that a bill like this would have some impact on the insurance and insurance rates um and you know and what we do is and we do this in many other circumstances whenever there's a bill that um has has a potential impact on rates there's an opportunity to actually ask the actuaries who can to quantify what that impact impact might be in the House Commerce Committee frequently does this when a bill is in front of them where they would be asked to adopt mandatory benefits in the air of health insurance.
And by getting that information, you as legislatures and policymakers have an opportunity to see the cost versus the benefit of these types of bills.
I'm going to, there is this expansion of the laws of consortium is not just happening in New Hampshire.
It's happening in many other states, and it happened last year in New York.
And the governor vetoed a bill that was going to expand the loss of consortium rights substantially.
And part of the reasons that the governor vetoed the bill was that it indicated, an actuarial study indicated that there would be a 40 percent increase in rates and so I'm not saying this would increase 40 rates by 40 percent but that's the type of information I think it'd be important for the legislature to have before it before it makes this decision.
State Farm can only speak from the perspective of an auto and homeowners insurer.
You've heard from the folks, one of the businesses or a business that's in the area of pet care.
You'd also have to think about how it might impact medical by practice insurance, which is, we all know, very expensive and very hard to get for our health care professionals.
And also it would have an impact on businesses in general.
So before you would consider this bill further, I would suggest that an actuarial study would be appropriate so that you could have all the information in front of you before making a decision.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Questions for this witness.
Representative Greese.
Thank you for taking my question.
How many claims of loss of consortium are there presently that State Farm then has to pay?
Well, I would say plenty, but I don't have a number and you know that's actually what goes into the actual study they look at how many claims involve loss of consortium and then they quantify the awards in the in the settlements and you know they come up with the number the actuaries come up with a number so Other questions?
I thought I saw somebody.
Representative Wallace, did you have a question?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Any other questions?
All right.
Thank you very much, sir.
Thank you.
All right.
Is there anyone else who wishes to be heard on House Bill 1684?
Seeing none, I'm going to close the hearing on House Bill 1684.
And before we recess for lunch, I wonder, I'm speaking for myself now.
My inclination is that there are at least two bills, I would say, but one in particular that we might be able to exec right now if the ranking ranking member agrees and i'm thinking specifically about uh hb 1672 which it sounded like we pretty much we heard we pretty much heard evidence that there was not that that this was not a problem that the uh somebody might have been given him the representative might have been given miss the constituent of the representative might have been given inaccurate information but that this isn't really necessary so if the ranking member agrees I would think we might be able to um exact this now all right so um Ben um on House Bill 1672 um I would move inexpedient to legislate second seconded by representative wallace um is there any discussion on 1672 all right then um i would ask the uh clerk to call the roll please on uh motion of inexpedient to legislate on House Bill 1672.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
Yes.
Rep.
Andrews.
Yes.
Rep.
Testerman.
Oh.
Rep.
Stapleton.
Yes.
Rep.
Tripp.
Yes.
Rep.
Greeson.
Yes.
Clerk Ketab votes yes.
Rep Tripp?
Yes.
Rep Greeson?
Clerk Ketab votes yes.
Rep Perez?
Not here.
Rep Smith?
Yes.
Rep Horrigan?
Rep DiLorenzo?
Yes.
Rep Devine?
Rep Lanza?
Yes.
Rep Manos?
Rep Chair?
Yes.
Chairman Lin?
Motion passes 14 to 1.
Any reason that this can't go on the consent calendar all right yeah representative testament are you are sorry if it goes on the consent calendar no no consent all right all right we'll go on the regular calendar oh okay i'm sorry i'm sorry all right consent thank you all right great thank you um so then again i um with regard to uh 1684 the loss of consortium my inclination is we may be able to this now my sense is that this is that this is that this is not a good idea at least based on the current information that we have certainly I I would say extend expanding this to pets just I mean I again I'm speaking for myself if other and I I completely understand how people love pets they love their pets but to extend legal liability in this manner seems to me to be a stretch.
And I am concerned even with the expansion to children because of, I mean, the expansion of potential impact on insurance rates and that kind of thing.
But the other thing that sort of bothers me is, given the way it's drafted, it would be, I could see situations developing where it's not limited to minor children, where you could have a situation of causing some kind of problems within families.
If the spouse is the one that would get, under current law, would be the one that would be entitled to consortium benefits if the spouse that was injured brought a lawsuit but only in those circumstances.
Now you'd have the potential that the, you know, the mother or father of the person potentially would have a stake, so to speak, in the recovery.
How does that interact with the spouse?
It just seems to me that this is not a good idea.
So I would be inclined to ITL it, and I guess I'd ask the ranking member her view on whether we should do that.
All right.
So I guess what I want to say is this.
I don't want, if members of the committee want to have more time before we exec this, if people are sort of conflicted or think we should take more time, I don't want to rush to a vote if there are people that think we should not do that.
But if the ranking member and I, you know, but but if there if people do have a different if if people don't have a different view, then I would be prepared to to, you know, to move to make a motion and have us vote now.
Representative Katah.
I'm wondering if it may make sense to interim study this to kind of look into some of the things that were brought up, because I mean, where there's 32 other states that are allowing this, at least for children.
I mean, I get, I take your point about, you know, this isn't just involving minor children, and perhaps that needs to be looked into more, but I mean, I think the loss of a child is a pretty significant thing, and I'm just wondering if perhaps we should look into it.
Sure.
The only question, the only thing I would say is, and I want to hear from Representative Smith also, but the only thing I would say is, as Representative Smith pointed out before, if we take into the interim study route, that means that we need to do something else at some point.
And so that's the, I guess that is, you know, are we, do we want to do something else at some point?
That's really the question.
Representative Smith, I think you want.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Thank you.
I just had a question for Representative Kutab.
Will you be chairing the subcommittee on this bill over the summer during election year?
Thank you.
So I'm sorry.
I guess, is it possible that maybe we could hold it and maybe we could potentially look into some of these things now and amend it prior i don't unless i want to hear what rep smith has to say i guess first we get a lot of bills in this committee um not as many as education but a lot of bills it is not the committee's responsibility to take a bill that may or may not have a core idea and then do all the work necessary to get it into a bill where the committee could take ownership of the quality of the research.
I think that our former colleague said probably a dozen times, yes, this is a problem, but the committee could find the answer, or this isn't quite right, but the committee could amend it.
With all due respect, and we certainly miss him and wish he was still here with us, I don't think this bill is ready for prime time.
There are a lot of issues that are raised that would need a lot of work.
I mean, I just think when the attorney who's representing the Allstate view talked about the kind of research that would have to be done, I don't think any of us are ready for that.
If this is a good idea, then there'll be members of this committee and others who will do the work on their own and come in with a bill that's ready for the committee to consider and i just don't think this one is uh representative stapleton and then representative greece i concur completely with representative smith representative greeson the uh what i see in here is an opportunity for a right of consortium for loss of a child and i agree it should be limited to minor child but i don't see anything where there's a loss of a child, and I agree it should be limited to minor child, but I don't see anything where there's a loss of a parent or a claim by a minor child.
I think about my wife.
She was seven years old when her father was killed by a drunk driver, so she got to live the next 11 years without a father before she moved out, not to mention her four-year-old sister and her one-year-old brother who grew up without a father.
So I don't see any right of consortium there, and so you can't tell me that the loss of a father isn't a pretty significant event on the life of a child with a loss of love and companionship and comfort and care of a father, unless we want to go ahead and declare right here that fathers are irrelevant.
I'll take personal exception to that one just so you'll know.
I happen to have two children.
So I think the bill actually is forgetting one portion where it could be, but I also agree that it is not the onus is not on the committee to do the homework.
So I would think that it would be okay.
It's acceptable to me anyway to put the onus back on the bill's sponsor to write an amendment and get it to us.
If we hold off on executing this for at least another, I guess it would be not next week, but the following week, give time to draft an amendment.
I definitely think you need to drop the pet section, though I can't go for that.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes, Representative Lorenzo.
As far as, you know, including children in this bill, isn't there already a basis for remedy in tort law?
Well, I mean, certainly a parent, if a child is injured or harmed, certainly a parent can bring a lawsuit in behalf of the child.
The difference here would be that when the parent brings a lawsuit in behalf of the child, the recovery is for the child.
This would allow sort of an additional recovery for the parent, which is not sort of allowed under current law.
So, look, as I say, I would be prepared to vote on this bill now.
It sounds like Representative Smith would be also.
On the other hand, I don't want, if people think we should give this more time and are not ready for a vote, then I'm not going to have a vote.
And so I guess my, let me just ask initially, just for a show of hands, who thinks we should not vote on this now?
Anyone else?
Representative Perez.
hands who who thinks we should not vote on this now anyone else representative perez representative horegon all right now that's enough then we're not going to vote on it we're not going to vote on today um all right um i think unless anybody has any any other business i think we're uh recessed until one o'clock but anything else anything Thank you.
any other business I think we're recessed until one o'clock but anything else anything anybody else wants to bring up all right thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
you like being retired all right um it's after one and i'm going to open the work session on House Bill 1002.
and so I guess what I'd like to just ask as a general question first to the members of the committee is just this general thing is it was the bill was remanded to us by the house to consider additional, consider other information, as I recall, or additional potential ways of dealing with this.
So I guess the general question I have for everybody is, are people open to considering options?
In other words, is there anybody whose view is, this bill is just bad and we should just kill it?
No matter, there's nothing that would change your mind.
Can I just ask you for a show of hands, if people have that view, would you let me know?
All right, so that's one 1002 1002 right okay, so that's a show of hands again, so it's one two Three four five six seven eight okay, so eight people would not be in favor of any change.
All right.
Okay, so I guess, so Representative Kutab, I think you have some proposed things for us, for those of us who are willing to consider other options to consider.
Excuse me, Mr.
Chair.
Maybe I need to back up a bit.
I'm saying as well as of what we know right now it's straight no for me if an amendment comes to me that I think we could work with and that's fine but right now there's nothing okay all right no I'm sorry then I then I maybe it maybe I was not as clear as I wanted to be what I I'm really saying is, are there people on the committee that there are no amendments that could possibly get you to agree with this bill?
That's what I was really asking.
So, yes.
I'm rude, and I'm interrupting you.
I'm sorry, and I apologize for that.
No, it's not all right.
I do apologize.
But this is a work session.
Right.
I'm wondering why you choose to begin the work session that way rather than saying this is a work session, we are going to consider what's before us, which, and there has been some work done to be presented to us and not ask people whether their minds are closed before they've even seen the work that disparate groups have done.
Well, I guess what I would say is my sense is that if there are people that say there's nothing you can do that's going to cause me to change my mind, then I guess my view would be, okay, So we, you know, we don't, we're not going to be able to accommodate you.
So there's, so let's talk.
I mean, the.
view would be okay so we we you know we don't we're not going to be able to accommodate you so there's so let's talk i mean the discussion basically would be among those who who are open to to uh consideration i i guess i would say i mean that's that's fine and it's just a different approach that I use.
I try not to make my mind up until I know what the options are.
And when I know what the options are, I can then say yes, no, or maybe so.
But I don't want to be in a situation where I'm told don't let the facts get in your way of your decision and that's the only that's the only comment and if it's I don't mean to challenge you I mean and I don't it's just a different way of looking at it I guess and so having said that I back no no no I hear what you say I guess what I'm saying is I mean, I'd like to think that my philosophy of dealing with things is the same as yours.
I want to hear what, but it sounds like from, I mean, I asked the question because it sounds like, at least with respect to this issue, that there may be some people who don't have that view with regard to this.
And that's why I asked the question.
But anyway, to move on to Representative Kutab, could you just tell us you have a proposed way of handling this situation?
And I wonder if you could just explain that to us.
Sure.
So I'm going to hand these out.
So I did work with Right to Know New Hampshire, who Ms.
Coco had a coalition of several people who were initially in opposition to the bill, including but not limited to the ACLU and the Press Association and a big kind of coalition of people.
And we worked together to really try and find somewhere that we might be able to meet some common ground.
And so what this amendment does is it changes it to first say that the cost would only be for for-profit companies that were using it for a commercial for-profit purpose.
But it also added that in order to give the charge, that they'd need to give an itemized estimate, so not just an estimate.
These other pieces are the same here.
And then for the purposes of this section, commercial use means a request for information for use or purpose that furthers in commercial trade or profit interest.
It does not include a request that's made for the purpose of attaining information for publication or broadcast by an individual employed buyer connected with or a freelancer of a newspaper, magazine, of general circulation, weekly publication, press association, or radio or television station.
So we've exempted the media from this commercial piece here.
The commercial use piece, they can charge for excess time in excess of three hours, not to exceed 25 an hour.
The reason why we've kind of brought that time down is because many people, they were even in opposition to the regular people paying it when we're talking about out-of-state commercial entities.
They're like, why are they getting any time for free?
And why is it only 25 an hour?
Why aren't they paying the full cost?
So I was trying to kind of come up with some common ground there then we've added a vexatious request piece which was modeled off of some language from Pennsylvania but at this point has had some other additions to it so I would say that it's kind of a collaboration at this point and I i wouldn't necessarily say that it's just solely based on one thing but um and it says after attempting to reach a reasonable modification or resolution with a request or a public body or agency may deny a request that the public body or agency deems intended to disrupt or place an unreasonable burden on the essential functions of the body or presents an unreasonable probability of having such effect.
Or presents a reasonable...
Oh, sorry, a reasonable probability of having such effect.
For any claim by a body, the request is an unreasonable burden.
The provisions of this section shall be followed.
The public body shall provide the requester a written statement with their reasons for denying the request.
After giving the requester 10 days to retract their request, the public body shall file a complaint within seven days to the end date of the retraction period with the ombudsman pursuant to RSA 91A7B or with the Superior Court for a determination of whether the denial was reasonable.
The public body's complaint shall contain relevant affidavits detailing the alleged vexatious nature of the request, and the burden shall be on the public body to establish by a preponderance of the evidence that the request is vexatious.
The ombudsman or court shall issue a ruling within 60 days or other reasonable time period granting or denying the access of records.
Any party agreed by decision under this section may appeal.
At any time during the proceedings under the section, the Ombudsman or Superior Court may recommend that both parties participate in mediation.
If both parties agree, the mediation shall last for a period of up to 90 calendar days and may be extended with the agreement of both parties.
During the mediation and any other proceedings under this section shall be stayed unless otherwise other unless otherwise ordered by the ombudsman or superior court so we've we've now taken away any charges for people you know regular people requesting things this is literally just be if somebody is putting in request after request that are really large requests and they're never coming to pick them up, that could potentially be considered vexatious.
If they're putting in such a huge request that so many people are going to have to work on it that it's going to impede the essential functions of the body, which is a pretty big burden to prove.
We're talking quite a big request, like you'd have to maybe be asking for 100 years of information or something like depending on what town you're going to.
So I think, you know, we've compromised on a lot of this.
I know that Gilles had sent a note in about, you know, kind of wanting to include online blogs.
But I think there were several that were really in opposition to that because any commercial entity can go ahead and create an online blog giving some information about their solar panels, you know, in Florida, and now all of a sudden they're media, and so they don't have to pay for their commercial request, and that's really just not the spirit of it, and I would say that the online publications such as like the New Hampshire Bulletin, the New Hampshire Journal, all of those are included as part of the New Hampshire Press Association.
So I'm not, it's not excluding all online blogs, but just ones that aren't considered news media.
So that's kind of the direction that we've kind of gotten to try and come up with some sort of compromise on a way to kind of move forward and address the concerns that were the reason that we put in the bell and i'm happy to take any questions on it all right questions from representative Alexander.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Representative, for taking my question.
So my first question is why in the amendment it changes the time from 10 hours to 3 hours.
That seems like going in the opposite direction from what opponents of the bill indicated.
Because it's much easier to make up 3 hours worth of work than, you need 10 hours worth of work.
Yeah.
So that piece only applies to commercial use pieces.
It doesn't apply to regular requesters.
And in doing this, actually, even people that were against the initial bill, many of the people said to me, why are our tax dollars paying for any request for any commercial purpose?
If the purpose of them putting it is for profit, they should take the costs out of their profit.
We shouldn't be, our tax dollars shouldn't be paying for that.
And keeping in mind that a lot of these requests are coming from people that are in Florida, California, like they're not even New Hampshire based things.
But this isn't saying that a company that's asking for something because, you know, the business lives in town, is in town, and they want to know what, you know, something about something being built next door or something, zoning things.
That's not, they're not asking for that for a for-profit purpose.
They're asking for that for, you know, a non-for-profit purpose.
So that wouldn't be included in here.
So it's dependent on the data that you're asking.
If you're, if you're going to go and ask for, you know, all of the, the building data, cause you want it to sell your solar panels and you should have to pay for the person to kind of do it.
And again, this isn't even some of the people were like, well, I don't know why it's only 25 an hour.
It should be the actual costs.
But again, it was me trying to come up with a compromise on it.
So if I could follow up, Mr.
Chair, are you, I guess I'm wondering what's to stop BAE as a commercial entity from just having a member of the public request the information they need when it says, and I understand for commercial purposes, but like, is the municipality then allowed to ask the requester the motive behind why they're requesting the information?
Like, don't you think that like, it's not their, it's like, it's not their problem.
Like they don't need to tell them the motive.
We don't impug motive on members of this committee.
Yeah.
So the, the commercial requests that are coming in that are for private purposes, they're, they're typically like very obvious why you're asking, but absolutely somebody could, could try and do that if it was some unobvious purpose of doing it.
And there's nothing to stop because we're not making it that strict in that purpose, but it's just trying to limit the ones that are truly for profit purpose.
And they're gonna be selling that data.
And a lot of times those requests are coming in directly like on email letterhead from those companies.
So it's obvious that they're for commercial purposes they're not coming in from somebody's gmail no i i understand i guess i'm like what what is this bill solving if there's a workaround for the one thing that we're putting in place that's that's the it's not really question more of a a thing to say like there's i just wondering like have we amended it or possibly amended it to a point where it's not solving any problems it's just passing no i think it is solving that problem still because i think i i again i do think it's incredibly obvious when these commercial requests are coming forward and then i do think it also is giving that option when there is a request so large that it's going to impede the essential functions of a body so i do still think that those those pieces are important pieces to have in and i especially i i also want to say that when i was looking into a lot of this there's a lot of other states that already have this in place and there was five other states with bills on the same subject so this isn't a a New Hampshire problem.
This is a growing problem across the U.S.
No, and this is the last thing I'm going to say, Mr.
Sheriff.
That's okay.
The other problem I have is with essential functions, because I believe strongly that government's most essential function is to respond to the public.
So to be accountable to the public, and this is a way for the public to do it it so when we're taking away that opportunity whether it's for commercial purposes or or what say you it it defeats the essential function in my belief of government what their job should be other people have other uh representative ferrez thank you caitlin i know you work really hard on this and I give you a lot of credit and I know this is people have been not the nicest to you about this but I have I'm gonna be straightforward commercial use is not really defined in here I still wanted one of the problems that happened in Londonderry when Kevin Smith, who was our town manager, ran for Senate, is that requests came in from all over the United States and from different parties came in.
And some came from California.
And it was a huge burden to the town of Londonderry.
And I think that's one of the reasons why a lot of the reps in Londonderry supported this.
This doesn't cover that.
I mean, if I decide to run for president and I live in Londonderry, this is not covering all the information people are going to try to find out about me.
But the other thing is, I personally, and from what I've heard from my constituents, unless it is not applicable for someone who lives in a town or someone who owns a business in the town, then, and I know you can have somebody from out of town say, hey, Caitlin, would you put this in for me?
I can't go for it.
I always say I run for the little guy and the kids.
This, in my opinion, is, unless it says specifically, this doesn't apply to residents of aES IN TOWN REQUESTING FROM THEIR TOWN.
I KNOW I CAN'T GO ALONG WITH IT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MY CONSTITUENTS ARE ASKING FOR.
ALL RIGHT.
OTHER, YES, REPRESENTATURER AND, OH, I'M SORRY, REPRESENTATURER SMITH, I THINK YOU WERE FIRST AND THEN REPRESENTATURER AND THEN REPRESENTATURER STABLETON.
THIS IS JUST a question that shows my age, I guess.
Representative, you used the word media.
And I'm not exactly sure.
I don't see the word media in here.
I see publication or broadcast by an individual employed by or connected with a freelancer of newspaper magazine of general circulation weekly publication press association or or radio or television station and I'm not sure that media captures  I mean, the word media, I think, is larger than that.
And so I'm a little confused about why you would use media, except for the fact that it's easier to say than all these other things.
I know that on the seacoast, we used to have newspapers that actually had reporters downstairs in the press room.
We don't have that at all anymore.
And we increasingly rely on what would be non-traditional sources for news, unfortunately.
And so I'm just wondering if you are building a wall to keep in or keep out some of those non-traditional sources that I don't actually really know what the definition of blog is.
I'm serious.
And so enough said, but I think you see what my dilemma is about who's covered and who's not covered.
Of course, yeah.
Thank you for the question.
So this was the language that was used in a few other states statute.
And I think the reason is because you or I could go start our own blog tomorrow.
We could just go open it up, but it doesn't mean that we're actual, you know, press, right?
And so this was trying to limit that from happening because what you don't want is people that have kind of a commercial, real commercial purpose going and just starting a blog that's going to give some information on something.
And then they go, well, I have a blog, so I'm exempted from having to pay for this.
So, i think the important pieces is that well yes you're saying that some of these um traditional pieces have gone away a lot of the places that have kind of replaced them are included in the press association such as um the um patch.com is included in the press association so isn't the new hampshire journal the new hampshire bulletin um the rochester voice which is again an online publication um so i guess the ones that are more actual legitimate media pieces and not just somebody with their starting their own website blog are included on here but i don't i think if you start adding in every single blog on the planet that all of a sudden you're just anybody can start a blog i could literally start a blog in five minutes while i'm sitting here but that doesn't mean that i'm truly a part of the press or media so is it involvement with the here, but that doesn't mean that I'm truly a part of the press or media.
So is it, is involvement with the press association something that is crucial to this or not?
So that just is including some of the, it does include several of the online media pieces that we do have online that are i guess some could call maybe they could call this an online blog i would say more it's an online publication but they are all included like i did try and think of all the places where we get news to make sure that they were actually covered by this definition and i was trying to be really careful in doing that because i wanted to make sure that we weren't excluding any legitimate media thing and i also don't i mean i think we want to keep i also don't want to degrade the quality of like journalism in this either you know we have some really respectable online journalist journalism and i don't i think including every blog kind of just also kind of degrades the quality of the media that people are trying to put out.
And, you know, I think, I don't know, I think we depend on a lot of that.
Thank you.
We get very, you know.
Let's see.
Representative Surr, I think, and then Representative Stapleton, I think you had a question, and then we'll go to Representative Mayer.
Please.
Great.
Thanks.
And thanks for bringing this.
There's a lot in this.
And I'll start off and say I sort of think there's, for my mind, three things in here.
Things that I like, at least to some degree.
Things that I am wondering whether we absolutely need from a legal standpoint, and things that I don't like.
And so I do like the separation of commercial.
I'm not sure the way this is in here is my favorite embodiment of that, because it's more about the use of the data than about the request in my mind, the commercial use of the data that you get, which may be a totally separate issue.
But I do think the commercial use of 91A is a problem all by itself.
The need part, and this is my, I guess, I sort of have two questions, sorry.
The first one is my understanding is that there has to be, and and this comes partly i think from our discussion with you um an alternative to the ombudsman in this legislation in order for it to stand and so that's the question of it be it this amendment or some other change do we need to make a change in order to allow the the process to to to be legitimately played out through whatever ombudsman or other this now brings in the court system could you speak to that and and then i'll ask the if if the chair allows i'll ask one more question so from my from my initial red line to ols i had put in there that they would could seek relief or something along the lines of to the ombudsman.
And they actually changed it to say may seek relief according to RSA 91A7B because where you're offering somebody to go to an ombudsman, you also have to offer them a pathway to go to superior court.
You can't force somebody to only go through an ombudsman according to the ols attorneys so that was changed in there so there is either path that both paths are now available yeah i guess i'd have to say i'm not sure i agree with that i mean i think you that certainly is under existing law it certainly is true you know without this it certainly is true that you have that you have the sort of option I'm I don't I'm not sure there would be a constitutional reason that you couldn't say for this purpose you only go to the ombudsman or you go to the ombudsman first and then you know there's all there's an appeal from from the ombudsman so I I don't know that that's you know that that you couldn't do that i guess the question would be what whether you wanted to do that or not um yeah so i think that's an interesting question that i'd love to hear sort of more clearly defined because if i and i'll say i sort of like the build the way it went to the floor um you know i i was not looking it was not one that's felt that it needed amendments but if it needs amendments then certainly there should be amendments uh the third the third part that i'll say the part that i don't like is the way that this now works i like the statement that i think you were able to make clearly originally which is this entitles you to 10 hours of your public officials time every month in perpetuity in order to get the information that you're looking for without any fees and then if your fee is if your request is so broad that's when when the the cost i felt that that sort of struck a nice balance between what we understood to be the size of a reasonable 91a request versus sort of an unreasonable or or you know uh i guess the new word is vexatious um and and this sort of now puts a whole lot more process on the municipal body to go through in order to sort of attain attain the same sort of ending that they they would have to go to the ombudsman they'd have to sort of bring a case and i even thought we we had found out that the towns don't have standing before the ombudsman i'm not sure yeah so i think the ag's office is actually here and might be able to speak a little bit to that but the ols attorney did come back and say that courts don't typically give advisory opinions they typically give determinations so you you this would in essence be seeking an advisory opinion on rather something was reasonable or not so it should actually be the requester that would go to the report but i think the ag's office might be able to offer some more information on that all right so if you don't mind just to finish that thought um so i so i think the way it was originally was a lot cleaner and a lot more comprehensible i do think there maybe could have been some additional language added to what would happen if the ombudsman decided that the estimate was unreasonable i was kind of hoping we'd be able to say a little more that um but i feel like this kind of really weakens the the underlying concept and puts a lot of burden on a municipality to use the term vexatious which it may be a definition would be good i don't know whether that's defined somewhere but it seems like you'd almost have to fill the request in order to sort of show that it's vect or fill multiple requests to show that it's vexatious so that's my representative stapleton um do i understand that this amendment replaces everything in the original to the point of also no criteria for unreasonable or extensive requests by private citizens um i why i ask that is because i've seen this play in motion where you get some activists to use nice term, private citizens who almost take joy in making it difficult for a municipality to provide information.
But back to my question, does it wipe out all the provisions before relative to private citizens?
So in regards to private citizens, no, it's replacing it with something else.
Although to be quite honest about it, it is a much higher burden to prove it would be much more than 10 hours.
It is saying that's the piece in here about that it's deemed intended to disrupt or place an unreasonable burden on the essential functions of the body or presents a reasonable probability of having such effect.
So it's only if your intent there is to, or that it will actually, place an unreasonable burden on the body.
Or if it's intended to disrupt the body.
Representative Manos, I THINK YOU HAD SOME COMMENTS.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THE Ombudsman.
DO YOU VIEW THIS, REPRESENTATIVE KATAB, AS CREATING THE RIGHT OF THE MUNICIPALITY TO GO TO THE Ombudsman is this the creation of that right it is yes and that was the sticking point for the clu and for right to know new hampshire that they wanted the burden to be on the body to have to go there and not on the requester I might prefer to see that right created in a separate paragraph and to be created more clearly rather than invoking the right and having the invocation of the right be what creates it.
So that's my thought on it.
Other representative de Laurentia.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm a little bit concerned about the feeling that people other than private citizens would be able to use the ombudsman office as a um as a general routine and i only say this because i'm the prime sponsor of the ombudsman's bill and it was initially for citizens to um have a conversation with the ombudsman about, you know, issues with right to know law or issues with requests from municipalities and public bodies.
So it kind of skews things.
And it worries me because I don't want to see the ombudsman's office spend a lot of time almost time on commercial request request from, you know, big money operations.
And neglect the request from the citizens.
We only we have only have so much for capacity.
The ombudsman position is is due to sunset in 2025.
So if we were going to use the ombudsman office at that much, we would need more capacity.
Thank you.
Of course, yes, Representative Ketab.
Thank you for bringing up that point.
So the ombudsman piece, that for the um in you're talking about in relation to the commercial use request so if that piece were changed to say that the that the commercial use requester could seek relief in the superior court would that would that make better sense to you i am not totally sure because i did hear someone say that you know you can't like separate things like send your commercial request to superior court when and not give the commercial interest um a shot at the ombudsman's office so i don't i don't think that that that piece wasn't said no i don't think that's yeah but we can ask the ug's office to comment on that part but if so if that was allowed though would that be the direction that you'd prefer to go with with the commercial piece i think so okay all right other comments so one of the oh i'm sorry no representative anders i cut you off i apologize no problem thank you uh thank you to caitlin and everyone that put all the time into this bill because I know it's a lot of work but I am totally against and I won't back down from changing the current law I realize there are issues a lot of them are commercial which maybe need to be addressed but with all the the changes, to me, it's like the citizen, the everyday citizen, is the culprit, and that's totally, totally wrong.
The employees in the governing body are paid a wage, and that wage includes looking up right to no requests and giving out that information now in this bill here the law grants me the right under 3210 to ask for transfer of funds from any governing body which i did recently for my school district under this in here if the governing body decided my request was unreasonable or a burden on their agency, would my request be denied?
And are there other laws and statutes that grant a person the right to ask for information and do this amendment and the laws, I guess, bond up against each other or do they coincide or whatever?
All right.
I'm...
I...
I mean, I...
my...
If you...
All right.
I mean, my impression would be that if we adopted this amendment, if a request was determined to be unreasonable, then it would not be granted.
I mean, I suppose that the, I assume that an ombudsman or a court might say well you've asked for i mean i'm just making this up you've asked for all the emails of employee x for the last five years that's unreasonable um but i will you know i will order the town to provide the emails of employee x for the last six months.
I mean, I'm just making that up, but that might be an example.
I think, speaking personally, I think I'm where Representative Turr was.
I personally liked the original bill much better.
And let me explain to you why.
One of the things that I think everybody, including particularly requesters, should be concerned about is that if we go down this route, we are in at least to some extent.
we're changing the current law, which says it doesn't make any difference.
You don't have to tell anybody, and it doesn't make any difference why you want the information.
If you want all the emails for the last year because you want to paper your bathroom with the emails, that's good for you.
You can do that.
This would change that in a couple of ways.
First, even, for example, with the commercial requests, as I think the discussion sort of highlighted, there could be a dispute and presumably some litigation about, about well is this a commercial request or not which gets to the to the point of what do you want this information for what are you going to do with it why do you want it are you going to sell it you know because that would have some bearing on whether it's a commercial request.
Do we want to start down that road?
And the same thing, I think, would be true about maybe to a lesser extent, but still true on the question of for non-commercial requesters, is the request unreasonable because of its burdensomeness?
I mean, it seems to me that one of the things that would go into reasonableness, at least partially, is what do you want it for?
I mean, if I actually, if, you know, if I actually went to the town and said, I want all the emails for the last five years, and the town said that's unreasonable, presumably one of the things that somebody who had to decide whether it was unreasonable or not would be saying is, why do you want it?
And if I actually did say, because I want to paper my bathroom with all the emails, presumably that would, you know, would go a long way towards persuading the fact finder to say that's unreasonable.
You know, paper your bathroom with something else, but not not don't don't require the town to pay for for an employee to do this.
So, you know, that's maybe an extreme example, but I'm just trying to get the point across that.
I think this, doing it this way would change, I think, in a fundamental way, the way the right to know law has always operated.
But having said that, I, if there was a consensus to do something along the lines of this amendment, I would support it because even though I think this maybe is not as good a way as the original bill, I think based upon what we've heard that there is a real problem.
I mean, first of all, I think just as a matter of fairness, I don't see why it makes any sense for the taxpayers to have to pay for the time it takes somebody to respond, a state employee or public employee, town employee, to respond to a request from a commercial enterprise who's going to sell that information and presumably pass on the cost to its customers, why shouldn't that commercial enterprise or its customers bear the burden as opposed to the taxpayers of the town?
And secondly, I think based upon what we heard at the hearing, there really are some people that you know make unreasonable requests requests.
And sometimes, I hope not all that often, but sometimes, and not, you know, not, it's not a tiny number, are doing it because they want, they have some axe to grind with the town.
They think that, you know, the town is out to get me and I'm going to show them and they make these unreasonable requests.
And I think that's a problem and there should be some way of dealing with it.
Personally, I think that making them have to put up some money after a certain period of time is the way to do it.
But addresses it at least in some fashion and so i could support that if you know if there's a consensus for doing something like that representative alexander then representative greece thank you mr chair it it seems to me that this amendment is not adding more people to support the bill.
So it might be better for the prime sponsor to just see how the vote goes again on the original bill.
Because I don't think that, I mean, from what I'm gathering, the committee isn't on board with either an amendment on this either.
So that's my suggestion for the committee.
It might well be a good one.
Representative Greason and then Representative Devine.
Does current law define what a vexatious request is?
It is that grounds for the denial of a request.
And if it's not, then maybe we need to take this one thing at a time.
First is to define what a vexatious request is and allow that to be grounds for a request denial, and then if the party making the request is aggrieved by that, then you've got the appeal process.
But tackling this one thing at a time, if we don't even define what a vexatiousious request is we can keep throwing that buzzword around all day long and we don't accomplish anything so what if we just tackle that and we'll deal with the commercial aspect of it in some other legislation or not at all or whatever could we have the ag's office come up because they're they're here like potentially just to speak to that ground i think we did define the vexatious piece in here, but I'd like them to talk to rather...
Yeah, so if, would you, are you okay with that?
No, no, that's fine.
I think there, you know, I think there is a provision, as I understand, it's pretty general in current law about, you know, when attorney's fees are allowed, if a request is unreasonable, or if somebody's acted unreasonably.
But it's not very specific.
But yeah, please inform us.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jessica King.
I'm a senior assistant attorney general at the Department of Justice.
And good afternoon.
Good to see you all again.
I'm JD Lavallee LaVallee, also Senior Assistant Attorney General at DOJ.
And we're happy to answer any and all questions that you may have.
We're really just hoping to provide information to you all.
All right.
Well, are there questions?
So I think he was asking about vexatious defined, and I don't know if you want to elaborate on.
I know currently, like, the only place it is given anything is under 91A8, under remedies, that the court may award attorney fees to a public body or agency or employee or member, therefore, for having to defend against a lawsuit under the provisions of this chapter when the court finds that the lawsuit is in bad faith, frivolous, unjust, vexatious, wanton, or oppressive?
But I'm not sure if you know of any other area where it's defined.
That's BUT YOU HAD AN ISSUE.
I JUST HAD A COMMENT THAT AND IT'S NOT REALLY DIRECTED TOWARD the AG but I question but you had an issue i just had a comment that um and it's not really directed toward the ag but um i don't care for you know house bill 10 1002 in in the way it's been presented however some of the problems i had with it originally was it didn't really address the commercial issues, which Representative Katab has in her amendment.
To me, getting rid of maybe the fees for the public, the general public, a person like you or I, to come in and request a right-to-know request, maybe that shouldn that shouldn't be in here I'm more I would be more behind a commercial kind of you know bill that addressed everything that you had put in here within three three days or three hours or whatever instead of I mean you eliminated the 10 hours for the regular person and then so there's no charge for a regular person right now this is only a charge for commercial people that's for commercial use purposes but is it on on the first page here you have on line 24 that it in excess of three hours and that would be for so then if you go to and regular person?
Nope.
So then it says only under paragraph 4.3, and that's for the purposes of this section.
That's only for the commercial use purposes.
So there'd be no charge for a regular person coming in, getting documents that they need from this from the town correct so this is basically just for commercial purposes this which you presented correct and the only other piece it would be for a regular citizen is if their request was vexetious representative sure thank you for clarifying that oh i'm sorry representative sure yeah thanks um hopefully this is an appropriate question it's kind of the question I asked earlier in the original bill as it went to the floor the final sentence of the bill basically allowed a um a requester to go to the um ombudsman uh and and basically claim that the town's estimate for time was unreasonable um is there a reason why and this kind of relates to the question there also needs to be a path to the courts um offered to that person or is the the bill the way it went to the floor okay the way it just allows the the ombudsman to fill that role um so we were whispering as you were saying that conferring tend to agree with representative lynn on that piece it could go to the ombudsman and then have an appeal right from the ombudsman, which I believe is there in statute now.
I don't see a constitutional issue where it would go to the ombudsman first and then to the Superior Court or the Supreme Court, depending on what this body decides.
Quick clarification.
So that appeal process is already in the ombudsman statute thanks it is mr kirk yes representative lorenzo please just to clarify any person may go to court you know there's no it there's no like well you know you can't you can only go to the ombudsman if you're a citizen anyone can go to court yeah so any party can go to the ombudsman so anybody that has made a request can uh and the request has been denied that can be appealed to the ombudsman and just a point of clarification um when we're talking about vexatious there is no basis to deny a deny a request based on vexatious request.
That does not exist in law as it currently is written.
The only vexatious part is at the end if a request is denied on some other basis and it goes to the Ombudsman or to the court.
And at that point, if it's vexatious, then the agency can seek to recover fees.
But the agency or municipality cannot deny on the sole basis that's a vexatious request.
So this would be a big change in that regard.
Yes.
Right.
So you know what?
Can I just ask a question basically?
Representative Horowitz, let me just throw this question out and then we'll get to you.
Can I just ask this question?
Is, is there, if we were to make a change to the original bill in terms of the, the numbers, then it was, if instead of saying 10 hours, you know, it can start charging after 10 hours and it's $25 an hour.
If we were to change that to say we can start charging after 20 hours and it's $15 an hour, I'm just making this up.
Does that bring anybody around who was opposed to the original version?
Okay.
All right.
Just asking.
Representative Smith, does that change your mind in any regard?
Nobody knows what my position is.
Do you care to hear everything?
Do you care to enlighten me?
I want to hear everything.
All right.
Yes.
I also think a point to make is the ombudsman is written into here but i was a member of the committee when we passed it and it sunsets in 2025 so unless we as a committee or as a legislature renews the ombudsman this isn't this isn't going to solve the problem.
All right else have uh representative oregon yes yes i um remembered hearing the adjective vexatious in a hearing for another bill this committee and i was amazed discover i've been on this committee that long which was back in 2013 there's a bill about vexatious litigants although that doesn't help us with this text because it has a specific definition of vexatious litigants which was anybody who files three or four more frivolous lawsuits however and that's in a totally different chapter of the law book from 91a but i noticed in the previous right before that law which was passed in 2013 was one which dates back to the 1980s which was long before my time which does talk about frivolous actions including frivolous lawsuits so could somebody if somebody was filing totally useless large volumes of totally useless uh right to no claims they had no merit could could they under existing law be punished for filing frivolous actions or does 91a override that or how does that work and you may not know the answer i'm kind of asking a vague question that's bringing it on you but uh so on the that piece of things i'm digging into the vaults of my memory on what a vexatious litigant is but um there is a specific definition of what a vexatious litigant is and it would include um cases that are at the superior court um so it would not necessarily include a right to know requester who has made volumes and volumes of requests because again we cannot deny on the sole basis of vexation so that those claims would never or would not necessarily make it to superior court Mr.
Chair yes we have a question of the AG's office what if a complainant feels that their right to know requests with a municipality or other public body was denied based on prejudice.
What would happen there?
What's the remedy?
Thank you for your question, Representative.
I mean, at the moment, current law would allow them to contest the denial at the ombudsman or straight to superior court.
And if there's no actual basis for denial or an improper basis for denial, then the public body would be subject to, or public entity agency or public body, would be subject to the remedies under A-8, which can be the attorney's fees, the fine, the penalty, everything under law.
Well, may I follow up?
Of course.
So my thought is, yeah, that sounds great, but I think it's an exigent instance.
How quickly could a person get relief?
So under A8 and under the ombudsman process the the um right to know cases are intended to be processed pretty quickly depending on the circumstances since i know uh the aclu is behind me we've had a case we had a case go on for quite some time um but it depending on what what we're arguing about, but for the most part, these are going through the Superior Court quite quickly.
All right.
And you, Representative Andrews.
Thank you, and thank you for taking my question.
This is kind of a threefold.
number one is when is the updated governance on the 91a going to be out and is there going to be a regular schedule to update it the third question is which i don't understand what does the ag's office have to do with 91a how do you defend it and who do you defend it with?
Thank you representative.
So I can say we are tracking for March 1st for an update to the 91A memo.
I believe that's what you're referring to, right?
And we do have intentions to not only update it, but have a maintenance schedule, right?
To have a routine team working on making sure that memo stays up to date and doesn't languish.
As for, I think your third question, I think my colleague wrote it down because I did not.
I apologize.
And so I believe the third question was what role does the AG's office play in 91A?
So we are counselors to state agencies.
We are also ourselves a state agency.
So we both process 91A requests that come into our agency, but we counsel state agencies on how to respond to 91a requests especially where there are gray areas in the law all right representative manos you had a issue thank you mr chair i wanted to inquire whether the creation of a municipality's right to go to the ombudsman as i see it it's it's kind of on the fly here, and whether you view that as problematic.
Should it be more clear?
Should the right be created?
Should the right of a municipality to go to the ombudsman be created separately from the invocation of the right?
So I think I'm going to thank you for that question.
I think I'm going to take that in a couple of different pieces.
When we say creation of the agency's right to go to the ombudsman, textually speaking in the statute, any party can go to the ombudsman.
In practical terms, it really is the requester that goes to the ombudsman because the process doesn't stop until the denial happens or records aren't produced.
So in practical terms, it is the requester that goes to the ombudsman.
So I think, I don't know that we can speak to the if there are issues with the text as amended in this this amendment with the agency going to the ombudsman proactively.
I think there could be some concerns.
We just haven't had a chance to examine that.
All right.
Representative Andrews.
Thank you.
And okay, I'm going to ask a question.
And if I'm wrong, I apologize.
I understand that House bill, the original 1002, the AG's office was in favor of it.
And they don't normally take a position on the bill and why would they take a position on this one i think uh probably in the testimony that my colleague gave um the reason that we've we came out in support of this bill is it does create these incentives to work with the requester to narrow these requests that um as representative lynn had mentioned there there are these requests that are very burdensome to our agencies in which there's no real incentive for the requester to work with the agency to narrow the request, to really get to what the person is looking for.
Representative Manos.
Thank you, Mr.
So admittedly, we're working through seeing the amendment as you all are, but I think it would allow for, I think as the chairman noted, an exploration as to the intent of the request, the way vexatious is defined, right, there's an intent piece, and then there's also the impact on primary responsibilities or primary duties, as some of the other colleagues have talked about.
So I think there would be some litigation or some opportunity for litigation to, you know, argue about, hey, does this actually impact an agency's essential functions?
Is that the intent of the request?
So you are, in a way, exploring both intent of the requester or practical effect on the agency or public body.
So I guess it depends, but yes, there's room to uh explore that man so you know given the uh given the time um my i i guess if i can sum up i i i or try to sum up i think i agree basically with representative alexander and we're not going to vote this now.
We've only noticed it as a work session.
But my inclination is that it doesn't appear that the amendment proposed by Representative Kutaba, and I really thank her for her extensive work on this, is likely to kind of change the views of anybody here regarding this matter.
And so my inclination is that, Representative Alexander, is right.
When we do vote on this, we'll take a vote.
That's not to suggest that the amendment may be offered, and we'll take a vote on the amendment and see how that goes.
If anybody else has any amendments they want to propose, you're going to have two weeks to do it before we actually exec this uh again um we'll take up those also um my sense is we may end up at the point where you know the amendments the various amendments fail and then we're back to a vote on the original on the original bill um course.
I'm just wondering if anybody who was opposed to the original bill after seeing this amendment, if there's anything that could be done with this amendment or even as the amendment's written, if there's anybody who would, I guess, potentially support it, because I'm happy to work with people if there is a potential, if there's just some tweaking that that's needed but if you just don't like the amendment then i obviously that's okay i don't want to waste anybody's time though so would we be able to i guess ask by a show of hands if there is anybody that was originally opposed that would be you know potentially supportive of this amendment or if the amendment were to be tweaked a bit Representative Sapleton?
All right.
After reading it and focusing on it, I'm kind of getting into liking the amendment, except on page 2, line 14 and 15, the reasonable charges imposed here under, or under this paragraph, do not apply unless the request is a commercial use request.
I don't see anywhere else in the amendment that provides for any charge.
And it's a loophole for the unreasonable or extensive request by private citizens who may be activists or malicious intent and I think that leaves a open hole for abuse and if you were to cover that then I would be in favor of the amendment all right so I guess maybe with with that I'm going to close the work session on.
House Bill 102 and we will notice this for an executive session on on March 6th since we're not going to be sitting next week.
Right.
Right, but it will be.
I'm gonna add I'm gonna have to have an amended an amended notice all right so I'm gonna close the work session and then what I'd like to do now is open the executive session that is continued from our last executive session and the first bill bill that I'd like to say, oh, I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate your being here.
Thank you.
So the first bill that I would like to take up and I want to, because there may be people here who are interested in this, we're not going to vote on this today because people haven't had a chance to to look at the amendment but we'll briefly take up house bill 1283 the end of life options bill and what what i would note is that representative smith and myself have proposed an amendment, and I asked OLS to prepare the amendment in the form that it was instead of sort of just dealing with each paragraph where there was a change, I thought it would be easier for people to follow if they just redrafted the whole bill with the changes in there and that's what you have in amendment 202 40808 H that I passed out to the committee earlier and what what I would say is this.
Let me just try to highlight for you the changes that this makes.
The first change that it makes is there was some discussion, as you may recall, about whether it made sense to have nurses who were not advanced practice registered nurses be among, be included within the definition of healthcare provider.
And that, and that is, we've made that change.
We've removed PAs from the, just the same one.
Yeah, we've removed them from the list of health care providers.
We've also, in response to testimony that was presented at the hearing we've added pharmacists under m1 Roman numeral 5 as subsection D but note that although pharmacists are now within the definition of health care provider there we specifically indicate that they do do not qualify either as a prescribing or as a consulting health care provider there we specifically indicate that they do not qualify either as a prescribing or as a consulting health care provider so they they are included but they're not going to be the ones that making are that are making decisions on whether somebody qualifies to receive end-of-life medications the the next thing that is changed is hang on one second you yeah uh in Roman numeral, in the original bill, in Roman numeral M, it's on page 3 of the original bill.
In the original bill, on page 3, lines 9 through 15, we reworded that because I was concerned that that could be read to suggest that the prescribing health care provider could make his or her decision based on examinations and determinations of somebody meeting the qualifications that were done by somebody else.
And I was concerned about that because it seems to me that this is something where the person that's making the determination ought to be the one that satisfied himself or herself that the person is qualified and not just somebody made a report to them and they signed off on it.
So that was changed.
The other thing, and this appears at several places throughout the bill, you will notice that in the definition, one of the definitional terms is prescribing health care provider.
But if you look later in the bill, there were some times when there was a reference to the attending provider and um we never had a definition of attending provider it seems pretty clear that the that that that what the original intent was that the attending provider is the pers is the uh prescribing so to avoid some claim of ambiguity, we changed.
The word is prescribing health care provider replaces attending health care provider wherever that was used.
And I believe that the last change of any substance appears on page 6 of the original bill in sections four and five those those provisions would as drafted would have basically said that if you are a health care entity I'll give you use the example of Catholic Center, because I think it's probably the most appropriate, that Catholic Medical Center could not tell its employee doctors, you can't provide end-of-life services even outside of your employment with us or off the premises.
I think there would be a real constitutional problem with that, particularly for religious health care providers, but maybe even with others.
So we took that out.
Because I think, for example, I think how Catholic Medical Center can say to its employees, if you want to work for Catholic Medical Center as a doctor, you can't provide end-of-life care anywhere.
And if you want to provide end-of-life care, that's fine.
You just can't work for us.
I think constitutionally they're entitled to do that.
And so I think it, you know, I don't think this, from my perspective, I don't think this was an important part of the bill and why have put something in the bill that raises a constitutional question that I think is not necessary.
It does say in the revised language, and you'll see this, that if Catholic Medical Center wants to say, our doctors can't provide end-of-life care under this act anywhere, at any time, if they're working for us, then Catholic Medical Center or other providers have to say that specifically in writing and specifically indicate that it applies both on and off premises, on and off duty.
If that's the terms that they want their employees to follow, they can do it, but they just have to tell them and tell them in writing.
And I think that's a reasonable provision.
So those, I think, are the major substantive changes.
The other thing is I saw some typos in the original bill.
I made some corrections there to some of the language.
But the substantive changes are I think I've covered them all and I'm gonna ask representative Smith if if if if I've missed something please please correct me so anyway I guess what I'd say I note that Representative Perez has also provided an amendment that proposes to repeal the Suicide Prevention Council.
We can take that up and vote on it when we're ready to vote.
My inclination is that everybody will now have the amendment and any other amendments that people want to propose within, you know, for two weeks until March 6th, which is when we will exact this again.
And I'll make sure it gets into the notice when we are ready to have a vote on this.
Yes, Representative, you had a question.
Mr.
Chair, I appreciate it.
I try to be, when I'm a substitute, Representative Schultz is my name, by the way.
Sure.
I try to be as low-maintenance as possible because I enjoy subbing and I defer to the wisdom of committee members.
What I realized, though, is there, I don't, other than a note that this is continuing your executive session of the 15th, she knows what I'm asking for.
Thank you.
Sorry to bother you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
I'm not sure that I know, but yes, Representative Perez.
Representative Alexander.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So the only problem I have is that I was ready to vote on this bill last week, and I'm ready to vote on this bill this week.
I'm wondering if the chair would entertain a motion of ITL to see where the committee is at, and if it doesn't pass, then the committee can go back to the drawing board.
But I feel like we keep bringing this up for exec and then say we're not voting on it.
Why don't we just create a work session with the members that want to get to a yes on this is my question.
Okay, well, I think, I mean, I think that that's not an appropriate thing to do because I think that people ought to have at least an opportunity to have looked at and kind of studied what is, you know, a fairly complicated bill.
So I don't think it would be appropriate to have looked at and kind of studied what is a fairly complicated bill.
So I don't think it would be appropriate to have a vote now.
Representative Perez.
Thank you.
I have studied this bill.
I have studied this bill line by line, and I have some information that I would like to present to the committee.
Is that possible?
Sure.
Absolutely.
Okay.
First, I would like to address the University of New Hampshire poll where it has been said multiple times that 71% of the people in the state of New Hampshire support this option.
I obtained the poll.
I actually spoke to Rebecca Brown from the New Hampshire Alliance for end-of-life options, and I have a lot of concerns.
I actually spoke at length with a man named Zach Esman about how the pollers are solicited, and I don't mean that in a negative way.
So let me explain a little bit about my concerns about this.
First of all, the poll was paid for $1,800 by the New Hampshire Alliance for end of life options.
And there were only two questions that they asked for.
And then the university adds a million things, like what do you think of Governor Sununu for demographics.
The first question that was asked, as you may or may not know, medical aid in dying laws give mentally capable, terminally ill adult patients who have six months or less to live the right to request and use a prescription medication to end their life if they choose.
Would you support or oppose legislation in New Hampshire that would allow mentally capable, terminally ill adult patients who have six months or less to live to live the legal right to use prescription medication to end their own life?
Very valid question for what we're talking about.
What really concerned me is question number two by the same organization.
Do you identify as having a disability?
A disability is a physical or mental impairment that seriously limits your life activities, such as conditions affecting a person's vision, movement, thinking, remembering, learning, communicating, hearing, mental health, or social relationships.
That concerned me because in my opinion it had absolutely nothing to do with this bill.
So I actually called Rebecca Brown and asked her why that.
And her response to me was that we need to consider vulnerable communities.
Those were her words, vulnerable communities, which again struck a chord.
And I asked, what about veterans?
What about depressed teens?
I found it very disheartening or something that that question was asked.
When I asked how people were picked, they have a company that does this and that, blah, blah, blah, and people are picked.
And then they send out randomly, do you want to participate in a survey?
There's a three-part thing.
They send text messages, this and that, mail, and people respond.
And if people respond that they want to participate, then they are invited to become part of a, and they want to participate again, they're invited to become part of a Granite State panel.
And this panel receives the surveys.
This panel is rewarded for participation.
So those were some of my concerns about that.
And then my other thing is that wording, you can word anything to get your answers.
For example, if I asked you if you were in favor of reproductive freedom or rights, I would bet everybody in this room would say yes, they were.
But if I asked you if you were in favor about abortion restrictions it would certainly split this the answers to these people.
I have concerns about this survey.
I have concerns about how this survey is being used to whatever the bill.
Now moving on from, I did literally go through this line by line.
And on line eight, and I'm going by the original bill, mental capacity, okay?
Durable power of attorney cannot be enacted.
I think we need to say that lines 12 through 14 a health care entity okay a weight loss clinic by this definition is a health care entity a medispa run by a doctor is a health entity.
I have a concern about the use of healthcare entity in here and that it is not tight.
In 15 through 20, a healthcare provider.
A healthcare provider and in the bill, it said according to, where is it according to rs a 329 it could be my retired dentist um i gotta oh here it is 329.
a person shall be regarded as practicing medicine under the meaning of this chapter, who shall diagnose, treat, perform surgery, or prescribe any treatment of medicine for any disease or human ailment.
Surgery means a procedure including, but not limited to, laser, in which human tissue is cut, shaped, burned, vaporized, or otherwise structurally altered, except that this session shall not apply to any person to whom the authority is given by any other statute to perform acts which might otherwise deem the practice.
Laser means a light application.
So if I go to a medispa and have a laser treatment, That person, according to this and according to this, can be eligible, or it could be argued that they are eligible to prescribe my life-ending prescription.
So you don't think that the language who is qualified, a prescribing health care provider means a health care provider who is qualified by specialty or experience to make a professional diagnosis and prognosis regarding the individual's disease and prescribes medical assistance and dying medication?
You don't think that that's sufficient?
Well, I think anybody who goes through anyone who goes through and you're using a nurse practitioner here as well, anyone could be considered if they had treated any of those things at any time could be qualified.
For example, if you go to a, I'm going to use a dentist again, you go to a dentist and he discovers mouth cancer on the inside of your jaw and treats that, he would be considered, could possibly, according to this, be considered a specialist in cancer.
It's too open-ended.
Let me go on.
Page 2.
1 through 2.
Number 2.
Am I on page 2?
Yes.
1 and 2.
The interviewer has a right to withdraw a request pursuant to this chapter or consent, any of their treatment at any time.
What happens to that legal, lethal medication?
What happens to it?
We're not supposed to be keeping leftover antibiotics at home.
Why would we keep, what happens to that lethal med?
Number six, peaceful death.
I have a great article here on the efficiency and safety of drugs used for assisted dying.
Very frightening.
Peaceful death does not come to all who use these drugs.
Peaceful death, evidence from jurisdictions where assisted suicide is legal, reveals that some patients who ingest the prescribed lethal drugs experience distressing complications.
The Canadian Association of MAID assessors and providers acknowledges that patients who ingest assisted suicide drugs can experience burning, nausea, vomiting, and regurgitation, especially if the patient has difficulty swallowing large volumes of fluid.
Nausea, esophagitis, gastritis, severe T hydration, or pathology of gastrointestinal tract may interfere with the drug's absorption.
This is reflected in data by the U.S.
states, such as Oregon, where annual complication rates have been as high as 14.8%.
And patients are reported to have experienced difficulty swallowing or drug regurgitation seizures and have regained consciousness after ingesting these legal drugs.
That is not a peaceful death as far as I'm concerned.
It's also not a peaceful death for your family to watch if they're there with you.
Hospice.
You use hospice in talking about this.
Well, I contacted hospice.
I looked up the laws as far as Medicare is concerned, and I spoke with hospice agencies.
You say a person is eligible for hospice is one of the reasons why they can use this.
Well, in order to be eligible for hospice, okay, you have to have a terminal illness less than six months to live, but you also have to have a declining functional status.
You have to be less than 50 or 60 percent of the palliative performance scale the palliative performance scale is a fabulous scale you're 100 if you're walking around like we are today and then it goes down by your conditions i have copies of the scale here as well okay so to be to start off say you have reduced ambulation you're unable to do job work and significant disease, full self-care, normal or reduced intake, and full conscious level.
That would put you at a 70%.
You cannot use hospice for what you want and then not use hospice.
The other thing about hospice, in order to be qualified in the state of New Hampshire or for Medicare, now that's whether you have routine home care, general inpatient payer, continuous home care, or respite payer, in order to be considered for hospice, you have to have two physicians certify you for hospice one of those physicians has to be your diagnosed diagnosing position the other one has to be a hospice doctor nowhere in this bill does it mention anywhere where your diagnosing physician is involved in this.
The one who said you have a terminal illness.
The one who said you have six months to die.
Nowhere in here does it say you have to have information.
It says your medical records records work from where from your diagnosing physician or for someone you go to afterwards on the very um so i'm sorry to interrupt yeah representative but i i'm looking at m2 a prescribing health care provider page and number of page, starting at line 29.
This is on the amendment.
I mean, it's the same in the original.
It wasn't changed.
A prescribing health care provider may provide a prescription for medical diagnosis and dying medications to an individual only after the prescribing health care provider has determined that the individual has mental capacity, a terminal condition, prognosis of six months or less, or is medically certified or is enrolled in Medicare certified hospice, which meets the definition that you just said.
So that that is enrolled in.
Right in.
Right, is enrolled in.
And I thought that you said, as you read, what was required for enrollment.
Page two at the bottom.
Okay.
Determine is making decisions.
No, this is the amendment.
I don't see what you're saying.
Is enrolled in?
Has this the amendment?
Number C, M2, Roman numeral 1C, line 35.
Line 35.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm on the original bill.
This part of it wasn't changed.
It's in the original.
I'm on'm on page two line 35 and it says dying medications that the individual requests in the original bill it is at hang on let's find it let me let me finish going through this quickly and I'm sure I'm across it.
Yeah, okay.
Online 20 page 2.
Reasonable medical judgment.
I looked up a reasonable medical judgment.
Is this documented in their health care?
Is it documented that they have six months to live?
Or are you going to a totally separate doctor, like the doctor that lives in New Hampshire who helps with Vermont, are you going to a totally separate doctor and you're telling that doctor, well, my doctor says, you know, I have this illness and, you know, according to statistics, I have less than.
There's nowhere that says you have to have, you're supposed to provide your medical record.
What medical record and where is it coming from?
I'll get to that.
Page three.
Nowhere is the six months documented from who's been your treating doctor.
Page three, line five, coercion.
Coercion, okay?
This is going to come up again.
Practice of persuading someone to do something is the definition of coercion.
How do we decide that somebody has or has not numbers number seven qualifies to receive wait a minute I lost my place nine through fourteen here we go confirmed and recorded in the individual's health record that at least one licensed physician not their diagnosing physician, not their treating physician, not whoever has treated them for five years for something, but any physician, osteopath, physician, advanced nurse, or physician assistants, I think you're going to take that out, after conducting an appropriate examination that the individual has capacity, a terminal illness, and the ability to self minister medical assistance in dying, that person may be prescribing health provider pursuant to this section.
so I can be treated for my lung cancer by a doctor for multiple years, but he has, I don't have to get his permission.
I don't have to use him at all to do this.
Okay, I'm moving on.
Coercion qualifies.
9 for 14.
Under under under.
Moving on.
Coercion qualifies.
9 through 14, under hospice, your health care provider has to be one of those people.
Page 5.
I do it all.
Wait a minute.
Hang on.
I apologize.
No, I'm sorry.
We're not having it coming.
As well as confirm that the individual meets her.
Also, there's no place in here that says that the person has to have stopped treatment for whatever they're being ailed for.
If you go into hospice, you no longer, not palliative care, but if you go into hospice, you can no longer be treated for that illness, for that diagnosis that you are dying from.
Number 22.
I'm sorry I'm losing track of where I am.
Postmas Board and Safety.
Relevant medical records.
What relative medical records?
Are they real are they your medical records from your treating physician?
It doesn't say medical records from your treating physician.
These are just little as a nurse for 42 years and dealing with people dying on a day-to-day basis.
These are things that need to be in here here peaceful manner I said it's not necessarily peaceful manner also there's the question of who pays for the meds are these meds covered under Medicare are they covered under my health insurance they also say three hours roughly it says in here somewhere about hours.
I've lost place where I am.
It can take up to 12 to 18 hours to die.
There's nothing in here, and it says, or longer, but if you read information, these people don't die quickly.
If you take a Tylenol and I take a Tylenol, it's going to affect you differently than it's going to affect me.
So to say that you're not pointing at you, Representative Devine, but if you give these meds to Representative Devine and she takes them and I take them, she may die in three hours.
I may be puking and vomiting and foaming at the mouth for 10 hours.
Peaceful manner.
Medical treatment guidelines.
Appropriate to embrace medical treatment guidelines.
You say that somewhere in here.
It says that, I think this is on page four peaceful manner 48 hours could be longer oh here's what it is why are we only saying 48 hours to give these meds to be able to pick up this prescription when Oregon and Hawaii Hawaii started out, they had theirs in 15 days.
They just recently changed it.
You want to put a new law into this state, but they can pick it up in 48 hours?
For Pete's sake, they've tried to get it so you can't pick up your gun that fast, but they want to do it for 48 hours why not 15 days why not people who have gone through this whole process why not allow them to time to sit back and think about it why not be conservative about that um I just want to make sure does this say that they have to make the decision?
No, they don't have to.
So if they decided 15 days or 30 days is what they want to wait, they can wait.
Right.
But why not give them the time to wait?
Why did other people put it in as 15 days?
Telehealth.
I really have a huge issue with telehealth.
You want me Thank you.
put it in as 15 days, 15 days.
Telehealth.
I really have a huge issue with telehealth.
You want me to go and I'm a doctor and you're on a screen, okay?
Telehealth.
Who's behind me?
Who's behind you holding that gun saying, I know you think that wouldn't happen, but you know, I said to my husband, I said, so you're, you're getting to be too much of a burden for me.
Okay.
You're too much of a burden.
I can't do it anymore, John.
Too much of a burden.
Let's get on telehealth.
Oh, I don't want to do that, Christine.
Well, let me put my, my brand new gun right to your back to make sure you do it.
I mean, really telehealth.
Are don't want to do that Christine well let me put my my brand new gun right to your back to make sure you do it I mean really telehealth are you kidding me page 5 who are seeing that's again okay page 530 number 30 I have a real problem with this.
A real problem.
It says that nobody can be criminally liable.
Why are we saying that doctors cannot be criminally liable for this?
Why do we say that they, what if we have a quack?
I mean, doctors are human too, just like lawyers and stuff.
What if we have a couple of doctors that are going to open up a clinic and start doing this?
Criminally liable, that's why they carry melfast insurance.
They need to be criminally liable if they do something that shouldn't be done according to this law and specifically cause a person's death.
Page number six.
I spoke at length.
Six through nine, I think it is.
Page number six.
Sorry.
Six.
About insurance.
Okay.
Page number six.
Six through nine.
I lost my place on it.
Okay, I'm going to talk about health insurance.
About insurance.
Do we have a right to dictate health insurance?
I don't think we do with this law.
No health care entity or health insurer is subject.
We don't have a right to talk about health insurance and what they can and cannot do.
Number 22 through number 26, a health care entity may sanction a health care provider for participating in medical assistance and dying.
I understand that these health care, this all, we have a page, a page and a half protecting the doctor.
Specifically protecting the doctor from doing this.
A page and a half in a seven-page bill or a nine-page bill.
On page seven, and don't think I just did this myself.
I talked to insurance people.
I talked to hospice nurses.
I talked to doctors.
I talked, literally talked to a dentist because I said, are you covered on this?
He says, I absolutely am.
Page number seven, seven through ten.
Why are we not putting this as suicide or assistance suicide it the definition the definition i'm sorry my pages got all messed up number three was that one the definitions.
Suicide.
The act of killing oneself intentionally assisted suicide assisted suicide suicide affected affected with the absence of another person especially the taking of lethal drugs provided by a doctor for the purpose by a patient with a terminal illness or incurable condition.
That is assisted suicide's definition.
Assisted suicide, a procedure in which people take medication to end their lives with the help of others, usually medical professionals.
This practice differs from euthanasia, also called mercy killing, in which a medical professional painlessly ends a terminally ill suffering by withholding or removing life support treatment.
People often request assistance suicide because of a chronic or acute physical or mental condition that is so affected their quality of life they no longer which wish to live.
So why are we not calling this?
Why does it say that it can't be called and why is it not why is it not on I'm not gonna get to that yet page 8 page number 10.
How do you know who took this medication if there is no witness?
Okay.
What if I move out of the state with this medication?
There's no way to track this.
you have to be able to have it say that the person utilized MAID as part of their death certificate to track this.
And also, not just to track it for how many people do it or this or that, but if I have terminal cancer, I have skin cancer, okay?
A terminal skin cancer, okay?
It is also necessary because physicians or agencies use it to track the life expectancy for different ailments.
For different ailments.
They need how a person died.
If you put that the person died on this day from their terminal illness but they could possibly have lived longer and you don't put on it made then they have no way that skews everything that people are trying to keep track of um okay number insurance.
I spoke to two insurance agencies.
Why do we have accidents insurance here?
What does accident insurance have to do with this bill, a MAID bill?
Why is that there?
Is it that later down the road, in case we want to add, if somebody's in a motor vehicle accident and then they have intractable pain, we can add them easier.
Why is an annuity policy listed here?
As far as life insurance policies are concerned, we cannot, that's reflecting right in my eye.
That's okay.
We cannot go to insurance, if you have life insurance, most life insurances have a two-year waiting period, okay?
A two-year waiting period for any death and specifically a two-year waiting period for suicide.
We cannot dictate to insurance companies that you took out an insurance bill a year ago and you did this, but you have to pay.
No, you don't have to pay.
We can't dictate to the insurance company that they have to pay.
On last page, what is the law in New Hampshire on page five?
Unless otherwise prohibited by law, the prescribing provider may sign the death certificate of a qualified individual who obtained and self-administered a prescription for medications pursuant.
What is the law?
I know a nurse practitioner.
I do not believe a nurse can sign a death certificate, but I'm not sure.
Why isn't it okay for MAID to be as on the death certificate as the secondary cause of death?
Anyway, that's...
I did literally...
on the death certificate as the secondary cause of death.
Anyway, that's, I did literally go through this line by line.
I have a lot of concern.
I'm not talking about the intent of the bill.
This has nothing to do with the intent of the bill.
If you want a bill for assisted made, I get it.
This has to do with do with this bill has so many loopholes and so many loosey-goosey things that can be challenged that i do not feel the thing that you all like to use that i've heard since i've been here is it's not fit for prime time all right all right thank you as uh as i said i i didn't really want to end up having a debate on this today because we're not going to vote on it today but does anybody else have anything they want to say before i move on to things that we are going to vote on today yes representative stable thank you mr chair um thank you you, Representative Perez, for going through this in such detail.
It points out how this assisted suicide or prescription suicide is such a radical departure from our basis in law that protects the individual and holds life important and in sanctity you can formulate law with additional pages and qualifications and you probably can even make it perfect if we had enough time to do that however we're still the essential question is why to go here in the first place.
Some people have testified that this is a slippery slope.
No, it's not a slippery slope.
It's a step off the precipice.
It's an abandonment of hope, abandonment of trust in the developing care that we have in hospice and palliative care.
It misses a connection between those two things and the assisted suicide.
Six months?
Well, what if it was seven or eight months?
What if it was three or four months of a terminal diagnosis estimate?
And it is an estimate.
I mean, how many people have been diagnosed as being terminal, and you got a year to live, or you have whatever you have, and then they live for seven or eight years?
We have developing medical progress that's always finding new ways, new medicines, new cures.
And to take that pill, as far as I'm concerned, is an abandonment of trust in God and an abandonment of hope.
And ignoring the realization that we have developing medical progress and that we have fine and developing and improving hospice and palliative care for those of us on a religious basis there's no way we can subscribe to suicide that's an abandonment of hope and trust in God and entrusting his design which is inherent and healing in human beings.
Yes, we have doctors and we have medicals, but the human body has been designed to heal itself.
We need to trust in some of these basic principles.
Call them religious, call them ethics, if you will.
But this is a step over the line this is dangerous territory i can't vote for this bill even if there's 70 or 80 percent of people think it's a good idea i cannot do it all right representative alexander thank you mr chair i have a question of the sponsors of the amendment i think represent perez brought up a good point a lot of good points but one of the ones at the end was on page 9, lines 10 through 11.
A qualified individual who had obtained and self-administered a prescription for medications pursuant to this chapter.
How do we know that the medication was self-administered?
Is there any language in here to show that there's a witness seeing the administration of the medicine?
And if we don't know it's being self-administered, I would encourage you to strike that out because that could lead to a huge problem if you don't.
because nobody if if nobody's there to see that that medication was self-administered and then later in section, you say that death following self-administration medications on this chapter does not constitute grounds for a post-mortem inquiry.
It's basically saying you can, you don't have, like nobody has to be there to see that it's being self-administered.
And then you can't even check.
You can't even check because on here, it says that no grounds for post-mortem inquiry so i guess that's my question for you like i know this is an amendment i would consider if if you want to pass something with language like this i'd consider you at least revise that part that's some very problematic language all right anybody else have anything said all right so i'm gonna uh uh move on then on then to where we left off on.
Pardon?
My amendment?
When you speak to your amendment, we're not going to be voting on this today, but if you want, I suppose, if you want to quickly speak to your amendment.
I will quickly speak to my amendment.
The reason why I have this amendment that we, suicide is among, among ages 10 to 34.
Suicide is the number two cause of death.
unintentional injury is number one this is in New Hampshire and suicide is the number two cause of death.
Unintentional injury is number one.
This is in New Hampshire.
And suicide is the number two.
We had two teenagers come and speak to us, which really hit home with me, because I hadn't thought of it that way, who spoke about how they were concerned about their peers who felt that their depression was terminal.
And by allowing a bill like the one, like 1283, that it would, granted they're not, they can't use this bill, but it would certainly make them feel as though they had a legitimate, oh, the government says you can do this, so why can't I do this?
Our Suicide Prevention Council on Suicide, it's to hereby establish the Council on Suicide Prevention to put together a suicide prevention plan.
As far as I'm concerned, we might as well just get rid of it because you can't allow suicide and prevent suicide.
The United States is a strong policy of suicide prevention.
The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention recognize that suicide is a serious health, public health problem and a leading cause of death in the United States suicide and suicide attempts cause serious emotional physical and economic impacts in suicide survivors loved ones and community according to the CDC the financial toll of suicide on society is also costly in 2019 suicide and non-fatal self-harm cost the nation nearly $490 billion in medical costs.
So that's one of the reasons.
And then also the practice, the practice, this practice of assisted suicide undermines the suicide prevention policy and increases the rates of non-assisted suicide.
Congress and the states, however, have broad powers to prevent human dignity at the end of life.
So therefore, I cannot justify, I think it's ludicrous and almost a farce to continue to have the Council on Suicide Prevention and also have a bill that is allowing end-of-life options.
All right.
Are we ready to move on?
Let's move on to, I think, where we left off on House Bill 1037.
I don't know if we need to.
I scheduled them all for executive session, so I don't think we need to do that.
I'm going to move on to.
Somebody want.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, let's take why don't we take five minutes?
Is that all right?
We'll take a five minute recess.
I gotta stand up.
Let me go right here.
Thank you.
all right all right so we're waiting for uh we're waiting waiting for uh representative katab and i say that with oh she's right here in jest i mean i i don't have questions to her because i you know i will defer to her background she's going to identify things that i would right right right no exactly that's that's i mean that's the thing it's not she already said when i asked her before there's not anything you could do that would make the course or what you know i know what i get i mean maybe that's the seal because of the subject matter right right right sure sure maybe we need to have a little bit of training as far as right right right right sure sure maybe they have a little bit better training as far as what does this all sorry right right right right right now you're what that what that in the past all right um all right yeah we're waiting for i'm waiting for representative page and representative uh greece oh page and greece pages was right here well I think we're offsetting penalties.
You never know.
Right.
Someone said to me the other day, don't they have a person, however, the vice chair or the ranking general?
Those are suggestions.
Just like soft signs and revelations.
Right.
Suggestions.
I suppose.
Yeah, yeah.
No, that's.
That is ten.
That's one of those pages of things that people don I think we have everybody I think we have everybody back so I don't know whether I need to do this or not but I just for the record I'm going to recess the hearing on 12 83 and we'll resume that.
I'm not the hearing, the executive session.
And we'll resume that on March 6th.
So now I'd like to turn to HB 1037.
As I recall, and Representative Katab, if I'm wrong, please correct me.
But I believe when we broke from our last executive session on that bill, we had on representative tur's amendment and that failed on the 10 to 10 vote and then before we moved on to anything else we we recessed sorry he was through his motion and represented Smith had withdrawn her second on the amendment so the the adoption of the amendment had failed 10 to 10 and then we the vote had not been called on the other motion so it was okay that we left it but now there's nothing essentially on the table so any motion can be put in at this point is what i've been told the amendment um could only be revisited if we took a vote to reconsider and the reconsideration vote prevailed then the amendment can be reconsidered otherwise it's already been voted on all right so um so representative smith thank you in terms of uh amendment to bill 1037 with no amendment now before us, I would move interim study.
Is there a second?
TO BILL 1037 WITH NO AMENDMENT NOW BEFORE US I WOULD MOVE INTERIM STUDY IS THERE A SECOND SECOND ALL RIGHT THEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK TO YOUR MOTION REPRESENTATIVE SMITH YES THE BILL REPEALS THE STATUTE THAT PROVIDES LIMITED LIABILITY TO MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTERS DEALERS or in The bill repeals the statute that provides limited liability to manufacturers, distributors, dealers, or importers of firearms or ammunitions.
It is a bill that is very close to the hearts of many members of the House, some in support and some opposed.
We know that the industry is very important in the state of New Hampshire in terms of employment and in terms of, to the limited extent that we still have some business taxes, in terms of revenue.
We also know that we are living at a time when, at a rate that cannot please anyone, weapons are being used in a way where neither the manufacturers nor most responsible gun owners support in terms of, let's not go past last week when the Super Bowl parade erupted.
And it was interesting to me that at the beginning, the police told us that the people involved were juveniles.
In fact, it turns out that they weren't.
They were adults who were having a fight and just pulled out their respective guns because they had access and shot not just at each other, but at almost two dozen other people, including children, any number of whom are still hospitalized because of the extent of their injuries.
I don't think anybody at Sig Sauer or any place else wants to see children injured.
But there has to be some way to acknowledge that we might have some things a little bit out of control.
In addition, I would go back to something that our colleague, Representative Perez, talked about, and that is the use of guns.
I don't want to just say weapons, but the use of guns in suicide because they are available in so many households to both adults and children, although I'm sure they're not available to children in homes where people take seriously the need to hold their weapons in a secure way.
There are just a lot of factors here.
And rather than add to the smoke about the issue and rather than add to a rallying cry about, yes, we should do everything we can to promote the industry, and no, we shouldn't allow any guns in the country, and we should hold gun manufacturers accountable for things that they themselves did not participate in, I would like to take a time out and have us look at the bill and see if it's possible to come up with something where people on both sides, on all sides of this issue, might find a little common ground.
I, as you know, tend to bend over backwards to ignore traditional divisions, R's and D's, gun owners and not gun owners.
I believe that there's a middle ground that if we work together, we could get to yes.
And rather than have kind of a knee-jerk reaction with everybody on one side voting one way and everybody on the other side voting another, I would like to see if we could come up with a reasonable, modest approach to the issue.
And because of that, I would move interim study, even though I'm the first person to say do you realize that that means that you're going to get stuck on the interim study committee and i i do and i think the issue is important enough for me to be willing to do that so that's why i support interim study all right representative horgan i've i was a co-sponsor of this bill and I co-sponsored a similar bill a few years ago.
That time, that was when Representative Kathy Rogers was still with us.
And I think the gun industry is a major employer in this state, and actually I haven't really heard of threatening that explicitly to move out of the state if we if we actually pass this bill because um they have especially six hour who are located the next town over from myself and revenue smith at newington but also there's several other major gun manufacturers i think they um i mean i think they have at least i think basically they're trying to be reasonable and they recognize their products are dangerous and actually in case of sick sour i think they primarily market towards uh uh the police the law enforcement market uh the like private security market especially the military market so they're not actually i mean they do make some attempt to market, you know, just people like the firearm lifestyle, but that's actually not their primary business.
So I think they're not necessarily Second Amendment extremists, although they certainly, I mean, certainly we'd like to have fewer regulations than more.
And also in the case of Sig Sauer, they have an ongoing product liability issue.
And actually, I had a long conversation a few weeks ago with the government relations person.
He had what sounded like a fairly reasonable explanation, which was partially that they have offered modifications to a particular very popular line of pistols, which many people have accidentally shot themselves while using.
And they do have a modification, which many gun owners have taken advantage of.
Some haven't.
And most of the law enforcement, military, and security personnel actually asked for that modification to put a safety catch on.
At least that's that's my recollection the conversation they haven't chosen to participate in this debate so you can take that with a grain of grain of salt if you want to but I um so I think I think they're the they're really the only industry that has like a blanket immunity like that and I don't think that's appropriate and I'm really I'm too optimistic, but I'm not convinced they would like just, they and the other manufacturers would get up and moved across the border to Maine or Vermont or wherever else, because they have hundreds of millions of dollars invested in our community.
They've got a specialized workforce that likes living here and working here.
And so I don't think they're going to pick up.
I don't, if I thought they were going to pick up and move and throw all those people out of work, I would not have co-sponsored the bill.
But that's, so I, you know, so I'm probably going to vote against the interim.
I would prefer like off to pass, obviously, and I'll probably just vote against interim study.
Although I think that a pretty that's certainly more positive result than what i was expecting which was that it would be it held so i think all right so thank you representative turn can i first ask um has representative smith's motion been seconded yet yes they were seconded by representative page Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Missed Page.
Okay, sorry, missed that.
Just coming back around to, I think, echo some of what Representative Smith was saying.
Obviously, I put forward an amendment that I thought was an attempt to, rather than move completely to a full repeal of the bill, an attempt to make a what i thought was very more modest um adjustment to the underlying bill um uh maybe i'll speak to that when we actually have a motion um other if depending on where this motion goes to but i think in in general um i want to say that was one attempt at fixing or amending what I think are some real issues with the immunity law the way that it's stated, because it actually allows people to claim in the gun industry an exemption that no other industry has, even if they are found by a jury to have committed a felony by the same standard that a civil claim would be would be brought on so um i think the interim study would be a useful exercise to see whether or not we can find a better way forward and i hope that we would support it all right anyone else wish to be heard?
Representative Greeson.
I don't know how we can hold the manufacturers, distributors, dealers, or importers of firearms or ammunition responsible for the actions of the consumer that purchased said firearm.
I've heard that this immunity  there's no other corporation or enterprise that is granted such immunity, and yet there is one that has immunity.
And I remembered hearing during testimony that this immunity that the firearms manufacturers have means they don't have to innovate.
Flip that around and insert the word vaccine manufacturer, and you will find that they do have immunity beyond even what the firearms manufacturers have.
and not only do they have immunity, it's at the federal level that they have this immunity such that they don't even have to acknowledge that the...
And not only do they have immunity, it's at the federal level that they have this immunity such that they don't even have to acknowledge that their product is defective in any way or caused any kind of injury at all, even after this vaccine court has determined that somebody was injured by the product.
They are granted this immunity was granted to the vaccine manufacturers because they were being sued.
And because there was no innovation, that was the fear.
They're getting sued, so they're not going to innovate.
So we need to give them immunity.
Now we're being told that this immunity is causing a manufacturer not to innovate.
So you can't have it both ways.
I just don't see how in the world I can't hold them responsible for the actions of the individual who purchased the weapon any more than I can hold any other business accountable for your actions or my actions.
Representative Stapleton.
Yeah, we have a gun problem here.
We have, well, not a gun problem, but a behavior problem.
We've got to do something about the wanton, reckless, irresponsible use of firearms.
But this is not the bill for that.
taking and hammering the gun manufacturers for personal irresponsibility and reckless use is apples and oranges.
And it's going to have a harmful effect.
After the Sandy Hook massacre, Remington was sued.
I forget the amount of the judgment.
they're in the bankruptcy and they're just closing their plant in Ileon, New York.
What, a couple of hundred employees going to go out without work in a town of about 7,600.
If we replicate that here, we've got Sig Sauer and we've got Ruger and maybe a couple other smaller manufacturers and maybe support industries as well that support these.
We're just hammering the wrong party here.
We need perhaps a bill that addresses irresponsible and reckless use of firearms with some civil and criminal penalties added to the law, crimes with guns.
Any number of innovative ideas can be applied to creating legislation and a law, but hammering the gun manufacturers with the loss of the immunity is just not the way to go it's just going to create a harmful effect here and any other anyone else representative for it um a question for you representative smith do you have any idea of what you might want to put to change to make this um to change this bill if we had an interim study?
I mean, did you have any ideas at all?
If I knew the answer, I would have come forward with an amendment.
My point is that there are 20 people on this committee, I believe overwhelmingly people of goodwill, faced with a challenge to see if there's a way forward that we would put our heads together.
If that assumption is wrong, then that will be reflected in a refusal to support the concept of interim study.
I guess that answers the question.
Follow it?
Yes.
Do you happen to know if the two men that shot at the thing were legal gun owners or not legal gun owners?
Because I think we're dealing with, we have 82.88 million legal gun owners in the United States.
I actually thought the number was higher than that.
Oh, that's how many owners.
But you can't really tell because everybody has different gun laws.
I personally don't think we have a problem with gun owners.
I think we have a problem with illegal gun owners.
I think we have a problem with mental health.
Most of the people that go out and kill have mental health problems.
Chicago has tightest, Illinois has the tightest gun laws in the nation.
They have shootouts with illegal guns over the weekend, constantly in some of the highest highest i said hurting the manufacturer and the legal seller let's go after the ones that have them illegal and those with mental health problems is my opinion so anyone else have anything they want to say representative staples within the last two weeks we had two shootings inaremont.
Fortunately, nobody was killed.
A ranger on Front Street.
Some kids were rifling through automobiles or attempting to get into them.
And an owner fired a shot to dispel the activity.
He's been called into justice.
And just yesterday, there was a road rage incident in front of Cumberland Farms on Pleasant Street.
Guy pulls out a gun and fires it at his road rage opponent.
Fortunately, the bullet didn't hit anybody, including innocent bystanders, but could have.
The manufacturers have nothing to do with these two cases or thousands of other cases of reckless and irresponsible use.
Both of the individuals in this case are being brought to justice under existing law.
And if anything, we could maybe strengthen it, but it needs a separate law reckless irresponsible use of firearms and civil and criminal penalties added to what we have on the statute crime with guns not withdrawing the the immunity from the gun manufacturer who has nothing to do with these particular awful cases.
All right.
Anyone else?
Representative Page.
I guess one thought i would have a comment on this is that it seems like i mean i've heard different um factual assertions made different um thoughts about where liability should be or shouldn't be different suggestions suggestions about mental health and so on, but it does seem to me that at the same time at bottom, I would respectfully suggest, I think everybody shares the assumption, and again, I don't speak for everybody, that we have a problem.
But we don't know, it seems that the interim study forum would be the right forum to consider different facts, different assertions, different ideas about where that liability would be.
So I think even as we're having this discussion that seems to air some discrepancies about what we believe or what we think is true or whatever, it seems me to make the argument for an interim study strong all right representative turk yeah i just wanted to make one one more statement um in response to representative perez's statement um i believe she was referring to the recent chester arms um supreme court decision is that is that right okay um okay i'm not sure if she was um but anyway points the same um that case came out a few weeks ago um it basically in terms of whether whether or not the this this law doesn't just give immunity manufacturers it gives immunity to to um sellers of of weapons the court case was again, I'm interpreting as a non-lawyer, centered around whether or not that sale was legal or not.
And the person in question, without dispute, had a long history of legal problems, a long history of mental problems.
the court reviewed the statute as it stands right now and you use the plain language reading of the law for the most part clarify that because of the way the statute is written and and by the way i think you had said shot at something these were two police officers that were shot by this person so i want to make it very clear i don't think i hope nobody around the table thinks that was a good outcome that somebody who had a long history of mental health and um and and legal issues um should be allowed to shoot two police officers whether or not that sale was illegal is sort of more the question on the table.
And so I guess in defense, again, of interim study, if we don't agree that that was the right outcome, that to me would be the reason for us to put some extra work into this rather than saying everything's okay.
Because that Supreme Court case came down and said that sale, based the current way that that things are structured was not illegal um and therefore um not only it had nothing to do with whether the case had merit it had to do with whether the case could even have in my understanding uh standing that the plaintiff could even even ask for it and and the answer was no so again i think that would be use of good use of our time all right um mr jenner if i might just to add to that in essence what the supreme court did reaffirm is that that actor who shot the two police officers was not a prohibited person uh in the opinion of the state or the federal government what is also not talked about uh in this particular case is what's called the fireman's rule goes back about 100 years and the intent of the statute and it does apply here in new hampshire firemen police officers first responders they have it in their employment contracts that there's a chance you could get shot at or injured or killed in the line of duty.
And as such, you cannot sue civilly because of that.
That would really apply in this particular case we're talking about, the fireman's rule.
So legally and technically, they really didn't have grounds to sue civilly.
That's why there's no civil case.
All right, Representative Ford.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Representative Ford.
Well, I was actually born in Chicago.
You were talking about Chicago.
There's a lot that goes into the rate of gun violence in Chicago.
It's not just Illinois' gun laws.
In fact, actually, it's probably somewhat overstated how dangerous Chicago is, and I spent part of my childhood there because I was originally in Illinois.
Illinois and Indiana are separated by basically an imaginary line that's drawn on the ground, which actually goes right through the middle of the Chicago metropolitan area.
And that's true to actually the Illinois of the Massachusetts, New Hampshire state line, too, which we're a little bit farther from our state lines, a little bit farther from downtown Boston than the Indiana state line is from the loop.
But it's still not a long distance and people can easily transport guns.
And certainly at least people in Massachusetts have the perception that a lot of the gun violence is guns are being bought in New Hampshire, where the gun laws are somewhat more permissive than in uh than in Massachusetts and that's certainly like where a lot of the guns in uh Chicago come from people buy them in Indiana and drive from a few miles across the state line so I think um so I don't I don't think we should necessarily uh blame Illinois's gun laws for what's it's not the only cause of what's going on Chicago so that's that's, and so I don't, sorry, I mean, I just wanted to defend my, at least defend the city where I was metropolitan area lived in when I was nine, mostly on the Indiana side of the imaginary line.
But that's, so I don't think, so I don't think strong gun laws cause gun violence, nor do looser ones won't necessarily prevent it either.
So in fact, if anything, gun laws are a reaction to the level of violence in the place.
Places like New Hampshire and Vermont are more permissive, mostly because people aren't as afraid of gun violence because it's a more peaceful place than some other parts of the country so you know anyways all right um so i i guess i think we're probably ready for a vote on this i guess i i want to say maybe it's sort of a for my comment i intend to vote against the uh interim study motion and i do it for this reason.
With great respect for the ranking member, this is an area where I think, at least for me, there is no feasible option that I could imagine involving holding manufacturers or dealers liable for what happens when somebody criminally misuses a gun.
And bear in mind that this immunity has nothing to do with like a defective gun.
If the gun goes off when it's dropped because the trigger mechanism isn't right right that the manufacturer can clearly be sued this is this is designed to uh if this immunity were gone the kind of lawsuits that we would see against manufacturers are along the lines of well you, you manufactured an AR-15.
Even though it's perfectly lawful, let's see if we can get a jury to say that that's unreasonably, it's defective and unreasonably dangerous because you shouldn't have sold it at all.
That's the kind of lawsuits that would be allowed.
And so this, it just seems to me that even if we were to interim study this, when it's time to write something, we would be, my suspicion is we're going to vote.
We're going to be, we're going to have a 10-10 vote on interim study.
And if we did, if it turned out to be an 11-9 vote in favor of interim study, when it's time to write something on interim study at the end, we would be 2-10-10.
Ten people would say, we should further take some action, and ten people would say, no, this is a really bad idea.
So I don't think that that advances the ball at all.
My suspicion is we're going to have a 10-10 vote on interim study.
Then somebody's going to make a motion of ought to pass the original bill, and we're going to have a 10-10 vote on that.
And then when this company's going to make a motion for ITL, and we're going to have a 10-10 vote on that.
And my only  I may be predicting wrong, but my only sort of  you know, from my perspective, my only sort of  the only  what I think may be something of a bright spot in this is I think when all these things get to the floor, I believe the people who feel as I do will have the majority because there will be some people in the other party who will agree with what I think most, if not all, Republicans believe.
Mr.
Chair, I would like to object to you describing this along strict party lines.
It is not a party line issue.
There might be more people on one side than the other, but this is not something where you will see an absolutely uniform vote the way we do for example about those people who believe in public education oh no no I thought in fact I thought exactly exactly what I said was that it when it gets to the floor it will not be a strict party line vote I suspect that there will be quite a so I I agree with you.
I don't think it is a strict party line vote.
Sorry, I misunderstood what you said.
Oh, all right.
All right.
Yes, Representative Stapleton.
Hypothetically, if this were to go to interim study, an amendment has made, could an amendment actually remove the, or supplant the immunity removal provision with responsible, irresponsible, reckless gun usage?
Or is that, would that not be germane?
Or was there a problem with radically changing the bill and the interim study in that manner?
I'd be happy to answer that if it's all right with you.
The interim study can come.
Don't forget, we won't be voting on the results of the interim study because this is the second year of the term.
What we would be doing is recommending for future legislation or not recommending.
And the report that we write can have anything in it.
We can say, this is the bill that came to us.
We do not think that this bill was an appropriate vehicle.
Instead, what we believe dealing with the issue of guns, we think X or Y or Z.
So we have, it depends upon the seriousness of the people who agree to be on the Interim Study Committee.
We can come up with anything we please.
And over the years, we can all give examples of where there were dramatic changes through the interim study process, and then someone would file a new bill that came closer to what the Interim Study Committee recommended.
Otherwise, it would be just, this isn't a case, Representative Stapleton, of trying to give a gentle end to a bill.
It is a case where I, and I was serious in what I said, where I think we might be able to find something that needs to be done and set out a way to do it.
Yeah, that was my question, if that flexibility was possible within the interim study.
But it comes back to the committee for a vote on the recommendation, right?
Well, the full committee, there would be a subcommittee and the subcommittee might consist of the entire committee if everybody wanted to participate, not likely.
But then what would happen is the chair of the full committee would hold a committee meeting near the end of October for this and any other bills that were under interim study for the full committee to agree or not agree on the recommendations of the sub committees.
And that would then be the report that gets filed.
Thank you.
All right.
Any, any other, any other comments?
So I think we're probably ready for a vote.
On the motion is interim study.
Moved by Representative Smith.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
No.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
No.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
No.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Greeson.
No.
Clerk of Tab votes no.
Rep Perez.
No.
Rep Smith.
Yes.
Rep Horrigan.
It may come as a surprise given my previous remarks, but I'm going to vote yes on the interim study motion.
Rep.
DeLorenzo?
Yes.
Rep.
Schultz?
Yes.
Rep.
Page?
Yes.
Rep.
Devine?
Yes.
Rep.
Lanza?
Yes.
Rep.
Manos?
Yes.
Rep.
Tura?
Yes.
Rep.
Howard?
Yes.
Chairman Lin?
No.
Motion fails 10 to 10.
Mr.
Chair.
Yes.
Is there an opportunity for me to move ITL?
I will recognize Representative Alexander for a motion.
Thank you.
I'd like to move an expedient to legislate.
I second.
Seconded by Representative Kutab.
Any further discussion?
Representative Terp.
Yeah.
Thanks.
So i did say i might make a little bit more uh clear um about the vote whether i assumed it would potentially get to itl or otp so i'm gonna vote against itl um but i wanted to make it clear what I think the exercise of going through the amendment process and the discussion around the interim study question helped me clarify.
the amendment that I tried to offer, which I accept we did not support, that basically said for this one blanket immunity that exists in our law, I think the issue with the vaccines is different.
Blanket immunity, which says you can't even bring a case because of this.
The attempt was to say, only if you are found by a jury based on the same evidence needed to bring a civil case, that you committed a felony in the sale or manufacture of the weapon in question that got used, then not that doesn't mean you would win that case, it means you could at least be heard.
So it was a very small attempt to, to clarify what I think is one of the more glaring issues with the statute the way it stands, because right now it says, even if a jury would have found that you committed, and's the word that I tried to insert, was committed instead of convicted of, because convicted of requires a separate trial that can either not be brought or that can fail for reasons that have actually not a lot to do with the underlying question of whether those acts were committed.
that was the attempt.
So it was an attempt to say, could we find something to move us slightly forward on this so that we're inching in the right direction?
But it wasn't possible.
So right now, the law basically says even if a jury would have found that you committed a felony in the sale or manufacture of that weapon that was used in that way, the person who was injured does not have any ability to be heard in court.
And so to me, that's a big problem, considering it's the only industry that has that blanket protection.
And so that plus the fact that we are so sure that we can't move forward on this, that it wasn't worth the time that I think some of us were willing to spend thinking about it.
That is leading me to vote against the ITL, even though I tried.
It wasn't an exercise in futility.
It was an exercise to sort of test what the limits were.
But that's going to be my reason to vote against ITL.
Thanks.
All right.
Any other comments?
Are we ready?
Yes, Representative Devine.
My reason to vote against the ITL is all about the manufacturer's intention of producing a weapon.
Their intention is either to target practice or kill someone.
So that's already established unless they can change what they're thinking or what they're doing when they're producing a product that is primarily used for either killing or targeting, killing either humans or an animal.
It's a weapon.
And the intention for the distributor is to kill it's already there that's their intention for the product is it not so i would move i'm voting itl on this Representative Greeson.
In personal defense, the use of a firearm is to stop the threat.
Sometimes you need to use deadly force, but when you...
the objective is to stop the threat.
Police officers are trained, you shoot to kill, because if they shoot to injure that opens them up to liability you can't just blow out his kneecap you have to shoot for center of mass all right any other comments all right i think we're ready for the vote then the motion uh before us is representative alexander's motion of it.
And I think I'd ask the clerk to call the roll.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
Yes.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
Yes.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
Yes.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Greeson.
Yes.
Clerk Kutab votes yes.
Rep Perez.
Yes.
Rep Smith.
Rep Horrigan.
No.
Rep DeL de lorenzo no rep schultz no rep page no rep divine no rep lonza no rep manos no rep tur no rep howard no chairman lynn yes motion veils 10 to 10.
All right is there another emotion well I don't know I mean is there yeah well I just I'm just asking you just to make sure that they're all right so there is no other motion so it'll go on the regular calendar on a uh without recommendation sure yes all right all right all right so it's uh been moved by representative manno seconded by representative horrigan uh otp are we ready to call the role on that yes yes of course All right.
All right.
So are we ready to call the roll?
I think so.
The motion is OTP by Representative Manos.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
No.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
No.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
No.
Rep Tripp rep trip no rep Greeson no Clark Catabbo it's no rep Perez no rep Smith Rep.
Horrigan.
Yes.
Rep.
DeLorent.
rep horrigan yes rep de lorenzo no rep schultz yes rep page yes rep divine yes rep lanza yes rep manos yes Repturer.
Yes.
Rep Lanza.
Rep Manos.
Yes.
Rep Turrer.
Rep Howard.
Uh, no.
Chairman Lin.
No.
Motion fails 7 to 13.
So, you know what, Representative Smith, I'm going to ask you to help me out.
So, the OTP has failed, but ITL has also failed so it does it go to how does it go to the floor now even right okay right that's what I thought.
And someone would be responsible for ITL on the floor.
And someone would be responsible for interim study on the floor, OTP doesn't make the grade.
Doesn't make the grade, right, okay.
That's what I thought.
I mean, there'd be no reason for us to go back again because we've established.
Right.
So, okay, so it's going to be without recommendation on Bo and so for the report the report would say basically would would basically spell that out that it was an idea that it was a.
one person would write a report for um ITL and one would write one would write a report okay for interim study and my guess, I don't know, this would be the clerk's call, ordinarily the ought to pass motion goes first.
Right.
And in this case, there is no ought to pass motion, so the clerk will decide and the speaker will decide whether interim study is the first motion the full house will consider or whether it's ITL.
And I have an idea of what it would be, but I wouldn't know for sure.
That would be up to the clerk and the speaker.
week all right so do i have a volunteer to write the itl report representative alexander all right and how about the interim study report all right and i don't do anything syndrome studies all right so you're off to All right.
So you're off to look at Representative Manos.
All right.
Next, I'd like to move on to House Bill 1020.
That's establishing a commission to study implications of insanity and restoration of competency.
I recognize Representative Kutab.
I believe she has an amendment.
I would move I would move OTP with the adoption of amendment 2024-0703H, which I passed out to everybody last week.
Excuse me.
10-20.
1020.
It's the establishing a committee to study restoration of competency.
you you 0703.
amendment.
Thank you.
All right.
Do you wish to speak to the amendment, Representative Patab?
So the amendment is changing the members of the committee as per suggestions that had come out at the hearing.
Rep.
Pearson went and put this together for the suggestions that had come out.
Right.
All right.
Any further discussion on the amendment?
So I think we can do a show of hands on that.
those in favor of the amendment please raise your hand anyone opposed all right it's unanimous so that's we gotta hang on one second all right and so now uh on the main bill uh otpa the bill as amended um anyone wish to uh so i'm i move otpa on that yeah yeah have to have a motion first.
That's right.
Is there a second?
All right.
Any further discussion?
And I'd ask the clerk to please call the roll.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
Yes.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
Yes.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
Yes.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Greeson.
Yes.
We could have votes yes.
Rep Perez.
Yes.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
Yes.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Greeson.
Yes.
Rep Perez.
Rep Smith.
Yes.
Rep Horrigan.
Rep DiLorenzo.
Yes.
Rep Schultz.
Rep Page.
Yes.
Rep Devine.
Rep Lanza.
Yes.
Rep Manos.
Rep Turrer.
Yes.
Rep Howard.
Chairman Lynn.
Yes.
Rep.
Lanza.
Yes.
Rep.
Manos.
Yes.
Rep.
Turer.
Yes.
Rep.
Howard.
Yes.
Chairman Lynn.
Motion passes 20 to 0.
Okay.
All right.
And Representative Katab, could I ask you to write the report?
Copy to.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
This can be on consent huh consent anyone yeah okay next is with regard to House Bill 1082 I spoke to Representative Turin and also Representative Manos, and there's sort of a tricky little issue here about, I think we all want to get to where Representative Turrer wants to get to with his amendment, that is to allow an assistant manager to be able to wind up a company, but there's this issue about, particularly in the legal context, is there some things that an assistant, would the assistant manager just by virtue of that somehow be violating the requirements of that only a lawyer can practice law?
I mean, arguably a position, but I think it might become more questionable with a lawyer.
At any rate, what has been suggested, and I think is an excellent idea, is rather than vote on this today, I'd like to appoint a subcommittee of Representative Ter, Representative Manos, myself, and Representative Ming.
That's right.
And maybe we should make Representative Ming the chair.
No, I'm kidding.
I was thinking when you're not here, when you're not here, we volunteer you to be the chairman of the subcommittee.
But I won't do that.
I'll make Representative Turner the chairman of the subcommittee so that we can work on this.
And hopefully, I mean, we should be able to find a solution to this problem because I understand the problem completely.
It makes a lot of sense.
And hopefully we'll be able to do that.
The only thing I would suggest to Representative Turner, just I think there, I mean, we have, we're not, we're not to do this by tomorrow, but we only, we only do have probably three weeks or so before we got to get, you know, this has got to, so if we can move relatively quickly on this, I'd appreciate it.
Understood.
Okay, great.
All right, uh 10 89 um this is the uh the one to uh eliminate the statute of limitations with regard to uh pfas um so uh do i have a motion all right my second all right um so it's been moved and seconded representative smith would you like to speak to your emotion yes I hesitated at first when I looked at this bill about removing the concept of statute of limitation because things shouldn't go on forever except in this case the chemicals go on forever.
And the problem is that they are every place, they go on forever and Saint Albain, one of the major players in this chose to pick up and run, chose to leave the state and which actually I don't think is the most honest and open way to ask in this situation.
And therefore, I think it is only appropriate that we agree with this this proposal even though it does tread on new territory because the nature of the of the problem is so widespread and so forever Representative perez i think the comment that representative smith made at the hearing about the lawyer being brought all the way in from washington said a lot any other uh yes representative greeson in the notes that i scribbled for myself i have that i'm not opposed to suing the company but when you eliminate the statute of limitations it becomes very dangerous and pfas would be the only case with no statute of limitations i agree that we can modify the three years two years, three years, whatever it happens to be, but at some point in time, there does need to be a cap, an end point.
And, you know, even is there a possibility of capping the amount of damages that could be awarded?
At some point in time, you're going to have a very difficult time showing the causal relationship that that is actually what caused the injury.
If we all have these things in us, then how do we know that that's what caused whatever problem after 45 years?
So I think we run into the issues of by eliminating the statute of limitations, you just open this up beyond where reasonable limitations.
I think that we need to end it at some point.
Representative Alexander.
I happen to agree with Representative Griesen.
I think this is a really bad bill to open up the floodgates with this to unlimited amount of time.
It will completely damage business in the state, so I think we should vote against it.
All right.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, for recognizing me.
I know that I haven't, I'm not a permanent member of this committee.
I'm only a substitute.
But when we're looking at PFAS in particular, it is known as a forever chemical, because once it is ingested and is inside of our bodies it's never going to leave and the effects of these chemicals are something that can take years to develop and actually be cancer causing so to say that there should be a statute of limitations that is limited to only a handful of years as it is currently, it doesn't really make a whole lot of sense if you are going to be experiencing, you know, dealing with cancer or another sort of illness, potentially 20 years down the line when we're currently only allowed to have six years of current statute of limitations.
So I think that in terms of this, I will be supporting the bill, and I urge everybody else to as well.
Thank you.
Any other comments?
Mr.
Chair?
Yes, Representative DiLorenzo and then Representative Cusat.
I think removing the statute of limitations on PFAS is a very good idea, mainly because children born, well, if a woman gets sick from PFAS and she's pregnant, you may not know that the child has contacted cancer or another disease for many years.
So it's, and there's a precedent there because back in the 80s, 90s in Woburn, Mass., if you all remember that movie, A Civil Action with John Travolta, it was about a company that had dangerous chemicals and it went into the drinking water in that town.
It's a big story.
I forget the name of the company, but it's a real thing.
Thank you.
All right.
Representative Katab.
Thank you, and thank you for letting me speak.
I just wanted to say that the current statue is six years after the date that the plaintiff should have discovered or in the exercise of reasonable diligence or after they discovered or in the exercise of reasonable diligence should have discovered that such harm, injury, or damages and the casual relationship of an act or omission to such harm or injury of damages.
So this isn't six years from the date that you may have consumed PFAS.
This is already currently six years from the date that you realized that you had an injury.
So the date perhaps that you were diagnosed with cancer and it might not even be six years from that day.
It might not be six years until the doctor actually tells you that the reason you probably got this was because of PFAS.
It would be six years from that date.
So I think that there is already a pretty large window after you've already discovered that this is why you got what you got for that to happen.
So I just, I want to say that while I hear a lot of people saying, well, you may not discover it for a while, but the way it stands now is if you don't discover it for a while you still have six years from that date until you do actually discover it so i just wanted to point that out because i i'm not i'm wondering if representative alexander thank you and i do want to point out that there's no the standard in here there's no standard of negligence so if the business or or somebody has found out to even do it on accident like they're still open Thank you.
And I do want to point out that there's no the standard in here.
There's no standard of negligence.
So if the business or or somebody has found out to even do it on accident, like they're still open to this sort of lawsuit.
So I just caution someone if to vote for this, if if there's not even a standard of negligence involved in it.
Representative Page.
Yeah, thanks.
I thank you for recognizing me.
My understanding of PFAS is that the science continues to develop an understanding of what it is.
And while I can certainly, as someone, I can certainly understand the hesitation with respect to sort of this unlimited statute of limitations.
I think with this particular case, I'm more comfortable with it.
in terms of the causation, my sense of it is that the market will sort itself out in terms of which lawyer is going to look at this and say you've got a strong case on the causation element and be able to determine that it does seem to me that if it's any indication that some companies who have left new hampshire have a little more knowledge than than a lot of us about the effects of PFAS.
And maybe this will help folks catch up with the science as the science catches up with what diseases this causes.
So I recognize the hesitation about expanding the statute of limitations, but in this particular instance, I think it's warranted.
All right.
Any other comments?
Representative Terrell.
Yeah, just one other thought that came out of the hearing for me was the ubiquity of PFAS in the world, the thousands of chemicals that fall under the general heading, and then the fact that all of us have them in our systems in varying quantities and varying types, to me, is a reason why this group should be sort of treated separately, because even after you've been, say, told you have cancer, it may be a long time before you can work through the process of figuring out whether or not you can attach that injury to any given exposure.
And so it feels like an echoing with what Representative Page said, you know, a lot of that is still evolving and it feels as though, you know, this would be a place where leaving the window open would be better.
Although I generally do agree with the principle of, you know, from the time you discover your injury for the overall concept of that type of liability.
All right.
So I guess what I, the only thing I would say on this is, I think, I think it, I don't, I don't think that this is necessary.
and I think that it would create a really sort of bad public policy.
And the reason I say that is this.
Remember, it's the language that Representative Kutab read from the statute, and this is the law for the statute of limitations anyway.
What's called the discovery rule, which is in current law, says that your cause of action doesn't accrue.
You have to not only know that you have been harmed, but you have to know the causal relationship between the harm and the person that you're seeking to sue.
at the end.
you have been harmed, but you have to know the causal relationship between the harm and the person that you're seeking to sue.
And so, you know, for example, and that means that, you know, things can happen, like look at all the asbestos cases, all of those asbestos cases, many of those cases go back, you know, decades, 20, 30 years or something.
People are still allowed to bring or were still allowed to bring their claims because they might say, well, I knew that I had some problem and it had to do with asbestos, but I didn't realize that it was this employer or whatever that was that had made use of asbestos somehow in their facility or somehow in their manufacturing process.
So what it seems to me that if we passed this law, what we would be saying is you can be somebody who was harmed by PFAS.
And now you know that you were harmed by PFAS.
And you know that you were harmed by PFAS, and you know that, let's say it was St.
Gobin that was responsible for injecting, for exposing you to the PFAS that caused your injury, and you can still sit on your hands for the period of the regular statute of limitations.
Why does that make sense?
Why should you be able to say, it's okay for me to have that information that I just described and still wait for six years or three years, whatever the regular statute of limitations is?
Yet that would be the only practical purpose of eliminating the statute of limitations.
It would be basically to say, yeah, you can you know, you can grow or you can grow old, so to speak, with all that knowledge that that you were harmed and that that the the St.
open whatever was responsible and never bring a suit until, you know, 30 years after you knew that.
Why does that, why would we allow people to sit on their rights for that, in that circumstance?
And what kind of message does that send to, you know, to the world generally?
I mean, you know, man, it seems to me that that.
Some, you know, some people will say, well, wait a minute, this is some companies, some businesses might say, well, wait a minute, they, you know, PFAS is the is the bad guy today.
you know will I become the bad guy today, you know, will I become the bad guy next year?
And so maybe New Hampshire is not the place for me to have my business.
I don't, I mean, I don't recall, maybe somebody, maybe there was some testimony on this and I just, but is there any other state that has simply eliminated the statute of limitations for really for any?
I mean, other than murder, obviously, in criminal law, murder has always not been subject to a statute of limitations.
But aside from that in the criminal law, I don't think that we've eliminated the statute of limitations elsewhere.
Maybe I just missed the testimony.
So Chris Appel from the American Tort Reform Association stated that no state has ever done this.
So I think, I mean, I think it's really important that you understand that this is not, that would be the only thing we would be accomplishing by eliminating the statute of limitations is to say that even when you know, to be fair, it's not just know, it should know.
Even if you knew or should have known that you were harmed by PFAS and you knew or should have known that the causal relationship between that harm and the defendant, in effect, you can still just sit on your rights for the regular period of statute of limitations.
Yes, representative Howard.
Thank you.
I Have a number of concerns with people actually acting on their right to sue a contaminator In this instance because of the way that it's written for six years.
My significant other, she works in, has done research in PFAS contamination and even this summer was looking at a case where there was suspected firefighter foam that was contaminating an aquifer.
And the consulting firm that she was interning for wasn't able to make a final distinction, despite this being a several-year debate over what the contaminant was.
And it was fairly difficult for the firm to actually confirm whether it was the firefighting foam, which was kind of the main suspect, or whether it was something else.
And because of the time that that has taken for just a singular case, I just have worry that some people may interpret this as the fact that they may have been diagnosed with cancer or some other disease six years previous, but are unable to prove who was the actual contaminator in that instance, and thus would not necessarily bring forward a suit, letting the contaminator go free.
Thank you.
Yes, Representative Payton.
I'm sorry, and I have great respect for the chair.
I just want to make two points.
One, I wonder as a practical matter if, and I'm trying to put myself in this position, which fortunately I am not in, but if I had known or some knowledge of a PFAS causing cancer, which these things do, and there are thousands of them.
I'm not sure I'd sit on that right, because I'm not sure what that implication would be for me personally with my health.
The second point I would make is if the message that we send as a matter of public policy is if you're thinking about setting up business in New Hampshire, and you know what you produce harms people, stay away.
So I'm okay with that message thank you all right other comments yes representative Breeson this is an emotional bill to to great extent the the damage that has done by polluters, it's tragic.
It's perhaps criminal.
I don't know.
The damage is not questioned as far as I'm concerned.
I think that they have polluted and they've done damage, and now they want to hightail it out of here but being a person who ate lead-based paint chips that were on my crib although that was 50 years ago I've stopped since then I've used Roundup but I stopped using it about 40 years ago my family extended family chain smokers so I was around secondhand smoke for years.
I never smoked myself, but I was exposed to secondhand smoke for years.
I was in the Navy.
I was exposed to radiation as a nuke machinist mate.
I've literally been inside a reactor compartment, and not while it was actually critical because that would be deadly pretty quickly, but there is still residual radiation exposure.
I've got PFAS because I'm a human being that's alive today, so we all have it.
You know, there are just so many other environmental factors that I don't know how in the way, I don't know who to sue now, to be quite honest with you uh I'm going to die of something someday and maybe it'll be diagnosed as cancer somewhere in my body but I don't know how unless there is just definitive proof that that company dumped that crap into your drinking water and you drank it like the case down in down in Massachusetts or several other places where those of things have happened, I just don't know how in the world we can identify after so many years that that's what caused this particular illness.
And then to say the statute of limitations is infinite after that, I just don't if we if we want if we don't want polluters to come to new hampshire i agree you're not going to come set up shop i totally agree with representative page there but this bill does not do that and that's not the right way that's not that's not this is not the way to send that message other yes representative staples yeah i i agree with uh representative greeson on that because you know our our culture is just replete with chemicals and all forms and types uh it's uh the bane of modern living.
And if we take the immunity away on the PFAS, then the question will be who's next if I manufacture ammonium chloride or whatever bad stuff might be out there.
I'm going to go or I'm not going to go there um i think it's already been pointed out that blanket removal of the statute of limitations could have some far-reaching and harmful effects for the economy and even for citizens you know as a practical matter if you tell people you got six years from discovery well i better get on this if you tell people you've got six years from discovery, well, I better get on this.
If you have no limit, well, maybe I can get to it next year or I'm too busy now.
And you know, if you've got dangerous stuff in your body and it's detected, you want to take care of that sooner rather than later.
I mean, that's the basic principle of medical healing so i don't think it serves even the the culture well uh to kick it down the road to provide extra time um let it lag all right are we ready for a vote all right i'm going to ask the uh clerk to call the role the The motion is OTP by Representative Smith.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
No.
Rep.
Belling.
I'm going to ask the clerk to call the roll.
The motion is OTP by Representative Smith.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
No.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
No.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
No.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Greeson.
No.
Clerk of Tab votes no.
Rep Perez.
Rep Smith.
Rep.
Horrigan.
Yes.
Rep.
DiLorenzo.
Yes.
Rep.
Schultz.
Yes.
Rep.
Page.
i move interim study i do not want to spend time on this at the end of the summer but and I suggest a better motion might be I will move ITL first seconded by representative Wallace is there any further discussion all right then I guess we're ready for a vote Vice Chairman Vice Chairman Wallace Yes Rep Alexander Yes Rep Andrews Yes Rep Testerman Yes Rep Stapleton Yes Rep Tripp Yes Rep Greeson Yes Clerk or Tab votes Yes Rep Perez Yes Rep Smith No Rep Smith?
No.
Rep Horrigan?
Rep DeLorenzo?
No.
Rep Kenney, sorry, Rep Schultz?
Rep Page?
No.
Rep Devine?
Rep Lanza?
No.
Rep Manos?
Rep Tur?
No.
Rep Howard?
Chairman Lin?
Yes.
Motion fails 10 to 10.
All right so it'll go to the floor without recommendation the OTP motion will be heard first.
Representative Smith can I?
Is there any point?
If a motion were made, if a motion were made for interim study, not having been made by Representative Alexander, of course, could, would anyone change their vote?
Could I ask that question?
Sure, No, absolutely.
That's a fair question.
And speaking for myself, I feel less strongly about this than I did about the gun thing.
Right.
But I think honestly, to just eliminate the statute of limitations where no one, no other state has done it, I think it would be, it would be, you know, it would take- Yeah, we know how you feel, Representative.
Mr.
Chairman, I'm wondering if anybody would, on any side, would change their vote.
In other words, would we get 11 people on interim study?
That's all I want to know.
That's a fair question.
And if't i don't see anybody so fine okay so we'll go with this i was sorry i was asking to say i i could see ways to change this that would be not complete elimination sort of like what we just talked about with the gun bill um something that's not complete elimination of statute of limitations but something that modifies it for pfas to make it different than other products because of the things that i think we discussed around the table so i would be happy to we could um representative uh truer um we could have um ITL or OTPA with an amendment.
That's a possibility.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, but I mean, we'd have...
I'm confused now because if if we did interim study, doesn't that mean that we're Yeah, but interim study, we're now past interim study, because nobody was willing to change.
Well, sorry, that's what I was trying to say, was that I would support interim study versus but perhaps what you're saying is that my change would not be the change we're looking for.
Okay, sorry about that then.
So let me just ask a follow-up to Representative Smith's question.
If there was a motion of interim study, would anybody that voted against ought to pass or for ITL vote in favor of interim study?
Mr.
Chair, for arguing between ITL and interim study, it doesn't matter because I believe that it effectively does the same thing this term so i'm okay voting for whatever i just don't want to spend the fall talking about this bill that i just think isn't workable so i'm okay either you know a complete death or a slow less painful death in that case Mr.
Jiggers,'t want representative alexander to consider death in any form um it wouldn't be right um i will i will move um interim study right is there a second oh yes of course i wanted to make a comment um i mean the only way to resolve the difference would be to change the length of the statute of limitations from six years to some other number it seems to me that would be the only the only potential change so why not just do it as a subcommittee do it in two weeks and we either move forward or we don't representative so when i was looking just to see because i know that we were previously told that no other state had done this with anything except for a dozen states relative to um childhood sexual abuse i did see that there were a few other states there were six other states that had pending legislation several of them have killed the bills but there's a few that have not yet so perhaps it's worth to see what some Thank you.
there were a few other states there were six other states that had pending legislation several of them have killed the bills but there's a few that have not yet so perhaps it's worth to see what some other states are doing and get more information from it i mean i think maybe some of them will give some sort of study information out of it i don't know did someone second in the interim study.
There was a motion for an interim study.
Well, but now there's a different proposal here.
It hasn't been seconded, and there's a proposal that we not vote today on this, and we vote in two weeks.
And at that point, we could vote ITL.
We're not likely to vote OTP, or we could vote OTPA if, for example, there was an amendment that lengthened, that extended the six years to something else.
Yes, Representative Saab.
I'd be okay voting for the interim study to kind of gather more data, but I guess I'm not sure what we would learn in just a week and changing, like, the number to be higher, because I will say in looking, like, we already have the highest number of six years.
Other states typically that I found i did look quickly but i looked through many states they had two or three years so i feel like if we want to hold it and actually look at kind of a study of information that would be okay but i'm not i wouldn't i wouldn't personally change my mind between this week and next week on just changing the number of years.
Sorry, one thought on this, because I guess in my head I'm thinking there is the lengthening of the statute of limitations.
There's also sort of, I guess, what I was trying to say earlier, this sort of idea between when or why would you bring your case?
Why wouldn't you bring it as soon as you thought you had the ability to bring the case?
Because it's sooner that you'll have it decided, hopefully in your favor.
So the idea of waiting a really long time, I'm not sure.
The only reason I can think to do that is because when you decide to bring that case, you have to have confidence that you're going to be able to prevail and it feels as though with all the emerging information about PFAS you might learn things later on that make you decide okay actually that is worth my while because there's costs involved in everything so I guess that would be my only other thought is something about substantially new information that would that would change the the decision as opposed to just lengthening but all right that's so so representative smith has moved i uh interim study is there a second i'll second that all right all right moved by um representative smith and seconded by Representative Alexander.
All right, any further discussion?
All right, I guess we're ready to call the roll then.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
No.
Rep Alexander.
Yes.
Rep Andrews.
No.
Rep Testerman.
Rep Stapleton.
No.
Rep Tripp.
Rep Stapleton.
No.
Rep Tripp.
Yes.
Rep Greeson.
Clerk Kutab votes yes.
Rep Perez.
Rep Smith.
Rep Horrigan.
Yes.
Rep DiLorenzo.
Rep Schultz?
Yes.
Rep Page?
Rep Devine?
Yes.
Rep Lanza?
Rep Manos?
Yes.
Rep Tur?
Rep Howard?
Yes.
Chairman Lynn?
No.
Motion passes 14 to 6.
14 to 6.
All right.
So, so now, so we will go then with interim study.
Is that correct?
Because the other one, that's the only motion that passed.
So, all right.
So, so we know, we know one person that's not going to work on interim study.
I think Representative Smith is probably a great person to write the majority report and chair the committee.
Sounds like a great committee for you to chair in the fall.
All right.
So Representative Smith, you will write.
Well, do we do a report now with interim study now?
Do we do a report?
Yes.
For the second year, it has to go.
Do you want to do a minority report for ITO?
No, no, no.
That's fine.
All right.
So Representative Smith will write the report.
So we're now on to the last express my appreciation to representative all right so now we're on to the last bill that we have to deal with today and And that is 1104.
Hang on one second.
No, that's 1004.
Let me get to 1104.
Okay.
So 1104.
So 1104, and I'm going to recognize myself to move.
I'm going to move amendment 0707H.
Is there a second?
Second by Representative Wallace.
And I guess what I just mentioned, I think I may have mentioned that in my testimony on this bill, the only real change made in this amendment is that, as I said before, this is kind of inside baseball for procedural issues for lawyers.
The original bill basically said that if the administrative judge or the chief judge to which one of these motions was made, that that judge's ruling would be final and not subject to appeal.
So, as I thought more about, I mean, that, the interest, that, whenever you make something not subject to appeal, I mean, one advantage of that is you, it makes it, you get, you can, you know, move the case more quickly.
But there's a, that's at a cost of some fairness.
And the more I thought about it, the more I thought, even though I think there is an interest in moving particularly marital cases where I think this often comes up, there is an interest in moving them along.
The fairness issue is also important.
So I changed it to say that the decision by the chief justice or the administrative judge is appealable, but it's appealable in this way.
If the judge to which the claim that an earlier judge who's been found to have committed misconduct, If the person claims that judge is ruling that judge's misconduct implicated my case in which out where I was harmed so the case now gets referred to the under the statute the case gets referred to the chief justice let's say of the of the Superior Court as I'm just an example if that judge finds that there is a reasonable likelihood that the judge's misconduct may have affected the decision in that litigant's case, then the judge will, the chief judge will, excuse me, will assign the case to another judge.
What this says is that ruling by the chief judge assigning the case, finding that there was a reasonable likelihood that misconduct affected the decision, cannot be appealed immediately.
In other words, because it is what is referred to as an interlocutory order the case is really not over so the judge the what this says is that the chief judge refers the case now to a new judge to to you know to look at this at this issue again and and perhaps to look at the underlying issue in, let's say, the divorce case again, that judge will then make a decision, and that decision can be appealed to the Supreme Court as part of that decision if the person who thought that the chief judge made a mistake in sending it to a new judge in the first place, if that litigant can raise that issue in the appeal from the new judge's order.
So the issue still can be decided.
It just can't be decided immediately.
That's what this language says.
And I know this, I see eyes glazing over here, okay?
But this can be important.
On the other hand, if the chief judge says, no, there is no connection between the misconduct of the judicial officer and the ruling in your case, so I'm dismissing your claim under this statute.
That is a final rule because that means the case, your case is over.
So that ruling can be appealed immediately because it's a final order.
That's, as I said, the lawyers in the room will kind of understand this, but the everybody else will have trouble with it.
But it is important.
It's 707.
0707H.
Representative Greason.
In the testimony that we heard, I picked up on a concern by some of those who are in, I guess they would be in favor of this bill.
I'm not sure exactly.
Some of them were a little confusing.
but there's there was the issue that they brought up was that they would get an unfavorable ruling, and they believed that that ruling was prejudiced by some misconduct.
And so the appeal would go to an administrative judge whom they have said was actually equally as corrupt or compromised as the original ruling judge.
And so what happens in that case if the administrative judge  they specifically mentioned the administrative judge  was what do you do in a case like that?
Who do you appeal to then if you believe that you're not even  because it says here in the language that the administrative judge shall determine with or without hearing whether there is reasonable likelihood that the misconduct of the judicial officer had a causal bearing on the challenged ruling decision or judgment.
And so you're going to take a prejudiced judgment, take it to a prejudiced judge for another hearing.
So where do you go after that when it's that intermediate step that's prejudiced as well?
Right.
Well, you know what?
Representative Terrer had raised that question with me earlier.
Actually, there is, if you read starting on the amendment on line six, if the judicial officer found to have committed misconduct is the chief justice of the Supreme Court, the chief justice of the Superior Court, or the administrative judge of the circuit court, the petition shall be filed with the most senior associate justice of the court in question.
So if the claim is that the boss, the chief justice, was somehow involved and was either committed to misconduct or was somehow involved in it, then you don't have to file with the chief justice was somehow involved in, was either committed to misconduct or was somehow involved in it, then you don't have to file with the chief justice, you file with the next senior judge.
And that's kind of the way, you know, there are other things in the, I think it's RSA 490 that deal with the same kind of thing.
If there's a basis for recusal for other reasons, it can go to the next most senior.
that that i think that that deals with that issue other representative manos thank you um i have a question on line 16 through 18 or 19.
okay um if there's a determination of a reasonable likelihood that the misconduct did have a causal bearing on the ruling, blah, blah, the justice shall vacate the ruling decision or judgment and remand the matter for rehearing before a judicial officer.
What I'm wondering about is wouldn't that leave the case, and they are typically domestic relations cases, but it doesn't matter, wouldn't that leave the case in the posture of having no order for some interim period of time until there could be a rehearing?
And I would be concerned about that.
Well, you know, but that's, I mean, in some sense, that's no different than any other reversal.
If the Supreme Court reverses, you know, an order in a marital case, there's no order.
There's no order in place until, you know, there's a new hearing.
So it's, I mean, in some sense, yes.
I suppose if the, you know, if there was some need for immediate relief after the reversal, I suppose one of the parties could go to the new judge and say, look, I need an emergency order for dealing with child support or something like that.
But I don't think that in that sense that's any different than any other reversal.
Right.
But I was going to say, if it's something like child support or visitation or joint custody decision making or residential placement of a child, you're leaving it in limbo where people need to live their immediate lives.
It's not like a case with, you know, damages X number of dollars or, you know, there are cases that people can live with a remand.
But these aren't typically those cases.
So I'm just I'm concerned about that.
Yeah, I mean, I you know, I hear what you're saying.
I guess I'm just not I don't see how that how in this case, in this situation, it's any than any in other words if Put aside judicial misconduct suppose that there's a judge issues a decision on child custody saying, you know This party gets the child That has primary custody and and the other party has the visitation every other weekend and weekend.
And the claim is that that was a wrong decision and the Supreme Court agrees.
And they vacate the decision and remand it.
The Supreme Court will not say, you know, this is what you should do.
They'll just say what you did was wrong.
And now, and so there will be some period of time before, you know, this is what you should do.
They'll just say you what you did was wrong.
And now, and so there will be some period of time before, you know, a new order can be entered.
I just don't see any, any way around that really.
If I may, I think, I think it could be changed to say that the ruling would not be, would be remanded, but not vacated.
And therefore the order that is complained about or said to have been influenced would stay in place until until there's a rehearing on the remand.
There's no reason to say that's to the beginning.
I'm sure I'm terrible they're not.
There's a determination, if there's a determination if there's a determination just hate the ruling decision or judgment remand um yeah they haven't heard the argument right so so how we know the decision's flawed sure well shell i guess i'm i mean i you know i i guess the thing i the the problem i have here is that i i still don't see how that would be any different than any.
In other words, if the, you know, put aside the misconduct situation.
Put aside this.
A trial judge makes a decision, and it goes to the Supreme Court, and they say wrong.
You know, they, I mean, it would be pretty unusual, I think.
I'm not saying it would never happen, but it would be pretty unusual for the court, for the Supreme Court to say reversed, but the original incorrect order remains in effect until there's another hearing.
I don't I think that would be pretty unusual to do that.
And so I wouldn't think of, you know, of a reason for doing that here.
So anyway.
All right.
So I know it's going back to the motion.
So is anybody else have anything to say on the amendment?
If not, are we ready for a vote?
And I think we might be able to do that for a show of hands are those in favor of the amendment if you'd raise your hand um any opposed all right so it looks like it's uh 20 to 19 19 i'm sorry 19 to 0.
uh all right hang on one second who second was that represent wallace two seconds yes okay um right i do i yes i 19.
oh all right and then on the uh on the main bill i would move uh otpa is there a second, all right.
And then on the main bill, I would move OTPA.
Is there a second?
Second.
All right.
Any further discussion on the bill as amended?
Then are we ready to call the roll?
All right.
I'd ask Representative Katop to call the roll.
Vice Chairman Wallace.
Yes.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
Yes.
Rep Alexander.
Rep Andrews.
Yes.
Rep Stapleton.
Rep Tripp.
Yes.
Rep Greeson.
Clerk of Tab votes yes.
Rep Perez.
Yes.
Rep Smith.
Rep Horrigan.
Yes.
Rep DeLorenzo.
Rep Schultz.
Yes.
Rep Page.
Rep Devine.
Yes.
Rep Lanza.
Rep Manos.
Yes.
Rep Turrer.
Rep Howard.
Yes.
Chairman Lynn.
Motion passes 19 to 0.
All right.
Any reason that this cannot go on consent?
Representative Lynn?
Yes.
It looks like we're going to have 10 bills on March 6th.
It's the week before town meetings.
I know I have tons of meetings and stuff.
Is there any possibility that we can move it to start at 9 a.m.?
So, I mean, I meeting at 5 o'clock and it has taken us three hours to get through four bills here.
All right so wait you know what hang on I will write I will just let me go back to 1104 let me go back to 1104 I will write the report since it's my bill.
So you know what?
Here's that.
You know, I'm I.
I was originally scheduling everything at nine o'clock and I got some pushback from people, which I understood that saying that they it made a real problem So let's push it back to 10.
My inclination, Representative Perez, is to do this.
I know we will have a lot of bills on for the 6th, but that will not be our drop-dead date to get bills done.
So I would prefer to start at 10 o'clock.
Hopefully we get through all the bills.
it starts to get late and then you know and it and it's uh it looks like we're going to be going until you know five o'clock that day starting at 10 maybe we'll just sort of re we'll we'll stop and and uh move on and do the you know do the following wednesday to finish up whatever we have to do that would be be my suggestion.
Well, what time will you have to do that would be my suggestion well what what time will you have to leave oh no no that's fine so so you know i i i can't imagine that we i'm sorry representative paris do you know why we are here so late today?
Yeah.
We could have voted on it today and then we win again.
Yeah, I mean, that's not really a fair criticism of Representative Perez, because we've talked about the same bill three times and have not voted once yet.
So, that's right.
And I don't think I would have taken much time.
The Democrats are planning a caucus until nine o'clock in the morning on the 6th without anything else.
And we're not going to meet on Sunday or Monday or Tuesday of that week.
So I would have some real problems if we started at 9.
Yeah, it would be really difficult for me to start at 9.
I'd rather add in another day than start at 9 if that's the alternative.
I think all of us can use some restraint in how long we go on.
And I put myself on that list.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to, just so everybody knows, what I'm going to do, I will sometime probably tomorrow or Friday, I will ask Karen to do an amended notice that will put on for executive session on March 6th all of our remaining bills.
I suspect that we may not get through all of them on that day.
And once we don't, then we will have a continued executive session the following Wednesday.
But we will start at 10 a.m.
on both those days.
And just Representative Perez, just so I know that you were very concerned about this, the first bill we will take up on March 6th is 1283.
We will do that first at 10 o'clock.
I think we've had, you know, people will have plenty of time to have considered the amendment.
They will also consider your amendment.
And we should be, you know, we'll have a continuing debate on the bill.
I know that there are strong feelings on both sides.
we'll have a we'll have a a continuing debate on the bill I know that there will there are strong feelings on both sides and we'll have a vote and and then we'll move on to the other bills right yeah no no I hear you And I think we should.
Yeah, I guess the only question, I mean, the only thing I guess I would say, Representative Perez, is it's the, your arguments might have been stronger, I guess I would say, if you were saying, and if you make, let's make this change and then that will make it an acceptable bill.
But if I understood correctly, maybe I misunderstood you.
My understanding from what you had said the meeting before was it was really nothing.
If we did everything that you pointed out as a criticism.
I never said that.
I was telling you the fact that this was a bad bill.
I was not going after the intent.
I have always said this.
I have always said that it's a bad bill and that it was the intent had nothing to do with it.
No, no, I'm not talking about the intent.
What I'm saying is, if I understood correctly, you were saying that, not that people had bad intent, but that there was nothing, that there were no amendments that could be made that would make you support the bill.
And so I guess the point that I have some difficulty with is if there's, you know, when you say, well, they, you know, they don't have to, nobody has to witness the person taking the medication.
I hadn't heard you say, well, and if you put that in, you know, and you do all the other things, I'll vote for the bill.
That could persuade me.
So I'm, you know, that I'm not saying you don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying you didn't have the right to make your argument.
I'm not saying that at all.
That's fine.
But I do.
But I but I do.
I'm in terms of the persuasiveness of your arguments.
If you know when your position is there's nothing you can do well I thought you I thought pretty clearly you did say that uh that that's the position okay all right and representative French to that end I have the same opinion that based on you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, you all right and representative brett to that end i have the same opinion that based on your statements to me that no matter what we did you wouldn't support the talk and and that's that's and if i was mistaken by understanding that i apologize but in my situation when i'm of that when i have a bill that there's nothing that's going to fit for me i just sit here i don't do anything and i vote against the bill that's and i just learned that over the years being up here.
And I understand that.
No, speak your mind.
We want to hear it.
Because you brought up, you pointed out some things that I have questions on, too.
Yeah, I pointed out a lot of very valuable, valuable things.
Sure.
Oh, that's not in dispute.
Going together?
We're not going together.
I think we are.
So anyway, everybody have a nice two weeks, and I'll see you on the 6th.
We'll see you tomorrow morning.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, yes.
I'm sorry.
I will see you tomorrow morning and tomorrow night.
Yes, that's right.
How could I have forgotten that?
How could I have forgotten that.